Lass mich raten, du bist jetzt Cabrio-Fahrer.
Nein, ich könnte aber einer sein. Nein, ich bin eigentlich ganz gegen Cabrio-Fahren,
denn das würde ja die Frisur kaputt machen, auf die ich viel Wert lege.
Und weil ich so viel Wert darauf lege, habe ich mir gedacht,
es wäre doch jetzt gerade ein guter Zeitpunkt, um mal die Geheimratsecken auffüllen zu lassen.
Das heißt, ich habe mich einer Haartransplantation unterzogen,
nicht in der Türkei, das werden jetzt alle direkt fragen, sondern in Deutschland,
da kann man das auch machen.
Ich habe auch nichts dagegen, dass man das in der Türkei macht,
nur für mich war es einfacher und sinnvoller es vor Ort quasi zu machen und
ich kann sagen, dass das doch ein ziemlich harter Eingriff ist.
Das merkt man dann, wenn man in den Folgetagen ein sehr geschwollenes Gesicht
hat, ein bisschen so aussieht, als wäre man das Ding aus einer anderen Welt.
Aber ja, es geht alles wieder besser jetzt.
Du willst nicht darüber weinen, Vorfreude wecken, bald ziehst du die Kappe ab.
Es ist ja leid, dass man sich selbst antut, aber man hatte mich auch sofort,
also ich war in einer Klinik zum Vorgespräch, kam dort an, nahm Platz und der Herr,
der Co-Leiter dieser Klinik sah mich an und sagte, Herr Schmidt,
Sie sehen aus wie ein Mann, der das Leben genießt.
Und ich sagte ja und damit hatte er mich sofort.
Aber das mit der Kappe ist jetzt wirklich etwas unglücklich für mich.
Ich habe nie Kappe getragen, finde es auch gar nicht so angenehm,
das dauert auf dem Kopf zu halten.
Ich merke ja auch schon, der April, der noch ist, aber der Klimawandel,
der auch ist, macht es warm.
Du trägst sie gerade aus Solidarität. Ich bin gestern durch Koblenz spazieren gegangen,
an einem Seniorenheim kam ich vorbei, dort haben Kinder ihre uralte Mutter im
Rollstuhl rausgeschoben, ich ging dort im blauen Anzug mit blauer Kappe vorbei
und diese Dame sagte, ah, ein Reitersmann.
Siehste, ja, du wirst erkannt. Ich will nur einen kurzen Bogenschlag machen, ich war...
In Thüringen im April, in Weimar und bin da durchs Bauhaus gelaufen. Ja.
Und da du ja jetzt ein neuer Mensch wirst, möchte ich alle aufrufen,
es mir doch nochmal gleich zu tun, bevor Thüringen, wir wissen ja nicht genau,
was passiert, 1. September Stichtag.
Aber das Bauhausmuseum hat naturgemäß eine Bauhausausstellung,
in der diese ganzen Arbeiten, aber auch Denkanregungen von Walter Grobius nochmal. mal.
Und die passen wie die Faust aufs Auge in diesem künstlichen Intelligenzzeitalter.
Ja.
Damals kam die roboterhafte Maschine und man sagte der neue Mensch.
Und es war noch unklar, meinen wir eigentlich uns, die wir uns jetzt anpassen
müssen, ans Roboterzeitalter? Oder sind einfach die Maschinen die neuen Menschen?
Genau wie heute. Also heute noch viel mehr eigentlich. Man müsste das alles
noch mal in den Kochtopf werfen und auf 100 stellen und noch mal gucken,
was da so an Ideen rausdünstet.
Große Einladung für alle, die in der Nähe sind.
Schaut euch noch mal im Bauhaus um. Scheint mir erstrebens- und lohnenswert zu sein, diese Besuche.
Ja, ich war vor vielen Jahren da und es war sehr eindrücklich.
So, damit kommen wir zum April. Oder ist schon Mai. Wir machen heute mal was
Kleinexperimentelles.
Und zwar, wir haben ja Martin Hecklund gelesen, der uns die Zeit nochmal mit
ihrem Eigenwert aufschlüsselte,
weshalb wir das jetzt einfach aufgreifen und mal einen roten Faden Zeitgeist zu Anfang spinnen,
denn ich möchte auch eine Argumentation verändern,
die ich sehr lange, sehr konsistent durchgehalten habe, aber die einer Änderung bedarf.
Und das lässt sich natürlich nur über die Zeit erklären,
denn manchmal habe ich ja gesagt, Trump wird gewählt und dann Trump wird nicht
gewählt und der Unterschied zwischen er gewinnt seine Wiederwahl nicht und ich
sage, jetzt wird er gewählt, ist natürlich einfach nur durch die Zeit zu erklären.
Es ist etwas passiert in den letzten Jahren, in diesen Jahren und es wird demnach anders passieren.
Nun habe ich sehr viele YouTube-Kommentare immer bekommen, die dann irgendwie
kommen mit, plötzlich wird er inkonsistent und ich sage, nein,
wir müssen auf diese Inkonsistenzen anders Rücksicht nehmen,
wenn sie mit dem Thema Zeit verplausibilisiert werden.
Was eben auch bedeutet, wenn ich jetzt sage, seit 2017 habe ich immer gesagt,
alle AfD-Wähler sind ausnahmslos Nazis. Mit dem Argument...
Mich interessiert ja nicht, was sie wirklich denken oder ihre Intention,
sondern ich sehe nur die Resultate, vergleiche historisch und sage,
ja Mitläufer oder nicht, ist dann auch egal.
Am Ende ist unterm Strich zählt, was Hitler will und so.
Und jetzt droht Höcke. Und ich möchte aber jetzt vorbereiten,
dass ab jetzt, obwohl es so driftig ist gerade, also niemand sagt heute mehr
irgendwas von Protestwählern oder behauptet, na der hat ja nicht gewusst,
was die AfD für eine Partei ist.
Und jetzt fängst du damit an?
Genau, und gerade in diesem Zeitgeist fange ich jetzt an und sage,
es sind nicht alle, Klammer auf, potenziellen AfD-Wähler, Nazis.
Überzeugte oder eben nicht überzeugte, mitlaufende Neonazis,
die einfach so im Zeitgeist treu bleiben.
Und wir hatten Zahlen dazu, die ich gleich später nenne. Erst möchte ich kurz umreißen.
Du leitest das also jetzt her? Genau. Wie diese Kursänderung?
Wir hatten ja diese Jugendstudienzahlen und so weiter, das war ja Hurelmann
und Co., die haben ja bisher die Shell-Jugendstudie gemacht.
Viele junge Leute sind bereit, die AfD zu wählen.
Genau, überraschend.
Da stellt sich ja die Frage, sind das schon waschechte Nazis?
Also das wäre ja die Frage, die dann unter diesem Gesichtspunkt zu stellen wäre.
Oder was passiert da eigentlich, dass die die jetzt wählen wollen,
wo sie Erstwähler sind und gleich sagen, ich gehe in die Vollen?
Genau. Also wenn so eine Zahl kommt, wie über 25% wollen jetzt irgendwie Neonazis
wählen, von denen wir nun wirklich sagen, also jeder weiß Bescheid und so,
die werden da beobachtet, das wird thematisiert, das ist überall Thema.
Thema, wieso gibt es trotzdem plausible Erklärungen, die uns das einfach verstehen
lassen, ohne dass wir gleich sagen, nee, da muss man es auch auf jeden Fall
und die Bildung und hier und da und die Kompetenzfragen, die da alle dran gehen.
Und wir leiten das mal aus zwei Richtungen her und die sind sozusagen illustrativ,
zeigen aber, was so passieren kann, wenn man nicht aufpasst und das eine ist,
Vier Jahre sind es jetzt, seit die Corona-Pandemie begann.
Ich sage mal so, jetzt ist April, jetzt vor vier Jahren war gerade Lockdown
und in diesen ersten Lockdown sind wir ja reingeschlittert, das hat ja Christian
Drosten selbst in seinem Corona-Update damals erklärt.
Er war bei einer politischen Veranstaltung, bei der er als Berater gebucht war
und sagte dort, kurz bevor er den Raum verließ, er stand schon und wollte schon
gehen, so ungefähr schildert er es und sagt dann nochmal,
ja die Schulen in Heinsberg zu schließen war keine schlechte Idee.
Einfach nur als Anmerkung. Keiner hatte eine Ahnung von irgendwas.
Er als Virologe auch nicht.
Das Virus war eigentlich noch gar nicht richtig hier, aber es gab diese Faschingssitzung,
die mit entsprechenden Nachwirkungen.
Also sagte er, das dort zu machen war keine schlechte Idee. Und dann hat er
zu Hause Fernsehen geguckt.
Diese Runde, die er verlassen hatte, Stunden zuvor, für den bundesweiten Zustand Schulschließung.
Einfach. Also im Sinne von wir haben gerade Osterferien, wir machen sie nicht wieder auf.
So. So, und das sei damit mal noch irgendwie hingenommen als,
ja, ja, Vorsichtsmaßnahmen unter Zeitbedingungen, hier ist Eile und so geboten, mach mal das mal.
Aber zweiter Lockdown im Dezember 2020 wird hier mal beschrieben von Richard
David Brecht und Markus Lanz in deren Podcast Ausgabe 135.
Und kein Wunder, dass er bei der letzten PISA-Studie so schlecht abgeschnitten
hat. So, genau. Also am 4.
Dezember 2020 analysiert ein Krisenstab beim RKI die Lage im Ausland und kommt
für Deutschland zum Schluss, und das ist schon brisant,
dass an Schulen das Infektionsgeschehen nicht maßgeblich vorangetrieben wird.
Dann gibt es ein Sitzungsprotokoll vom 9.
Dezember, also ein paar Tage später. Da steht Ähnliches drin.
Da heißt es wörtlich, dass der Ausmaß der Kontaktbeschränkungen reicht nicht
aus, um die hohen Fallzahlen einzudämmen.
Dazu müssten unter anderem auch Schulen geschlossen werden.
Aber daraufhin folgt dann die Anmerkung, Schulen sind nicht das Mittel,
um die Pandemie einzudämmen.
Das zeigen auch andere Länder.
Vier Tage später, Bund-Länder-Gipfel unter der Leitung von Angela Merkel.
Präsenzpflicht an Schulen wird ausgesetzt und diese seien, Zitat,
grundsätzlich zu schließen.
Aber sag mal, die Brisanz, die kommt ja jetzt nicht daher, also das RKI hat
ja dann offensichtlich gesagt, ist keine besonders gute Idee mit den Schulschließungen.
Da haben wir keine hohe Evidenz, dass das sinnvoll ist und so weiter.
Und dann hat die Politik sich offensichtlich darüber hinweggesetzt.
Sie haben etwas gemacht gegen die Empfehlung des RKI. Das spricht ja jetzt in
diesem Fall nicht gegen das Robert-Koch-Institut, sondern gegen Politiker,
die gesagt haben, egal was sie sagen, wir machen das trotzdem.
Also diese Entscheidungsherleitung wieder besseren Wissens ist auch einfach
eine Lüge, die der Öffentlichkeit anders verkauft wurde.
Also man wusste Bescheid, es hilft nicht viel.
Schlimmer finde ich noch, dass man wohl wissend, wie die Auswirkungen eines
Schullockdowns sind vom ersten, das hier gar nicht mit einpreiste.
Ja, das ist etwas, was mich direkt zu etwas bringt, was ich eigentlich später sagen wollte.
Wir sind ja nicht aufeinander abgesprochen, wir sagen ja nur kurz vorher,
was wir so grob vorhaben. Und zwar hatte ich da ein Interview gelesen im Spiegel
mit der Vorsitzenden des Ethikrats, Lena Büx, uns allen wohl bekannt.
Und sie wird dann gefragt, gibt es denn auch irgendetwas, was man nicht richtig gemacht hat?
Und dann sagt sie, der Ethikrat hat sich viel zu spät intensiver mit den Kindern
und Jugendlichen befasst.
Und das sei ein Fehler. Und man denkt sich, wie kann denn das überhaupt passieren,
dass man sich damit nicht beschäftigt.
Sie wird dann auch auf die Schulschließungen angesprochen, sagt sie,
dass die Jungen schwer gelitten haben, steht außer Frage.
Aber auch da sind falsche Narrative unterwegs.
Die längste Unterrichtseinschränkung, die es gab, dauerte 184 Tage.
Nicht in allen Bundesländern. Und das ist viel keine Frage.
Gleichzeitig muss man sagen, in der Zeit gab es Notbetreuung,
die zum Teil mit 50 bis 60 Prozent besetzt war. je nach Region.
Und in Schweden, wo es kaum Schulschließungen gab, sind die Jungen psychisch
genauso schwer betroffen.
Letzteres kann ich jetzt nicht beurteilen. Wir lassen das mal so stehen.
Ich habe sie dann in einem Deutschlandfunk-Interview gehört.
Sollen wir jetzt ein bisschen hin und her springen?
Und wir bekommen nämlich gleich mal globale Zahlen geliefert und die sind so
verrückt, dass man es sich ja gar nicht vorstellen kann.
Und zwar hören wir mal kurz, im Deutschlandfunk wird Alena Büx auch angesprochen
auf die Schulschließungen.
Und dass die Folgen so heftig waren, dass sie vielleicht nicht mehr im Verhältnis
standen zum Gesundheitsschutz. Es gab unterschiedliche Schulschließungen für
unterschiedliche Altersgruppen.
Das war unterschiedlich in unterschiedlichen Bundesländern.
Es gab Notbetreuung und so weiter und so fort.
Also ich finde es fast läppisch, wenn man sagt, die Schulschließung,
das ist bei ganz vielen Maßnahmen so der Lockdown.
Das war das nicht. Also wenn man das wirklich aufarbeiten möchte,
dann muss man das sorgfältig und ordentlich tun und muss sich genau den Kontext
angucken, muss sich genau die Situation angucken, muss sich genau angucken,
wie war eine Maßnahme, etwa eine bestimmte Schulschließung und dann schauen,
hätte man die mit dem Wissen von damals schon früher aufheben können.
Das halte ich für wirklich sinnvoll.
Also ich kann mich erinnern, dass es bestimmte Schließungen gab bei den Kitas,
wo die Kleinen wirklich ganz besonders betroffen waren.
Das ist so ein Kandidat, also da würde man wahrscheinlich bei so einer Untersuchung
zum Schluss kommen, das hätte man früher aufheben können.
So, wir belassen es mal bei Corona bei diesem Clip. Den Rest hören wir später,
weil das, was sie hier sagt, darauf kommt es mehr an.
Weil sie ja gerade meinte, nee, jetzt nicht pauschal einfach der Lockdown sagen,
sondern hier muss man jetzt differenzieren. Und ich würde sagen,
ja, man kann jetzt hier differenzieren, aber das hilft niemandem weiter.
Denn die Grundstimmung nach, also vier Jahren danach, ist einfach,
und das kennt jetzt jeder, vielleicht lohnt es sich jetzt hier,
das sozusagen über Bande zu argumentieren, in privaten Beziehungen.
Beispielsweise Eltern mit ihren Kindern.
Haben manchmal Eltern Anliegen, die sie ihren Kindern versuchen, so unter zu jubeln.
Man wird da nicht direkt angesprochen, sondern es werden so Themen vermieden,
schlechtes Gewissen, ausgeblendet, wie auch immer.
Und dann kriegt man so ein paar Tage, Wochen später mit, nee,
es schlägt sich doch durch irgendwie.
Dass da was im Argen liegt, etwas bewusst nicht angesprochen wird.
Bei Kindern wird das ja sofort angesprochen, wenn das Kind so kommt und dann
so, nee, ich will's nicht sagen und nee, ist nichts passiert und überhaupt und
so. dann werden alle Eltern hellhörig.
Wenn die Eltern das machen, können die Kinder nichts dagegen tun,
weil sie sind den Eltern unterlegen. Und genau so eine Situation haben wir hier.
Also es lohnt jetzt nicht, und ich will ja darauf, warum die jetzt alle AfD
wählen, dass wir jetzt einfach sagen,
ah ja gut, dann müssen wir jetzt mal aufarbeiten oder so, sondern nein,
wir schleppen seit zwei, drei Jahren so ein ganz schlechtes Gewissen mit uns
mit und wollen das auch gar nicht aufarbeiten, thematisieren,
in die Details schauen, wie auch immer, weil wir genau wissen, das wird ganz düster.
Also wenn wir uns das angucken, was da abgelaufen ist,
dann wird es ganz düster und die ganzen psychischen Folgeeffekte und so weiter,
die sehen wir ja bis hin zur Kriminalstatistik, falls wir da heute noch zukommen,
also es ist einfach überall präsent und jetzt braucht man also,
so wie man damals den Lockdown einfach allen Schulen schlug,
also grundsätzlich zu schließen,
das war die Anweisung, nicht irgendwie detailmäßig, wenn so das und das,
sondern einfach grundsätzlich zu schließen.
Genauso könnte jetzt auch eine Antwort aussehen, dass man einfach grundsätzlich
jetzt mal allen Kindern hilft und nicht irgendwie sich in Details verliert mit,
ja aber dann bezahlen wir ja auch von den Anwälten die Kinder mit oder was auch
immer mit irgendwelchen Hilfspaketen und der ganze Kram.
Sollen wir, bevor du, ich finde deine Argumentation sehr schlüssig und ich bin
sehr gespannt, was jetzt kommt, aber lass mich diese vier Clips bringen,
dass wir wissen, was man eigentlich fordern könnte, weil du hast die Forderung
jetzt schon gebracht, also eigentlich muss man grundsätzlich an die Kinder.
Gut, aber wir behalten den roten Haken.
Die Idee ist eigentlich die Zeit.
Genau, das Problem ist.
Und die Zeit bringen wir jetzt mal noch auf mehr Daten. Wir hören uns noch einen
Vorschlag an von Alena Büx, wie man das vielleicht lösen könnte.
Und dann überlegen wir, ob das was ist.
Könnte sein, dass mich das jetzt derailed, wenn ich Alena Büx noch mehr höre.
Möglicherweise.
Einer der Aspekte bei diesem Aufarbeiten, Lernen, Heilen ist,
Ist eben auch, dass es nicht nur um diesen engen Blick auf einzelne Maßnahmen
und einzelne Entscheidungen geht, sondern es geht auch darum,
anzuerkennen, wie grässlich das alles war, wie viel wir alle verloren haben,
was wir für eine Angst hatten, wie wir getrauert haben, wie grässlich das einfach war.
Wenn man diese emotionale Seite, diese Angst, diese tiefe Betroffenheit,
wenn die so ein bisschen ignoriert wird, weggewedelt wird, nicht berücksichtigt
wird, das ist für eine Gesellschaft ganz schlecht.
Und ich glaube, da müsste man was tun. Da bräuchte man symbolische Dinge, da muss man innehalten,
da kann man irgendwelche, ich bin nicht diejenige, die da jetzt Expertin ist,
was man da alles machen kann, aber es gibt viele, viele Beispiele von Innehalten,
von so ein bisschen Gedenken, einfach ein symbolisches, was Versöhnendes,
was Verstehendes. ist. Ich glaube, da bräuchten wir mehr.
Ja, ganz schlimm. Also ich bin kurz vor dem Derailing. Jetzt nochmal großes
Balkon klatschen, braucht niemand.
Ja, ich bringe dich da auch nachher alles, ich bringe dich total wieder aufs Gleis.
Ich will nur ganz deutlich sagen, mit Symbolischem kommt man gerade hier nicht
weiter und wir brauchen nicht noch einen zweiten Veteranentag jetzt für die Corona-Leute.
Jetzt keine Geste. Gefehlt hat Geld und Geselligkeit, keine Gesten.
Du sprichst es an. Wer kann uns was über Geld sagen?
Adam Tooze. Adam Tooze hat in vier Episoden Corona-Revue passieren lassen und
wir hören jetzt nur einen Teil davon zum Thema Schul-Lockdowns.
Die Perspektive von Schul-Lockdowns, das war eine der größten kontroversen Polizisten,
die in Bezug auf die Pandemie gestaltet wurde.
Ich bin interessiert, ob das zu einem meckern und vielleicht zu einem langwierigen
Verlust im globalen Menschenkapital führt.
Ja, also where the economists estimate that the really most severe impact is going to come.
There's been truly staggering numbers compiled by the World Bank.
I'm just going to reel some of these off because they're kind of mind-blowing.
Also I Euro, den man in einen Schüler oder eine Schülerin investiert.
Dadurch, dass die Schulzeit, sagen wir mal grob, so 10, 11 Jahre ist und danach
aber 40, 50 Jahre Berufstätigkeit anschließen, rentiert sich siebenfach.
Wenn man den nicht investiert, hat man halt genau so einen nicht erwirtschafteten,
und wir wollen ja immer Wachstum und so weiter.
Schon Stagnation ist hier ein Verlust und wenn man das Vorzeichen umdrehen von
solchen Entwicklungen, erst recht. Er nennt jetzt keine Zahlen.
Jetzt kommen sie.
In March 2020 schools closed in 180 countries around the world.
That's practically all of the countries of any size, 180 countries.
A year later, in March 2021, 12 months on, schools were either partially or
fully closed in 94 countries around the world.
So overall, 1.3 billion children in low- and middle-income countries missed
at least half a year of school.
960 million missed at least a full year.
711 million missed a year and a half or more of education. Vielen Dank.
Und in den latinamerikanischen und karibischen Regionen in Südasien sind die
Schulabschlüsse für unglaublich lange Zeit weitergegangen.
440 Tage auf dem Trott in Uganda, 326 Tage in Saudi-Arabien,
510 Tage in den Philippinen.
Also haben die Kinder im Grunde genommen von der formalen Bildung für ein Jahr
oder mehr auf einer absolut gigantischen Scale ausgelöst.
Was hat das gekostet?
And the impact of this is measurable in studies which are now being done in
places as far apart as Bangladesh and Brazil,
where there are huge deficits in the development of preschool age kids and also
school age kids in the development towards language and literacy and towards
in their mathematical capacities.
Und diese sind Defizite im frühen Kindheitsentwicklung, die extrem unwahrscheinlich
sind, an einer späteren Stelle zu entwickeln.
Die Auswirkungen davon für ihre
Jobmarkt-Prospekte auf der Linie sind wirklich, das Wort ist staggern.
Die Weltbank bezeichnet, dass global eine Generation von Studenten verloren
hat und wirklich nur über dieses
Nummer stürzt, 21 Trillionen Dollar in potenziellen Lebenserhöhungen.
21 Trillionen Dollar. ist.
21 Billionen Dollar, das ist vergleichbar mit der Hälfte der Gesamtkosten der
Klimawandelschäden bis 2049 in diesem neuen Nature-Text, den wir dann im Salon
lesen werden. Das ist ein halber Klimawandel.
Und wir wissen ja, wir würden den Klimawandel diskutieren, zu Recht.
Ja. Und das hier ist ein völlig ausgespartes Thema.
Ja, folglich diese Forderung sagt jetzt, also wir können ja mal kurz überlegen,
wird Adam Toos jetzt sagen, und deswegen brauchen wir Gesten,
Symbole und irgendeinen Gedenktag? Vielleicht nicht.
Alles, was wir von der Bildung und der Wirtschaft kennen, sagt uns,
dass diese Schadenswerte durch die Leben von jahrzehntelang Billionen von Kindern
aufweichen werden, bis die restlichen Leben, ohne dass diese Schadenswerte gut gemacht werden.
Und es ist wirklich nicht der verdiente Wunsch weltweit, diese Jungen mit der
Kompensation, mit den Reparationen, mit der Reparation ihrer Bildung,
die notwendig sein wird,
To make good the deficits that accumulated in those critical years,
early years of their development.
Toos will Reparationszahlungen für die Jungen.
Ja, da bin ich auch total dafür. Wir können ja mal vergleichen,
weil Alena Büx hat ja jetzt einfach alle in einen Topf geworfen.
Das war für uns alle schwer, wie auch immer.
Lockdowns für alle. Wir hatten ja nicht Lockdowns für alle. Bei der Wirtschaft
wurde ja auch differenziert zwischen denjenigen, die einfach weiter zur Arbeit
gehen mussten und niemals einen Tag frei hatten, nur weil irgendwo ein tödliches Virus lauerte.
Alles sollte weiterlaufen. Und diejenigen, die ein Homeoffice verordnet bekommen
haben, die hängen bis heute da drin, weil sie es super geil finden und die Unternehmen
wissen nicht, wie sie die Leute zurückkriegen.
Also Homeschooling und Homeoffice können wir hier nicht in einen Top werfen.
Das eine ist für die einen immer noch ein zu verteidigender Luxus und Homeschooling
ist einfach eine Katastrophe für alle.
Ja, und das finde ich für eine Vorsitzende des Ethikrats auch einfach unredlich,
wenn sie dann in diesem Spiegel-Interview sagt,
zwei Jahre nach Pandemiebeginn war ich bei einer Veranstaltung mit Chefs größerer
Unternehmen, alle waren geimpft, aber es gab eine neue echte Herausforderung,
nämlich wie machen wir Homeoffice gerecht möglich,
wie bekommen wir es hin, dass das fair läuft, dass die Arbeitnehmer diesen Schutz
in Anspruch nehmen können und die Bedarfe der Unternehmen trotzdem erfüllt werden,
Arbeitsprozesse nicht zusammenbrechen.
Ich war tief beeindruckt, wie gut und wertschätzend da diskutiert und Lösungen gefunden wurden.
Ja, das gilt für ganz wenige Bereiche, wo man das so machen kann und da werden
hier in Frankfurt Innenstadt einige dazugehören, die ihre Beratertätigkeit oder
ihre Anwaltstätigkeit dann auch mal von zu Hause aus machen,
aber die meisten Leute müssen irgendwo hin.
Und darum muss es doch gehen, dass man sagt, ja, diese Leute hatten nie einen
Lockdown gehabt und die hat man einem sehr hohen Risiko ausgesetzt.
Sogar zu der Zeit, als noch gar nichts da war, noch keine guten Maßnahmen,
wie man überhaupt mit Corona-Kranken im Krankenhaus umgeht, da waren wir noch überfordert.
Man hatte zugleich keine Impfung, keine Tests und sonst was und trotzdem mussten
die Leute alle arbeiten gehen.
Mhm.
Also als es schon mal einen großen Geldbedarf gab, damals gab es gar keine Not
eigentlich, man hat einfach nur gesehen, da sind so kleine Kinder,
die brauchen Universitäten.
Da gab es eine, ich sag mal, Elterngeneration, die hat gesagt,
okay, dann bauen wir euch jetzt Universitäten.
Wie viel braucht ihr? 20 Stück? Wie viele Leute sollen da jeweils rein? 20.000?
Okay, bauen wir halt für Millionen von Leuten einfach Universitäten.
Wir bauen ganze Innenstädte um, Bielefeld, Bochum und so weiter.
Alles wird auf die Uni zugeschrieben.
Zack, mega Investition, vielleicht eine der größten Investitionen pro Kopf,
die jemals auf der Welt irgendwo so stattfand, dieser Reform-Uni-Aufbauprozess der 70er Jahre.
Jetzt haben wir wieder einen großen Bedarf, in die Jugend zu investieren und
die ältere Generation so, nö, gar nichts.
Null. Ihr spielt hier keine Rolle und Alena Büx sagt uns, wir saßen doch alle
in einem Boot, so vier Jahre später immer noch.
Also, wir haben es mit so einer grundlegenden, der Staat gönnt dir gar nichts,
er will nur was von dir, er gibt dir aber keine Mittel in die Hand und jetzt
sieh mal zu, dass es irgendwie hinhaut.
Am Ende musst du den Laden übernehmen, wir sagen dir aber nicht,
wir helfen dir auch gar nicht weiter und überhaupt. Das ist das eine Thema.
Das zweite Thema ist zwei Jahre Ukraine-Krieg.
Wir bekommen jetzt im Mai eine Wehrpflicht-Debatte, die sich gewaschen hat.
Das kann man schon mal sagen.
Historius macht selber Vorschläge und er wird zuerst, bevor die Öffentlichkeit
informiert, Friedrich Merz anrufen, um ihm zu sagen, das ist mein Vorschlag.
Beeinigen wir uns jetzt auf das schwedische Modell, jeder Jugendliche wird angerufen.
10% werden gemustert, alle stehen als Reservisten bereit, jeder muss mal in
so ein Trainingslager oder wie auch immer.
Irgend solche ganz absurden Programme werden demnächst kommen.
Also mit demnächst meine ich morgen. Der Mai ist nah.
Und wir erinnern uns ja noch, bunte.de in Kooperation mit Focus Online,
Toto Hosensänger, Campino, Zitat, würde den Wehrdienst jetzt nicht mehr verweigern.
Also es wird aus allen Rohren jetzt auf die Jugend eingeschossen.
Das sagt sich als steinalter Millionär natürlich gut.
Ganz genau, ganz genau.
Dafür bekommt man ja auch eine Poetikdozentur in Düsseldorf an der Uni.
Ah ja, sie dauerte 90 Minuten.
Campino ist da und erzählt Kurses über Lyrik.
Ja, das ist sehr gut, sehr gut. So, also eine Wehrpflichtdiskussion kommt.
In Dänemark ist es ja sogar so, dass man darüber diskutiert,
dass jetzt auch Frauen zur Wehrpflicht eingezogen werden, also dass man das
auch als Verpflichtung macht.
Ich bin mal gespannt, wie weitreichend das in Deutschland so ist.
Ja, man kann das ja unter diesem Brand Vogue und Wehrhaft auch jetzt erweitern
auf das weibliche Geschlecht.
Ich weiß auch nicht genau, wie Pistou es aus dieser Nummer rauskommen will,
dass er Frauen da nicht sozusagen auf Augenhöhe gleichberechtigt mit einnimmt.
Ja, feministische Außenpolitik und so, ich denke, da ist Spielraum.
So und jetzt warten wir das aber mal ab, wie es im Mai sich dann entfaltet,
wir werden es ja dann beobachten.
Pistorius hatte Ende April jetzt noch eine andere Botschaft. Er hat am 26.04.
Vor ein paar Tagen gemeinsam mit seinem französischen Amtskollegen neue Waffentechnik vorgestellt.
Wir hören mal kurz zu, halbe Minute. Hören wir hier was Substantielles oder
ist es Bullshit-Bingo? Nein.
Frankreich und Deutschland wollen bei der europäischen Verteidigung im Gleichschritt
gehen und haben große Ambitionen.
Das Kampfpanzersystem Main Ground Combat System MGCS stehe genau dafür.
Es geht um etwas völlig Neues, miteinander vernetzte Gefechtsfahrzeuge,
die teilweise auch unbemannt operieren können.
Autonomisches, taktisches Navigieren, robuste Cloud-Unterumgebung und eine resiliente,
digitalisierte Automatisierung Und künstliche Intelligenz wird natürlich ebenfalls dazu beitragen,
dass wir mit MGCS einen deutlichen qualitativen Fähigkeitsvorsprung für die
Landes- und Bündnisverteidigung erreichen.
MGCS, Matsch, Gelände, Chaos, irgendwas, keine Ahnung.
Neuer Panzer, der mit KI-Automatisierung vernetzt, digitalisiert und so weiter.
Und da denkt man sich ja, ah cool.
Das heißt ja, der Mensch selber wird ein bisschen aus dem Spiel genommen,
stellt sich raus, nee, ganz und gar nicht.
Ich bin einem Text gefolgt mit dieser lustigen Überschrift, Abschreckung heißt siegfähig sein.
Den haben wir wahrscheinlich einige bei Twitter gesehen. Der wurde allein wegen
dieser Überschrift von soldat-und-technik.de publiziert, geteilt.
Ich habe mir gedacht, okay, den lese ich jetzt mal. Und ich bin dann aus allen
Wolken gefallen. Im Vorspann.
Also doch eine ziemliche Bundeswehrveranstaltung. Da greift die Deutschland
AG und ich zitiere jetzt mal aus seinem Grußwort zwei Abschnitte.
Der zweite davon ist die Pointe des ganzen Grußwortes.
Und wir haben im Hinterkopf, okay, die Jugend wurde ganz schön drangsaliert.
Vier Jahre Corona, keine Hilfe, kein Nichts, die kommen jetzt irgendwie aus
der Schule, jetzt haben wir eine anstehende Wehrpflichtdiskussion,
jetzt kommt aber Pistorius und sagt, nee, der Panzer macht das alles,
den wir brauchen, der Krieg wird automatisiert.
Und jetzt heißt es von Alfons Mais, Abschreckung heißt, siegfähig zu sein,
dazu müssen Landstreitkräfte kaltstadtfähig und technologisch auf der Augenhöhe
der Zeit agieren können.
Es muss daher gelingen, Zukunftstrends zu erkennen, kontinuierlich die Ressourcen
für deren Implementierung bereitgestellt zu bekommen und die Bereitschaft zu
haben, sich auf neue Technologien einzulassen.
Und dann in Anführungszeichen Masse spielt dabei eine unübersehbare Rolle.
Das gilt für Material und Antriebsstoffe, genauso wie für Finanzmittel und Soldatinnen
und Soldaten. Also wir brauchen jetzt Soldatinnen und Soldaten in Masse, sagt er.
Und dann läuft sein Grußwort auf folgende Pointe hinaus.
Durch qualitative Effizienz Verluste, wie zum Beispiel die Erforderlichkeit
einer Hinterlegung mit höchst qualifiziertem Personal im Backend aufgezehrt werden.
Kriegstauglichkeit muss hier der Maßstab sein.
Also automatisiert wird hier das Backend des Krieges.
Backend aus der Techniksprache wissen wir, das ist das, was im Hintergrund läuft.
Für den User vorne ist das Frontend da.
Also die Front heißt jetzt Frontend.
Und damit wir gar keinen Menschen hinten im Panzer, der auch alleine fahren kann, verschwenden,
holen wir jetzt quantitative Effizienzgewinne durch das, was Pistols gerade
nannte, KI, Automatisierung, Digitalisierung, damit alle Menschen vor diesen
Panzern artilleriemäßig irgendwie den Krieg dann gestalten. Ja. Also du wirst jetzt,
Also sozusagen am Frontend des Krieges. Früher war es noch, naja bei der Bundeswehr
kann ich wenigstens Führerschein machen.
Heute heißt es Führerschein, der Panzer fährt doch von alleine,
hier braucht niemand einen Führerschein. Geh mal nach vorne,
geh ins Frontend und lass dich opfern.
Und ich bin sehr froh, dass du das ansprichst, denn das ist ja diese absolute
absurde Situation, die wir jetzt gerade haben, dass man sagt,
die Ukrainer sind kriegsmüde, weil der Westen keine Waffen in genügend ausreichender
Weise liefert und das ist ja zum Beispiel eine Argumentation,
die sich Ulrike Herrmann zu eigen macht.
Also die Ukrainer wären gar nicht kriegsmüde, wenn sie nur die richtigen Waffen
hätten, sonst würden die natürlich an die Front gehen.
Und dabei wird immer so getan, also es stimmt natürlich, dass die Motivation
geschwächt wird dadurch, wenn die sehen, also der Westen unterstützt uns nicht
so sehr, aber die Tatsache ist ja, dass man, auch wenn man Waffen hat und gut
ausgestattet ist, man trotzdem an der Front stirbt.
Nicht zu 100 Prozent, aber natürlich ist das Risiko an der Front zu sterben
sehr hoch, denn es geht darum, sich gegenseitig tot zu schießen.
Also das muss man doch ganz klar so konstatieren.
Also so zu tun, als wären diese Waffen, wenn sie dann geliefert würden,
einfach nur dafür da, dass man völlig opferfrei dort einen Krieg führt, ist völlig verrückt.
Und das ist aber etwas, was wir immer weiter jetzt erzählt bekommen und was
mich da auch wundert ist, dass da nicht Leute aufschrecken, wenn es um dieses
Selbstbestimmungsgesetz geht.
Das Selbstbestimmungsgesetz, das ja jetzt verabschiedet wurde vom Bundestag,
bei dem man das Geschlecht also frei entscheiden kann.
Das sagt ja folgendes, die personenstandsrechtliche Geschlechtszuordnung und
die Vornamenswahl von der Einschätzung dritter Personen ist zu lösen und die
Selbstbestimmung der betroffenen Personen zu stärken.
Das Ziel des Gesetzes ist es, das Recht jeder Person auf Achtung und respektvolle
Behandlung in Bezug auf die Geschlechtsidentität zu verwirklichen.
Und nochmal ist hier wichtig zu unterstreichen, es ist nicht an medizinische
Maßnahmen gekoppelt. Das heißt also, wer jetzt sein Geschlecht ändern will im
Personalausweis, ist nicht gleichzeitig dann irgendeinem Prozess unterzogen
oder hat damit irgendwas angeleiert.
Hier wird nochmal deutlich gemacht, jeder Person, deren Geschlechtsidentität
von ihrem Geschlechtseintrag im Personenstandsregister abweicht,
kann gegenüber dem Standesamt erklären, dass die Angabe zu ihrem Geschlecht
in einem deutschen Personenstandseintrag geändert werden soll.
Die Person hat mit ihrer Erklärung zu versichern, dass der gewählte Geschlechtseintrag
beziehungsweise die Streichung des Geschlechtseintrags ihrer Geschlechtsidentität am besten entspricht.
Und zweitens ihr die Tragweite, der durch die Erklärung bewirken Folgen bewusst ist.
Das ist ja ein ungeheuer fortschrittliches Gesetz und viele aus dem Ausland
blicken ja auch gerade auf dies jetzt finden das hochinteressant.
Und jetzt erleben wir aber die Gleichzeitigkeit von Fortschritt und Regression,
denn es gibt Paragraf 9 in diesem Gesetz und dieser lautet ….
Die rechtliche Zuordnung einer Person zum männlichen Geschlecht bleibt,
soweit es den Dienst mit der Waffe auf Grundlage des Artikels 12a des Grundgesetzes
und hierauf beruhender Gesetze betrifft, für die Dauer des Spannungs- oder Verteidigungsfalls
nach Artikel 80a des Grundgesetzes bestehen,
wenn in unmittelbarem zeitlichen Zusammenhang mit diesem die Änderung des Geschlechtsantrags
von männlich zu weiblich oder divers oder die Streichung der Angabe zum Geschlecht erklärt wird.
Das heißt, hier wird gesagt, wenn es einen Zusammenhang gibt im Spannungs- oder Verteidigungsfall.
Also der Krieg ist noch nicht da, aber ein Spannungsfall.
Jetzt ist die Frage, was ist Spannungsfall?
Ich bin kein Jurist, aber ich könnte mir vorstellen, das ist ein sehr dehnbarer Begriff.
Der Grundbegriff lautet, es ist ein Auffangparagraf.
Und würde das nicht eigentlich bedeuten, dass wir jetzt hier sagen müssten,
du hast gesagt, da kommt jetzt eine heiße Debatte im Mai.
Möglicherweise ist der Spannungsfall noch nicht da. ja, jetzt noch schnell das
Geschlecht wechseln, bevor man nachher irgendwo eingezogen wird.
Am Ende will es der Staat entscheiden, denn er möchte, er braucht dich.
Ja. Der Staat braucht dich. Und jetzt haben wir ja Unterschieden zwischen Backend, Frontend. Ja.
Backend, Mega-Investition. Da macht Pistorius, kriegt einen wirklich semantischen
Orgasmus, wenn er KI und Automatisierung und Digitalisierung und Vernetzung
in einem Satz unterbringen darf.
Jetzt hören wir mal entlang dieses Gesetzes, was ist im Frontend der einzelne Mensch wert?
Eva Högl stellt hier mal ihre Arbeit dar, sie ist ja Wehrbeauftragte des Bundestags
und im Heute-Journal gab es Anmerkungen.
Zum Thema Personal habe ich keine guten Neuigkeiten und keine guten Botschaften,
denn die Bundeswehr altert und schrumpft.
Bis 2031 braucht die Truppe Minimum 20.000 Soldatinnen und Soldaten zusätzlich.
Und hier kommt Dauerbrenner Nr. 3 ins Spiel, die fehlende moderne Infrastruktur.
Marode Kasernen, veraltete Unterkünfte laden nicht dazu ein,
dass junge Menschen ihre Zukunft beim Bund sehen.
Mich sprechen manchmal Eltern an, wenn ich bei einem Gelöbnis war,
und schildern mir, wie die Kasernen aussehen und was sie gesehen haben,
in welchen Stuben die jungen Rekrutinnen und Rekruten Dienst tun.
Das trägt ganz maßgeblich dazu bei, ob die Bundeswehr als attraktiv wahrgenommen wird oder nicht.
Noch kann man ja abbrechen und die Abbrecherquoten sind enorm.
Eines der größten Probleme der Bundeswehr. Gar nicht so sehr das Rekrutieren,
sondern dann, dass die Abbrecherquoten nicht so hoch sind.
Also hinter dir wird ein super geiler Panzer fahren, aber deine Kaserne sieht
aus, als wärst du schon im Krieg.
Während der ganzen Ausbildung. Also der gar nicht groß in dich rein investiert,
weil man genau weiß, na gut, okay, du bist ja nur so ein Mensch.
Also du stehst es halt durch und dann am Ende und da wird einfach auf dich zugegriffen.
Also nicht nur, du bist jetzt doch ein Mann, wir brauchen dich als Mann,
du bist jetzt ein Mann, sondern du hast jetzt auch sonst keine Ansprüche mehr,
du brauchst warmes Wasser, nee, hier ist kein warmes Wasser,
du willst gute Ernährung, nee, ist ja nicht.
Also du wirst von allem entledigt.
Und richtig gut ist, dass nicht nur die Politiker uns sagen,
was sie wollen, sondern auch die Journalisten.
Der Deutschlandfunk hat einen Politik-Podcast gemacht zum Thema Was ist uns Verteidigung wert?
Mit besonderem Verweis auf ab Juni gibt es ja einen Veteranentag in Deutschland.
Hurra.
Also genau, wir haben die von Alena Büx geforderte große Feierstunde für Veteranen.
Und der Deutschlandfunk macht dazu mehrere Anmerkungen. Wir hören jetzt die
Deutschlandfunk Journalisten.
Aber es ist noch nichts bekannt, wie der sich gestaltet. Also ich würde es ja
ganz traditionell machen, dass, Heino hat ja sehr viele Märsche aufgenommen
auch, alte Kameraden und so, dass man einfach so einen riesen Medley macht mit Heino,
der dann mal durch die Reihen dort geht.
Oder man macht es einfach so wie die FAZ, man feiert 75.
Geburtstag, dann wir ja auch und eröffnet wird von Frank Walter und am Ende
sitzt nochmal Harald Schmidt auf der Bühne und macht Witze.
Und dann hat man das Ding irgendwie abgefeiert. Wir hören jetzt die Deutschlandfunk-Journalisten,
nur ganz kurze Snippets, die aber sozusagen den Tenor des Podcasts tragen.
Hier zum Beispiel, was sind eigentlich Soldaten?
Ich muss sagen, ich bin da jetzt erstmal dafür. Das heißt nicht,
dass ich nicht meine ganzen Freunde toll finde, die Zivildienst gemacht haben.
Die können auch an bestimmter Stelle natürlich geehrt und mitgedacht werden.
Aber Soldat sein, Soldatin sein, das ist einfach was Besonderes.
Ist ja nicht so, dass wir in einer Gesellschaft leben, die gerade,
und da braucht man einen ganz breiten Begriff, ganz viel Zivildienst braucht,
sondern nein, Soldatinnen sein ist jetzt was ganz Besonderes.
Und was genau ist die Aufgabe von so einem Soldaten, der muss sich ja da eingliedern,
das wird uns im selben Podcast auch noch erklärt.
Wir reden natürlich zu Recht über Soldatinnen und Soldaten, die im Einsatz verletzt
worden sind, an Körper und Seele.
Das ist gut und um die muss sich besser gekümmert werden. Die Bundeswehr ist
ein Bürokratie-Monster und das ist manchmal wirklich furchtbar für die Betroffenen.
Aber in erster Linie ist die Bundeswehr ein Instrument, ein Instrument unserer Außenpolitik.
Ja, du bist ein Instrument der Außenpolitik. Im Frontend, wo du nach vier Jahren
Corona, wenn du dann deine Schule, sollte das sein, da ankommst,
dann bist du ein Instrument der Außenpolitik.
Also wir haben gar keine Verteidigungspolitik mehr, sondern wir haben jetzt
Außenpolitik und die Soldatinnen und Soldaten sind natürlich ein Teil der Außenpolitik.
Ja, vor einer Weile hatte ich mich mit einem Soldaten unterhalten und der sagte,
das sei auch sehr frustrierend als junger Mensch, wenn man dort ist und dann
zum Beispiel von Leuten kommandiert wird, die deutlich schlichteren Gemüts sind als man selbst.
Aber man kann ja innerhalb dieser Hierarchie und da man nur das Instrument ist, nicht widersprechen.
Und das allein sei schon frustrierend und dann fragte ich natürlich auch nach
sanitären Einrichtungen und all diese Dinge und dann sagt er einfach,
Wolfgang, bleib da, wo du bist und denk nicht weiter drüber nach.
Hier der Aufruf für den Mai. Wenn ihr mit euren Eltern oder Großeltern zusammen
Fernsehen schaut, ihr selber macht es ja nicht, zu Recht übrigens,
und dort sagt irgendwer so ein Argument wie, nee, die Bundeswehr muss wieder
in der Breite der Gesellschaft verankert werden.
Wir brauchen auch wieder die, die es eigentlich gar nicht in ihrer Biografie vorgesehen hatten.
Dann einfach reinrufen, ja, weil die Soldaten, die freiwillig gehen, alle doof sind.
Weil die Bundeswehr verblödet ist. Genau deswegen, weil man die in der Breite
wiederfahren kann. Und das ist nun mal so.
So, was sagt jetzt die Jugend dazu? Und das waren ja nur Illustrationen zum
Thema vier Jahre Corona, zwei Jahre Krieg und jetzt geht es erst richtig los mit beiden.
Die Grünen, die 2022 hier noch bei über 25% lagen, in dieser Trendstudie,
also 2014 bis 1929-Jährige wurden gefragt,
sagen jetzt nicht mal mehr zu 20%, ja, ja, die Grünen sind meine Partei.
SPD, abgeschmiert. FDP, richtig abgeschmiert. Linke, sowieso nicht vorhanden.
BSW, was, also so bei 5%. After you.
22 Prozent. CDU 20, beide aufstrebend.
Und vor allem aufstrebend, keine Ahnung, bei der Frage, wen willst du wählen? Keine Ahnung.
Also wir haben eine verfassungsgebende Mehrheit bei den Jungen aus,
keine Ahnung, AfD und CDU.
Das ist wirklich sehr besorgniserregend, denn 2022, als man an diesem Punkt war zu sagen,
okay, der zweite Lockdown war so scheiße und so falsch und auch so erlogen,
wenn ihr euch jetzt entschuldigt und uns entschädigt, sehen wir drüber hinweg.
Da war diese Gemengelage aus AfD und CDU noch bei 42%. Da war das nicht mal
eine qualifizierte Mehrheit.
Jetzt verfassungsgebende Mehrheit. Also es sollte doch allen zu bedenken geben.
Und jetzt zur Frage, und jetzt binden wir es auch richtig zurück an die Zeit.
Worum geht es den jungen Menschen, wenn man sie fragt?
Junge Menschen beschäftigt vor allem ihre finanzielle Situation,
hat die Zeit über ihre Grafik geschrieben und aufgeschlüsselt wird dort Megathema Inflation.
Da würde ich sagen, nenn es nicht Inflation, sondern macht es wie die Briten,
es ist eine Lebenshaltungskostenkrise und die geht durch Wein und Mark, also überall hin.
Das ist hier nicht einfach, ah ja Inflation, dann dann denken alle wieder an
die Überinflation von vor 20, 100 Jahren oder so.
Sondern nein, das ist hier eine echte, man geht zum Supermarkt einkaufen und
ist danach einfach pleite. Das ist das Problem.
Und kommt nach Hause und bekommt einen Brief, dass die Miete nochmal sich erhöht.
Genau.
Und dann kommt die Rechnung, dass die Energie auch teurer wird. Ja.
Und dann kommt zum Schluss noch, dass Netflix jetzt auch nochmal drei Euro teurer ist.
Und dann denkt man, naja, das könnte ich kündigen, dann könnte ich mich zumindest,
da um 13 Euro ein bisschen befreien.
Und dann hat man uns im Salon und dachte, hohoho, das ist aber krass,
wie die EZB so gar nicht wusste, was Inflation ist und ein Monat später,
also nächste Woche, gibt es dann wieder Stefan,
der nochmal einen Text verliest von Ben Bernanke, der die Bank of England beraten
hat und den mal auf 100 Seiten aufgeschrieben hat. Leute, ihr habt wirklich
gar keine Ahnung, was Inflation ist.
Also niemand hat Ahnung, was Inflation ist, aber hier steht einfach mal so Inflation.
Ich würde sagen, nee, Inflation, räumt das Wort mal aus.
Niemand weiß, was das ist und
vor allem die Banken trauen sich wirklich zu sagen, wir wissen es nicht.
Also wir werden Grafiken uns angucken, da zieht es einem die Schuhe aus.
Deswegen, liebe Journalisten, Inflation ist kein Grundbegriff,
den man verwenden kann, denn niemand weiß, was das ist.
Aber man geht zum Supermarkt und man kommt nach Hause, es ist der 8.
Des Monats und man ist pleite. Das nennt man Lebenshaltungskostenkrise.
Eine Cost of Living Crisis. So, Inflation ist aber nur das eine.
Nächstes Thema, teurer Wohnraum.
Sollte eigentlich auch unter Inflation laufen.
Wirtschaftskrise, Altersarmut, Kollaps des Rentensystems. Das ist hier No Future,
und zwar in Geld ausgedrückt.
Geld ist Zeit. No future. Die sagen alle, wir haben kein Geld für nichts und
jetzt ist plötzlich hier ein Krieg und wir sollen alle mitmachen und es wird
einfach so wie bei Corona über uns hinweg entschieden.
Nee, ich gehe mal in die verfassungsgebende AfD, CDU, was auch immer.
Ich sehe Björn Höcke, wie er sagt, der Krieg ist scheiße und die kriegen ja
gar keine Kinder mehr, weil sie alle an der Front sterben und da sage ich,
das ist vielleicht mal mein Mann.
Ja, wie erklärst du dir das, dass man ja doch vielleicht so viel Grundwissen
voraussetzen könnte, dass mit einer CDU oder einer AfD die wirtschaftliche Situation
für Leute, die nicht schon reich sind, nicht besser werden wird.
Das könnte man ja eigentlich schlussfolgern. Das ist aber eine Schlussfolgerung,
die wir nicht vorfinden bei den Jungen.
Also ich kann verstehen, warum zum Beispiel jetzt Jungen nicht mehr die Grünen
wählen, die sind enttäuscht. Es gab diesen Riso-Effekt, ja, damals bei der Europamahl.
Das ist ja jetzt auch dann, jährt sich ja jetzt auch bald wieder.
Und zum vierten, fünften Mal.
Das heißt, wir haben da diesen Hype gehabt durch Fridays for Future auch.
Hatte also große Hoffnung. Das haben die Grünen nicht eingelöst.
Deswegen ist da die Skepsis bei den Jugendlichen größer geworden.
Verständlich. Aber wie erklärst du dir, dass jetzt 18-Jährige sagen,
das sieht alles ganz krisenhaft aus, ich wähle AfD oder CDU oder habe auch gar
nichts dagegen, wenn die beiden
koalieren würden, denn darauf läuft es ja auch dann sehr stark hinaus.
Das heißt, ist das einfach schon so sehr ideologisch durchtränkt,
dass die glauben, dass überhaupt dieses System nur funktioniert,
wenn man selber die Ellenbogen ausfährt und man Parteien hat,
die einem das ermöglichen.
Denn man könnte ja zugleich auch eine andere Schlussfolgerung daraus ziehen
und sagen, ich wende mich mehr dem Sozialstaat zu, also versuche irgendwas im
Spektrum SPD-Links-Partei zu wählen.
Also, ich schlage ab jetzt nur noch Lanzen für die Jugend.
Ich habe ja selber drei kleine Kids zu Hause und will mal eins fordern.
Einfache Antworten. Wenn irgendwer kommt und sagt, einfache Antworten sind böse
Antworten, sage ich, nee, wir brauchen jetzt einfache Antworten.
Die einfache Antwort ist, deine Miete wird halbiert.
Wenn irgendwer aufschreit, kann er ja beim Staat einen Wohngeldantrag stellen
und sagen, der zahlt mir nur noch die Hälfte meiner Miete, ich will aber mehr.
Vielleicht sagt dann das Stadtwohnbauamt irgendwie, keine Ahnung,
ja hier, wir stocken dir das auf oder so.
Aber ab jetzt müssen bitte die Vermieter selber sich um ihr Wohngeld bekümmern,
wenn sie es haben wollen.
Und so auch, wenn man einkaufen geht. Wenn man einkaufen geht und da ist irgendwie
so ein Gemüsestand und man geht das Gemüse kaufen und dann ist quasi,
das ist schon weg, das Geld.
Nimm trotzdem mehr mit und verlasse den Laden.
Aber das ist ja jetzt eine Aufforderung, die man vielleicht nicht politisch
wirklich in Anschlag bringen kann. Ich weiß, was du meinst.
Und das ist aber die Sache.
Also man könnte ja sagen, die Zeiten sind schlecht, also versuche ich wenigstens ein Minimum.
Also ich könnte sagen, dass ich eine gute Gesundheitsversorgung im Alter haben
werde, ist nicht sehr wahrscheinlich. Aber ich bin froh, dass wir noch so einen
Staat haben, der sich um die öffentliche Gesundheit kümmert.
Ich kann aber auch die Schlussfolgerung ziehen und sagen, ich muss nur noch
sehen, dass ich so viel Geld verdiene, dass ich mir Privatkliniken leisten kann
und dann könnt ihr mir mal den Puckel runterrutschen mit all dem anderen Kram.
Und das ist glaube ich die Haltung, die bei Jungen ganz deutlich vertreten ist
und absolut verständlich ist.
Also auch ich will hier diese Lanze für die jungen Leute brechen,
denn sie werden ja permanent enttäuscht und das einzige Jugendprogramm,
das die Ampelregierung jetzt anzubieten hat, wird dann wohl die Wehrpflicht sein.
Und genau deshalb ist natürlich diese individualistische Antwort oder so eine
individualistisch plus völkisch kollektive Antwort,
die jetzt die AfD noch anbietet, etwas, was wahnsinnig reizvoll ist für junge Leute.
Ja, also verschiedene Soziologen sagen ja, der Staat wird dir deswegen als Identitätsangebot
gemacht, weil einfach deine Nationalität und die Geschichte,
an die du dich da bindest, dir nicht genommen werden kann. Sie steht ja im Geschichtsbuch.
Du musst also nur sagen, ich bin deutsch. So, damit ist das einfach geregelt.
Man zieht sich also auf das Letzte zurück, von dem man weiß,
das kann mir nicht veräußert werden.
Alles andere kann dir genommen werden. So, also ist das ein sehr attraktives
Angebot, wenn jemand kommt mit Deutschland, aber wieder normal und echte Männer
machen das und das und dann sind sie besonders deutsch und so weiter,
haben wir ja von Krah alles gehört.
Ich will ganz ehrlich sagen, ich kann und ich habe mich ja nun wirklich sehr
ausführlich mit diesen Generationsfragen beschäftigt.
Es gibt derzeit für mich keinen sichtbaren Ausweg, es läuft einfach wirklich
ein Bürgerkrieg gegen die jungen Leute.
Und zwar mit diesem, wir haben es bei Hecklund gelesen, die Zeit spielt da eine große Rolle.
Ich habe es ja als Idee vorgestellt im Salon. Jetzt ist vielleicht auch der
gute Zeitpunkt, allen nochmal zu empfehlen, bucht euch ruhig mal den Salon,
wo wir das in zwei Stunden besprechen.
Aber wir haben die Eigentumsökonomik von Gunnar Heinzern und Otto Steiger.
Und auf dem Buchtitel steht ja schon Rätsel der Wirtschaftswissenschaften.
Und sie argumentieren dann, Geld ist verbrieftes Eigentum.
Also, alle suchen immer nach, ah ja, Gold ist es nicht mehr,
dann gehe ich jetzt in Bitcoin oder so ein Quatsch. Aber nein,
Geld verbrieft Eigentumstitel.
Auf Grund und Boden, auf Autos, auf Sachen, die man so hat und so weiter.
Es ist immer, es verbrieft etwas.
Wir haben so viel Geldvermögen, weil einfach so viel da ist,
dass man mit Geld handeln kann.
So und jetzt haben wir ja von Hecklund dieses Angebot bekommen,
wir haben es inspirativ herausgelesen, es steht nicht so eindeutig drin,
aber den Marxismus, der ja diese Art von Eigentumsökonomik begründet,
nochmal auf Zeit, auf Lebenszeit umzumünzen.
Also aus der Sachdimension heraus in die Zeitdimension hinein.
Und das, was wir jetzt sehen beim Thema Corona, das Leben ist unglaublich teuer
geworden und wir wollen dich als Soldaten haben, ist doch unter dieser Lesart,
würde ich sagen, wir wollen an deine Zeit ran.
Deine Arbeitszeit, ökonomisch.
Deine Eltern konnten von einem
Monat arbeiten noch drei Monate Miete zahlen, du nur noch drei Wochen.
Und diese Veränderung, die über die Zeit einfach passierte und diese,
diese ökonomische Gemengelage ist halt wirklich genickbrechend.
Das Besondere verkauft, dass deine Lebenszeit vielleicht nicht an die Lebenserwartung heranreicht.
Gleichzeitig guckst du aber Brian Johnson YouTube-Videos, wie er sein Leben
die ganze Zeit verlängert, weil er so ein Multimillionär ist,
der sich da 80 Pille am Tag reinhaut.
Und das ist absolut Inkonsistenz und das lässt sich, glaube ich,
nur noch erklären über wir nehmen mal solche Textangebote wie Hegel und Ernst,
sagen hier muss man jetzt mal gucken,
wie Zeit kodiert wird und irgendwelche Vermieter holen sich einen fünften Urlaub
im Jahr dafür, dass du einfach fünf Wochen arbeiten musst, um vier Wochen lang irgendwo zu wohnen.
Und wir sind jetzt an diesem Punkt, wo das nicht mehr zusammenpasst und wo auch
die älteren Generationen sagen, das ist uns doch egal. Zucken einfach mit den Schultern.
Und deshalb sollte man auch vorsichtig sein, wenn jetzt diese langfristige Perspektive
in den Anschlag gebracht wird, um die Zeit jetzt zu beschneiden.
Also wir alle wissen, man muss in Anbetracht des Klimawandels sagen,
dass man längerfristige Entscheidungen treffen muss und das darf nicht immer
nur bis zur nächsten Wahl alles reichen.
Aber was wir jetzt auch vorfinden, ist, dass man sagt, wir müssen uns jetzt mal zusammennehmen.
Damit dann bald alles gut wird. Ein Beispiel ist Christian Lindner,
der kürzlich in der Talkshow sagte, also jetzt so drei Jahre nochmal sparen,
diszipliniert sein, dann haben
wir zehn Milliarden mehr und die können wir dann da und dort einsetzen.
Man denkt so, ja, aber zehn Milliarden, darum kann es doch jetzt wirklich nicht
gehen, was soll denn das bringen? Das geht dann weiter bis hin zu Ulrike Herrmann
überlegt, was ist in 400 Jahren mit Hamburg?
Bin ich nicht da? Weiß ich nicht.
Aber auch etwas, was Markus Lanz kürzlich im Podcast rezipierte,
als er Bezug nahm auf Florenz Gaub.
Die sagte in ihrem Buch wohl in so und so vielen Jahrzehnten,
in zwei oder drei oder vier Jahrzehnten, sie zieht eine gute Zukunft für Europa.
Und dann denke ich mir, ja, das ist bestimmt toll für die Leute,
die dann 18 sind, aber was machen jetzt die anderen, die gerade 18 sind,
die reißen sich jetzt mal 30 Jahre am Riemen oder wie. Wie?
Also das ist so eine Idee von, also man, diese Debatten finden so statt,
als könnte man sich selbst außer der Zeit setzen.
Also als könnte man das selbst so, ja jetzt haben wir so 30 Jahre,
ich überdauer das mal und dann komme ich wieder.
Wir sind aber nicht in einem Marvel-Film, wo irgendein Held 30 Jahre gewartet
hat und plötzlich wiederkommt und sagt, ah ja prima, jetzt mache ich hier wieder
mit, sondern man ist dann 80 oder tot.
Das heißt, man muss die Zeit, die jetzt da ist, nutzen.
70 Jahre im Eis hat nur Captain America weitergeholfen. Um die Jungen kriegsteuglich zu machen übrigens.
Ja, es ist wirklich dramatisch. Also die Zeit erscheint mir hier die maßgebliche
Sinndimension unserer völlig verirrenden.
Das heißt aber, wenn ich deine Diagnose jetzt nochmal Revue passieren lasse,
siehst du nicht irgendeinen anderen Ausweg gerade,
beziehungsweise wir laufen jetzt erstmal in dieses totale Desaster hinein,
dass junge Leute sich immer mehr der AfD annähern,
sie wählen, sich dadurch radikalisieren und das bedeutet dann aber wirklich
einen Bürgerkrieg insofern, als diese jungen Leute ja, da überall noch sind, ganz mobil sind.
Wir haben jetzt nicht diese anderen Beschreibungen, die du ja oft mitgebracht hast aus dem Osten.
Da sind über 70-Jährige, die wohnen da in Dörfern, die völlig verlassen sind.
Und die haben sich da irgendwie gesagt, wir wählen jetzt noch mal aus Protest
oder aus lauter Dollheit die AfD.
Aber das kriegen wir ja nicht mit, wenn wir hier durch Frankfurt spazieren.
Aber diese jungen Leute, die du da jetzt gerade beschreibst,
die sitzen ja neben mir auch im Restaurant in Frankfurt oder gehen auch in den selben Filmen im Kino?
Ich sag mal so, diese jungen Leute kriegen jetzt dieses Angebot,
wir haben es ja als völlig wahnsinnige Theorie mal vorgestellt,
ich will es jetzt nochmal wiederholen,
Donald Trump wird gewählt und nutzt seine Transition,
um die Welt schon mal und vor allem seine Mitarbeiter darauf vorzubereiten,
am ersten Amtstag fliege ich nach Russland, lege Putin einen Zettel hin,
da steht drauf, wie der Frieden organisiert ist, nämlich das Rasmussen-Modell,
was jetzt kam, Vom ehemaligen NATO-Chef.
Die Gebiete, die Putin jetzt erobert hat, was auch immer das bedeutet, sind russisch.
Und die Ukraine kommt dafür in die NATO oder kriegt halt so einen europäischen Schutzschirm.
Und dann unterschreiben das einfach beide. Putin und Trump.
Dann beginnt irgendwie der deutsche Bundeskanzler sich darüber aufzuregen,
aber da er noch in einem Telefonat war, dauert es zwei Stunden,
bis er darauf reagiert und da interessiert es schon keinen mehr,
weil Trump schon wieder das nächste irgendwie angeleiert hat.
Und dann jeder, der was dagegen hat, muss extrem rechtfertigen,
warum er will, dass der Krieg weitergeht.
So und das sind dann so Momente, wo die jungen Menschen einfach kurz aufatmen
können, na wenigstens ist der Krieg vorbei.
Vom Rest, was hat man erwartet?
Man hat eh nicht erwartet, dass der große Sozialstaat kommt und dann sagt man,
aber er hat wenigstens den Krieg verhindert.
Wenigstens ist der Krieg vorbei. So, was werden zehnjährige gefragt?
Hier, was wünschst du dir? Und so weiter.
Und dann beginnt irgendwann dieser kurze Moment, wo man sagt,
ja, Weltfrieden. Wieso gibt es eigentlich keinen Weltfrieden?
Und dann hat man einfach Trump, der sagt, wir machen jetzt mal einen europäischen Weltfrieden.
Und dann ist das einfach unterschrieben. Putin so, ich bin nochmal aus der Nummer
rausgekommen, ich kann Präsident bleiben und kann sagen, Russland ist gewachsen,
und wir haben diese Gebiete entnazifiziert und den Rest kläre ich irgendwie,
keine Ahnung, das ist dann so ein Aushandlungsding mit Trump,
dass auch die Russen, die sich auch Frieden wünschen, dann irgendwie sagen,
ja gut, so besser als gar nicht.
Man kann dann dem eigenen Kind sagen, du wirst morgen nicht eingezogen,
weil Trump hat einen Vorschlag gemacht und Putin hat ihn angenommen.
Also das ist eine Situation, die für alle da das Beste rausholt,
außer für Agnes Strack-Zimmermann.
Was machen wir mit der dann?
Genau, sie wird dann irgendwie rumkrakehlen und irgendwas, aber die Jugend der
Welt wird aufatmen, wenn so so ein Szenario kommt.
Weil mehr ist sowieso nicht für sie im Angebot. Es macht ihr auch keiner ein anderes Angebot.
Auch Joe Biden macht den amerikanischen Jugendlichen kein anderes Angebot,
sondern lässt da irgendwie die Unis gerade räumen und so.
Und von daher würde ich sagen, so traurig und schade es ist,
aber außer Akzellentarismus, dass man einfach die Sachen, die gerade in die
falsche Richtung laufen, dann einfach beschleunigt, aber dann mit einem...
Ende mit Schrecken statt ein Schrecken ohne Ende, das ist so das Einzige,
was noch als Argumentationslosung da irgendwie Paradigma mit unterzubringen
ist und das war's. und ja.
Wenn Trump da wirklich daran interessiert ist, ich bin da ja immer etwas skeptisch,
ob in der republikanischen Partei nicht doch jetzt sich andere Stimmen mehr
durchsetzen, die durchaus daran
interessiert sind, diesen Krieg auch lange Zeit noch laufen zu lassen.
Ich meine, diese Unterstützungen gab es jetzt und auch Trump spricht mit unter
andere Töne. Also man wird das sehen.
Er forcierte, hört alles bedingt auf und damit müssen wir erstmal mit Trump
rechnen, würde ich sagen.
Wir gehen nochmal ganz kurz zu Corona, denn wir können uns ja fragen,
was kann man denn eigentlich so machen, was sollte man eigentlich tun?
Wir denken jetzt mal darüber nach, dass wir ja ordentlich aufrüsten,
sehr viel Geld ausgeben.
Und Adam Tooze hat sich, ich empfehle das sehr, in vier Folgen mit Corona auseinandergesetzt.
Und er sagt dann auch, ja, es gibt ja eine Wahrscheinlichkeit,
dass wir wieder so eine Pandemie in etwa erleben.
Und zwar liegt die pro Jahr bei zwei Prozent, hat man errechnet.
Das ist ja schon relativ viel, wenn man so bedenkt, was das doch für einen großen Effekt hatte.
Und deswegen muss es natürlich um Impfungen gehen.
Für die Stadt New York, zum Beispiel, eine Rückkehrsrate, die gestattet wurde,
ist ungefähr zwischen 4 und 1, also jeder Dollar, der verwendet wird,
kostet 4 Dollar im Sinne des gesamten Vorteils bis zu so viel wie 10 Dollar
für jeden Dollar, der verwendet wird.
Jetzt kann man sich ja überlegen, waren die Impfungen zu teuer?
Diese Debatte kommt ja jetzt wieder hoch, weil von der Laien da sich rechtfertigen
soll, welchen Deal hat sie da eigentlich gemacht?
Hat sie Milliarden veruntreut, wie manche dann behaupten? Nun, wir hören nochmal Toos.
Ja, und wir hören mal noch weiter, was denn eigentlich das jetzt so mit den
Impfungen kostet. Also da könnten verschiedene Szenarien gibt es,
welche Pandemien eintreten könnten.
Und da könnte man sich jetzt auch schon darauf vorbereiten. Also man kann natürlich
auch nicht genau Impfstoffe entwickeln für Sachen, die noch nicht da sind,
aber man könnte natürlich in ganz anderer Weise vorbereitet sein,
wie ja auch Biontech vorbereitet war.
Also die hatten einfach so eine gute Struktur, dass die sagen,
ah ja, da können wir doch gut auf dieser Grundlage aufbauen.
Und Moderna ja auch, das war nämlich der einzige Cure-Vac auch.
Es gab vor einem Monat im Handelsblatt einen Artikel von Theresa Raufmann über
Biontech und da ist ja ganz interessant, dass sich da so ein Abwärtstrend gezeigt hat.
Biontech bekommt das Ende der Corona-Pandemie immer stärker zu spüren.
Im vergangenen Jahr machte der Impfstoffhersteller 3,8 Milliarden Euro Umsatz.
Wie das Unternehmen am Mittwoch mitteilte, das ist ein Rückgang um 78 Prozent
und weniger, als Biontech allein im vierten Quartal 2022 erlöste.
Auch der Nettogewinn sank von 9,43 Milliarden auf 930 Millionen Euro.
Und zugleich erfahren wir...
Biontech investiert derzeit stark in klinische Studienprogramme für potenzielle neue Medikamente.
Die Forschungs- und Entwicklungsausgaben hat das Unternehmen 2023 von 1,54 Milliarden
Euro auf 1,78 Milliarden Euro gesteigert.
2024 will Biontech bis zu 2,6 Milliarden Euro dafür ausgeben.
Also die machen wahnsinnig Umsatzverluste, also verglichen mit den Corona-Jahren,
haben aber trotzdem so ein ganz engagiertes Programm,
denn es geht darum, dass 2026 dann schon das erste Krebsmedikament auf den Markt
kommen soll. Man hat da ganz ambitionierte Ziele.
Ich will jetzt gar nicht Werbung für Biontech als solches machen,
nur wir hören jetzt hier so Zahlen und denken so 2,6 Milliarden,
also damit kann man schon richtig
viel bewegen und wir geben das ja mal gerade für ein paar Panzer aus.
Genau, wir haben den Spiegel-Leitartikel dazu, dass Biontech gerade mehr als
20 Krebsstudien laufen lässt.
Gegen diese ganzen Lymphknoten-Krebse, wo, also da war es eine Todesrate von 90 Prozent.
Ja. Und jetzt werden da schon die ersten geheilt. Also es sind wirklich ganz,
das muss man auch sagen, das sind halt jetzt Umsatzverluste,
die man da eingeht, aber das sind, wenn es dann aufgeht, also gigantische Gewinne,
die da, wenn du überlegst, wie viel Menschen auch bereit sind,
privat, sieht man jetzt bei Osempic und so weiter, wie viel Menschen privat
sind, privat für ihr Leben zu bezahlen.
Während wir gleichzeitig so eine Wehrdienstdiskussion haben,
wie viele Boomer da irgendwie dann doch mit, ich saß jetzt 30 Jahre zu lang,
ich hau mal noch ein paar Jahre zurück so.
Und wenn man dann gegen Krebs sich freikaufen kann, also dann ist Biontech an
der Goldgrube, glaube ich, nochmal richtig.
Ja, das wird so sein, aber Impfung wäre eigentlich gut, ist aber für Unternehmen
ja gar nicht so lukrativ, weil das ja auch immer so gesagt wird,
ja das ist für die Pharma-Lobby jetzt, die Pharma-Industrie macht das.
Nein, das ist völliger Unsinn, also womit eigentlich die Pharma-Industrie sehr
reich wird, sind Mittel, die man braucht, wenn man chronisch an irgendetwas erkrankt ist.
Diese Rechnung kann man ja mal machen. Wir hatten ja mal diesen Pflegetyp,
der immer auch die Pflege kritisiert hat, der dann meinte, ein Tag Beatmung
in einem deutschen Krankenhaus, vierstellig. So.
Wenn dann Leute 100 Tage lang beatmet werden, was bedeutet, sie kommen aus diesem
Zustand wieder raus und sind für einen lebenslangen Reha-Fall,
geht das in die Millionen und Millionen im Vergleich zu, ja gut, die Impfung.
Wären jetzt 15,50 Euro oder 150 der richtige Wert gewesen?
Ja, also ich würde sogar sagen, man hätte, nachdem ich das jetzt hier bei Biontech
gelesen habe und bitte nicht falsch verstehen, ich weiß sehr wohl um die Pharmaindustrie
und die Schwierigkeiten darin, aber eigentlich hat man bei Biontech viel zu wenig gezahlt.
Also man müsste eigentlich sagen, nee, man hätte gesagt, ist tolles,
nettes Angebot, aber wir zahlen einfach 100 Euro pro Impfung mehr.
Ja, warum hat man Ugo Shahid nicht vorher schon mal 10 Milliarden in die Hand gegeben?
Und was müsste man jetzt machen? Also Pandemie, Risiko 2% pro Jahr.
Also wir gehen in jedes neue Jahr und denken, zu 2% könnte aber jetzt wieder
so eine Pandemie kommen.
We have a pretty good idea of what it takes to produce a response.
The policy makers understand it, but as so often in the current moment,
all of that enlightenment and insight and clarity of purpose doesn't actually
translate into the kind of levels of spending, even though the kind of levels
of spending that are necessary are not heroic.
And even though the rates of return on these investments are gigantic,
whichever disease you look at, the cost of developing the vaccine.
Das heißt also, wir haben es hier mit einem Investment zu tun.
Das wäre kluge Industriepolitik, wenn man sie betreiben möchte.
Enough to actually make a down payment on the key vaccine development for all of the WHO suite.
You gotta ask yourself, where would Germany's taxpayer euros be better invested
in some lamentably inadequate military or in a world-class biohazard preparation?
Das heißt, ich will den Matschgelände vernetzen, Panzer haben von Pistorius.
Keine Impfung. Also das ist so verrückt, wenn man das hört.
Also 50 Milliarden würde es kosten, wenn man Investitionen macht,
die darauf vorbereiten, dass man egal welche dieser zehn möglichen Pandemien
kommen, dass man da dann sehr schnell eine Impfung hätte.
Also das könnte das Land Deutschland mal gerade so alleine aus dem Wertzahlen
und es gibt keine Ambitionen weltweit dafür.
Also wenn jetzt gesagt wird, wir haben so toll viel gelernt aus der Pandemie,
würde ich sagen, nö, wir haben eigentlich gar nichts gelernt.
Plus wir sagen noch WHO, nö, sollten wir mal lieber, das braucht niemand mehr,
die Weltgesundheitsorganisation. Vielen Dank.
Ist verrückt und es wird nicht besser. Anne Will ist ja nicht mehr jetzt Talkshow-Host,
sondern wollte was ganz Neues machen.
Sie war bei Matze Hielscher im Podcast und hat gesagt, dass sie jetzt so eine
Lust hat auf eine Herausforderung, was ganz Neues. Was macht sie?
Sie macht einen Podcast, der heißt nicht mehr wie ihre Talkshow Anne Will,
sondern der heißt Politik mit Anne Will, also was ganz Neues und sie lädt auch
Leute ein, bei denen man denkt, toll, wollte ich ja immer mal erleben,
zum Beispiel Melanie Ammann vom Spiegel und Kevin Kühnert. Noch nie gehört.
Das war ganz neu. Die war ja auch noch nie bei Anne Will in der Sonntagstalkshow.
Und man könnte sich ja denken, naja, aber das Thema vielleicht,
vielleicht mal ein Thema wählen, das man so noch nicht hatte. Und was ist es?
Sie macht ihre erste Sendung. Und das erste, was sie als Thema sich auswählt
für diese Sendung, eine Stunde lang spricht sie dann darüber,
wie wird Deutschland kriegstüchtig.
Also sie macht exakt das, was sie vorher auch gemacht hat, nur mit ein paar weniger Gästen.
Also sie hat fünfstellige Honorare für diese einstündige Moderation kassiert.
Und damit meine ich mittlere fünfstellige Honorare.
Nicht 10.000 Euro, sondern mehr so 40.000 Euro.
Warum macht sie denn plötzlich einen Podcast? Das verstehe ich nicht.
Weiß ich nicht. Naja, sie war auch bei dem All Ears bei Spotify und so.
Ich vermute, da werden schon irgendwelche Kooperationen bald in die Wege geleitet werden.
Kriegt doch für den Podcast jetzt nicht.
Ich weiß es nicht. Also ich würde jetzt mal mutmaßen, dass das nicht Gott zur Ehre produziert wird.
Wir wollen aber, bevor wir jetzt dazu kommen, also es wird jetzt heiter.
Wollen wir mal gerade auf ein paar Dinge hinweisen, nämlich zum Beispiel, dass wir am 24.
August unseren Live-Salon machen und zwar in Bornheim, also das ist hier in
Frankfurt direkt, man ist da schön zentral.
Es gibt Karten, ganz einfach, indem man auf den Link klickt,
den wir in der Beschreibung haben.
Wie viele gibt es denn noch? Gibt es noch Karten?
Ja, es gibt noch so 140 Karten.
Denke ich.
Also es gibt jetzt noch die Möglichkeit zuzugreifen. Das wird dann eine bunte
Sommershow im August für alle, die die nicht kommen können.
Das wird dann auch im Hinterjahr live sein. Und lass mich noch kurz sagen, dass ich am 9.5.
Und am 10.5. in Mühlheim an der Ruhr bin.
Dort wird Theater gespielt. Ich spiele aber kein Theater, sondern halte den
Vortrag dazu. Da gibt es das Stück Die Verwicklung.
Das beschäftigt sich mit Peter Weiß, Antisemitismus, Luigi Nono und ich werde
jeweils den Vortrag davor halten.
Also auch da kann man alle, das verlinken wir jetzt mal nicht mehr,
einfach auf meine Homepage gehen, wolfgangmschmidt.de, da findet man die Veranstaltungen
und auch die Links dazu. Am 15.05.
Bin ich in Göttingen, da spreche ich über den Film Der schwarze Falke von Jean
Forte, ein wunderbarer Western und der wird dann auch gezeigt.
Und am 25.05., das ist was für dich, als Opernliebhaber ja jetzt,
da bin ich in Wiesbaden bei den Maifest-Spielen und spreche mit dem Dramaturgen
Konstantin Mende über Wagner's Ring.
Sehr gut.
All das findet man auf meiner Homepage.
Wirst du bei diesem Theatervortrag kurz einen bedächtigen Gang zeigen?
Einen bedächtigen Gang?
Naja, so wie du...
Singst, wenn du nicht mit mir auf der Bühne bist, kannst du ja dann auch anfangen zu schauspielern.
Nein, also das überlasse ich den Profis.
Und mein Vorschlag wäre dieser bedächtige Gang, den man ja in der Oper nie sieht,
aber im Theater die ganze Zeit.
Ja, der bedächtige Gang, du meinst damit so diesen...
Dieses langsame Ich habe noch keinen Text, er kommt erst später, ich komme erst mal...
Ich gehe schon mal so rüber.
Auf die Bühne.
Ja, und da... Ja, ja, wir werden schauen.
Du hast nicht zufällig Tannhäuser schon gesehen, ne? Wie der Auftritt?
Nein, nein, kommt noch.
Aber du hast Termine schon, ne? Ich bin ja angefixt durch die ersten Bilder,
die die Opa gestern auch auf Instagram veröffentlicht hat.
Große Vorfreude. Ich habe Tickets für dieses Gespräch von Michel Friedmann im Bockenheimer Depot.
Aber ich glaube, ich kann das erst in der nächsten Spielzeit sehen.
So, so, schon ausverkauft. Oder die Termine bei dir, ja. Ja, okay.
Aber ich bin sehr gespannt, wir sollten dann vielleicht auch mal ein Podcast-Review
zu solchen Sachen machen.
Ja, vielleicht.
Denn mittlerweile wird es ja wirklich interessant. Also wenn ich jetzt so rüber
gucke, ich sehe ja da meine Operngeschichte, die ich jetzt absolviert habe, programmhefteweise.
Und das sind ja schon so 15 ungefähr.
Und bei Tannhäuser habe ich jetzt gestern das erste Mal in mir so Vorfreude.
Bisher gehe ich halt abends immer in die Oper.
Aber diesmal, als ich das Bühnenbild gesehen habe und so, habe ich gedacht,
schade, dass ich mich nicht rechtzeitig gekümmert habe auch und so.
Aber wir sollten es vielleicht doch dadurch, dass wir ja gesagt haben,
oder es ist ja deine Losung, der ich mich sehr anschließe, dass die Oper nicht
mehr Hochkultur, sondern Subkultur ist. Mhm.
Also wäre das glaube ich auch häufiger hier Thema im Podcast,
sollte es irgendwie sein, auch wenn ich nicht weiß, in welcher Form, aber.
Wir versuchen es ein bisschen einzubinden. Wir gucken auch mal,
dass wir im Herbst dann, wenn wir da unsere Salons haben, dass wir das auch
nochmal verbinden mit Opernbesuchen.
Im Juni machen wir das. Im Juni machen wir das, da gehen wir ja in La Juive,
das kann man alles nochmal nachhören im Salon und darauf wollen wir auch noch hinweisen.
Also man kann diesen Podcast unterstützen, einmal natürlich dadurch,
dass man ihn ein bisschen teilt, dass man ihn gut bewertet.
Also das hilft diesem Podcast auch sehr oder einfach Freunden weiter sagt,
dass der Podcast hörenswert ist und dann kann man ihn auch finanziell unterstützen,
indem man den Salon bucht und wir diskutieren da jedes Mal über ein Buch ausführlich,
so zwei Stunden dauert es ja dann meistens schon.
Dieses Mal geht es um das Buch Demokratiedämmerung, eine Kritik der Demokratietheorie
von Veit Selck, der die These hat,
dass sowohl die Demokratie als auch die Theorie der Demokratie in die Krise
geraten ist und wie kommt man eigentlich daraus oder gibt es da gar keinen Ausweg?
Das ist ein Buch, das vieles zermalmt, sich auch mit den ganz Großen des Fachs
anlegt und das schon für sehr viele Diskussionen gesorgt hat und ich bin gespannt, was wir dazu sagen.
Hast du es schon gelesen?
Nein, ich habe es angelesen.
Ich habe es schon gelesen, weil wir ja diesmal knapp, nur zwei Tage später nach uns.
Ich sage, wir werden es sehr inspirativ lesen müssen.
Okay, ich bin gespannt. Und diesen Salon, sag uns doch, wie man da am besten hinkommt.
Neue20er.de, dort dem goldenen Button folgen oder bei Apple einfach Shortcut buchen.
Wer einen Patreon-Account hat, uns da einfach suchen.
Da gibt es uns auch, aber wir empfehlen den Weg über Steady,
dann gibt es das ganze Archiv, da kann man alle Live-Folgen nochmal nachhören
und ich habe nochmal nachgeschaut, am 20.
Juni gehen wir in die Oper, weil wir am 21. in der CASE auf der Bühne sind.
Für alle, die am 20. auch wenn sie das hier nur hören und nicht mit in der CASE
sind, können sie trotzdem mit.
Ja genau, die CASE ist schon ausverkauft, also die regulären Veranstaltungen
in der CASE sind alle in diesem Jahr schon ausverkauft.
So, Anne Will.
Also, alle Podcasts sind mittlerweile gleich. Sie beginnen mit,
worüber wir heute nicht reden. Und dann dauert das eine halbe Stunde.
Dann kommt der Code, mit dem man unterstützen kann.
In dem Falle, Anne Will, alles ohne Leerzeichen und großgeschrieben.
Und am Ende kommt der konstruktive Ausblick. Ich habe ja jetzt für unser erstes
Thema schon mal gesagt, also ich habe hier leider keinen konstruktiven Ausblick.
Ich hoffe, wir dürfen hier noch mitspielen in der ersten Podcast-Liga,
auch wenn wir keine konstruktive Wende haben.
Ich würde auch sagen, wenn man solche positiven Ausblicke anbietet,
wie Arne will, hat man lieber keinen. Denn ich würde sagen, das ist jetzt für
mich der negative Ausblick.
Schweden zum Beispiel, gucken wir doch da mal rüber, Anfang März gerade erst
Mitglied der NATO geworden.
Und die haben einen Minister für Zivilverteidigung im Verteidigungsministerium.
Der Mann heißt Karl Oskar Bolin und ist von der Moderatensammlungsbewegung.
Der hat seine Landsleute davor gewarnt, sich in einem falschen Gefühl von Sicherheit zu wiegen.
Und er hat gesagt, hör mal zu, es könnte Krieg in Schweden geben.
Ich möchte eine Tür öffnen, eine Tür, die häufig durch die Anforderungen und
Herausforderungen des Alltags blockiert und verstopft ist. Eine Tür,
die viele Schweden vielleicht ihr ganzes Leben lang verschlossen gehalten haben.
Eine Tür zu einem Raum, in dem wir mit einer wichtigen Frage konfrontiert werden.
Wer bist du, wenn der Krieg kommt?
Das ist der positive Ausblick aus Schweden. Kannst du dir vorstellen.
Dass das bei uns jemand so sagen würde? Eine Rede so halten würde?
Und was würde das mutmaßlich auslösen?
Also, ich würde mal sagen, liebe, also, keine konstruktive Wende,
sondern nur ein Angebot, um Krawall zu machen.
Jetzt bitte auf die Straße gehen und sagen, ich bin gegen den schwedischen Weg,
das war ich auch vor vier Jahren schon.
Ich lasse die Tür zu.
Ja.
Der schwedische Weg, ah ja.
Jetzt plötzlich.
Einigen sich dann, das habe ich aber jetzt weggelassen, Melanie Amann und Anne
Will darauf, dass vielleicht Annalena Baerbock so eine Rede halten könnte und
das wäre irgendwie toll.
Ja.
Würde ich sagen, naja, vielleicht auch nicht. Wir blicken noch in ein anderes Land.
Lass mal nach Finnland gucken. Das war das andere Beispiel, was mir aufgefallen
ist bei der Suche danach, wie könnte man es anders, bin ich sicher, besser machen.
Auch gerade frisch in der NATO.
Ja, Finnland. Was könnte da wohl sein? Wir erinnern uns, dass wir es auch schon
mal hier im Podcast angekratzt haben, nämlich das hier.
Weite Teile der städtischen Infrastruktur Helsinkis, lerne ich dann,
sind in den felsigen Untergrund der Stadt gesprengt und gegraben worden.
Da sind Schwimmhallen, Eishockeyhallen, Rechenzentren und Museen.
Und bei Neubauprojekten wurden für die 650.000 Einwohner in der Hauptstadt, achte bitte...
Da wurden nämlich ganz viele Bunker gebaut. 50.000 Bunker gibt es insgesamt
ja dort und da finden dann 4,8 Millionen Menschen Platz.
Ich habe das auch nochmal nachgeschaut und die Bevölkerung liegt bei 5,5 Millionen,
also sehr viele kommen rein. Nein, und jetzt ist man plötzlich… Also diese Bunker-Idee.
Ja, die ist ja heute wieder aufgekommen. Ich bin heute Morgen losgefahren und
sah DPA-Meldungen, dass Felser mehr für den Zivilschutz tun will und dass dann
der Herder vom Amt für Bevölkerungsschutz sagte,
dass aktuell das Bundesinnenministerium und das BBK zusammen mit anderen Institutionen
an einem neuen Schutzbau-Konzept arbeiten.
Also ich habe ja einen Bullshit-Sensor, wie wir alle hoffentlich.
Was bedeutet, wenn hier irgendwelche Ideen kommen, wie die Bundeswehr geht jetzt
in Schulen und hat aber gleichzeitig ein Nachwuchsproblem,
dann wissen wir, selbst wenn alle Bundeswehrsoldaten jeden Tag in eine Schule
gehen, erreichen die die 12 Millionen Schülerinnen und Schüler vielleicht in 30 Jahren mal alle.
Also solche Sachen, lasst sie einfach diskutieren. Sollen halt die 500 Bundeswehrsoldaten,
die man hat, in 500 Schulen gehen?
Ist mir doch egal. Es gibt noch 50.000 andere Schulen, die werden davon unbehelligt und so.
Wenn jetzt hier solche Ideen kommen wie, wir brauchen mal einen Bunker und Anne Will trägt schon vor.
Die werden aber dual use mäßig als Sporthallen, Schwimmhallen, Museen benutzt.
Wir in Deutschland kriegen es nicht mal so hin, Sporthallen,
Schwimmhallen und Museen zu bauen.
Jetzt noch unterirdisch, bitte.
Unser großes Leid, die Oper. Also die Oper ist einer der ganz wenigen Räume,
der kein Tageslicht braucht.
Könnte man sofort unter die Erde bauen. Nur sie oberirdisch zu bauen,
kostet schon 1,7 Milliarden Euro.
Sie unterirdisch zu bauen, kostet wahrscheinlich 10,7 Milliarden Euro.
Wird nie passieren. Das sind alles so Nonsens-Diskussionen.
Mit dem Stuttgarter Hauptbahnhof hat das ja super geklappt.
Ja, super Idee, den Stuttgarter Hauptbahnhof mit Lichtfenstern,
also sehr bombensicher ist das dann nicht, unter die Erde zu bauen.
Das Projekt hieß Stuttgart 21 und wer 2024 nach Stuttgart fährt,
steht vor der größten Baustelle Europas.
Das Loch ist immer noch, es ist ein wirklich ganz, vor allem konstruktive Diskussion von dir.
Jetzt muss man sich das mal vorstellen. Man hat jetzt hier eine erfahrene Talkshow-Masterin,
die das 16 Jahre lang gemacht hat,
die eigentlich doch in einem politischen Diskurs drin sein müsste und doch ein
bisschen mehr müsste ihr einfallen, als zu sagen, die haben da ganz viele Bunker.
Und dann hat man Melanie Amann, die meines Wissens stellvertretende Chefredakteurin des Spiegel ist.
Also auch ein hohes Tier im Journalismus und die unterhalten sich dann weiter so darüber.
Und dazu sagt das Bundesamt für Bevölkerungsschutz und Katastrophenhilfe,
dass diese Schutzräume akut nur sehr begrenzt nutzbar seien.
Das ist ja schlecht. 579 davon, ganz wenige nur nutzbar.
Und du hast die Zahlen aus Finnland gehört, wo 900.000 Bunkerplätze für 650.000
Einwohner der Hauptstadt sind. Ich dachte, du wolltest diesen Podcast jetzt
auf einer konstruktiv positiven Note enden lassen.
Stattdessen machst du mir nur immer mehr Angst.
Ich dachte, gut, Zivilverteidigung ist vielleicht irgendwie was.
Ja, es ist, wir müssen, das stimmt schon,
glaube ich, also vielleicht muss ich zu Ende zähneknirschend sagen,
dass natürlich Pistorius irgendwie recht hat, dass dieses Thema Kriegsgefahr
mehr ist als etwas, was man bei der Bundeswehr abladen sollte.
Genau. Ich sag's nur ungerne. Es ist die Bundeswehr, es ist das Land,
es ist die Gesellschaft und der Zivilschutz, ja.
Ja, also wir hören noch ein paar Clips, finde ich auch gut. Wir wollen ja auch
die Comedy-Podcast-Szene mal.
Das ist alles so ein Nonsens. Was haben wir vor vier Jahren diskutiert?
Keine Masken, es wird irgendwie über irgendwelche nahezu illegalen Deals,
plötzlich stehen Leute auf den Gleisen und halten Züge in der Schweiz an,
weil da unsere Masken drin sind und lauter so ein Kram.
Wir haben diesen illegalen Handel, dass mittlerweile einzelne CSU-Mitglieder
für 25 Millionen Steuerhinterziehung, also eine Grundlast von mehreren hundert
Millionen irgendwelche Geschäfte mit Masken gemacht haben.
Und damals war die allergrößte Idee, Masken sind einfach nur Gummi und Papier.
Das wurde noch vor dem Rat erfunden.
Das sollten wir hier machen.
Zwei Jahre später alles nach China gewandert. Deutsche Rückstände,
alle vernichtet worden, weil irgendein Haltbarkeitsdatum oder irgendwas so,
Lass sie doch diskutieren. Lass sie doch über ihren Bunker jetzt reden,
als ob hier irgendwer irgendwo einen Bunker baut.
In einem halben Jahr, wenn Trump gewählt ist und der Friedensvertrag mit Putin
unterzeichnet ist, interessiert das niemand.
Wie kann man nicht mal ganz kurz über was nachdenken? Also dass man es vielleicht
da mit einem kleineren Land und hier mit einem größeren Land zu tun hat.
Also in der Bundesrepublik gab es zu Hochzeiten mal über 2000 Schutzräume und
insgesamt hätten mit Mühe und Not dann 2,3 Millionen Menschen reingepasst.
Wie viele Leute sind wir in Deutschland?
84 Millionen. Also wie soll das gehen?
Ja, sie wünscht sich jetzt 100 Millionen Plätze.
Ihr großer Anne-Will-Podcast präsentierte uns etwas, bei dem ich dachte,
Moment, das war doch schon mal vor einem Jahr. Was war denn da?
Ach ja, da dachte ich, da hat doch Stefan uns mal Clips mitgebracht.
Und deswegen fragte ich dich die Woche über, kannst du mir mal diese Clips geben?
Wir haben doch mal über Bunker geredet. Ja, vor einem Jahr, ZDF heute.
Unter dem Lake Eola Platz in Helsinki liegt ein offenes Geheimnis.
Es ist für alle Finnen offen und zwar rund um die Uhr. und man sieht ihm seine
riesigen Ausmaße weder von außen an noch von den zehn Stockwerken aus,
die man hinabklettern muss, bis man da ist.
An diesem Abend steht die deutsche Außenministerin unter dem Lake Juola Platz
und lässt sich die Toiletten für den Ernstfall zeigen, die Betten für den Ernstfall
und die Hockey-Tore für den Normalfall.
Denn das ist das Geheimnis tief unter Helsinki, dass die 400 Bunker,
die die Bevölkerung im Kriegsfall vor dem Tod retten sollen,
im Frieden voller Leben und Lachen sind.
Ja, und dann gab es in den Tagesthemen auch einen Bericht, der handelte von
den deutschen Schutzräumen.
In Sicherheit vor einem Atomangriff auf das Berlin im Kalten Krieg, so der Plan in den 70ern.
Doch nur wenige hätten davon profitiert. In West-Berlin gab es bis zu 27.000
Bunkerplätze für rund zwei Millionen Menschen.
Wir hatten, und sie sollten eine psychologische Wirkung haben,
sie sollten den Bevölkerungen ein Gefühl auch von Sicherheit vermitteln.
Das finde ich nämlich ganz gut, dass er sagt, es sollte eine psychologische
Wirkung haben. Und das scheint wohl auch bei unseren Hauptstadtjournalisten so zu sein.
Als psychologische Wirkung brauchen sie es, dass sie jetzt mal über Bunker diskutieren.
Doch richtig sicher wäre hier heute keiner mehr. Die letzte große Wartung gab
es 2004, drei Jahre nach 9-11.
Die große Bedrohung war der Terrorismus.
2007 gab Deutschland einen Großteil seiner Schutzräume auf.
Trotzdem vor einem Jahr Baerbock unbeirrt.
Baerbock ist dafür, es den Finnen in Deutschland nachzumachen.
Und erstmals seit Jahren wieder Bunker zu bauen, die aber nicht nur Bunker sind.
Deswegen solche Anlagen so zu bauen, dass sie in friedlichen Zeiten,
die hoffentlich für immer sein werden, genutzt werden können,
aber eine Vorsorge zu treffen, weil Vorsorge ist gerade in diesen Zeiten der beste Schutz.
Ja, bringt man.
So, ich spiele nochmal ad hoc jetzt, ich weiß nicht genau, was kommt.
Ein Clip an, den ich mir gemacht habe aus der Kulturzeit vom 18.01.2023.
Es geht um einen speziellen Bunker.
Im Ahrtal. Unter einem Weinberg.
Hier wollte die Bundesregierung das atomare Inferno überleben.
18 Kilometer Bunkerstollen.
Ein Labyrinth.
Das Besondere an diesem Gebilde ist das Unfassbare.
Das Mariental hat irgendwas um die 5 Milliarden gekostet. Es gibt Schätzungen,
die gehen bis 20 Milliarden.
Die machen das Ding zu dem tausendsten Gebäude der Bundesrepublik.
Und es war immer ohne Sinn und Verstand.
Wir haben hier gehört, Andreas Magdans, Hans, ein Fotograf und Professor für
Fotografie, der mit seinen Studierenden in diesen Bunker geht.
Er hat gesagt, das teuerste Gebäude der Bundesrepublik, 18 Kilometer Stollenlänge und so weiter.
Die Bundesregierung wollte sich damit selbst einen Schutzraum schaffen, also für sich selber.
Und das Projekt war so geheim, dass sie keinen Architekten engagiert haben,
sondern einfach Leute, die sie unter ihrer Knute hatten, als Beamte einfach
losgeschickt haben, hier, grabt mal.
Also das größte Gebäude Deutschlands, das ever gebaut wurde,
ist ein Schutzbunker für die Bundesregierung und er wurde dümmstmöglich konzipiert
und danach einfach versteckt.
Er hat ihn dann wiedergefunden und nutzt ihn jetzt als Kulisse für seine Studenten,
weil sie da Fotos machen. Genau, also da müssen sie ihr eigenes Licht mitbringen
und haben eine geile Kulisse und so, dafür ist es super.
Aber das größte Gebäude Deutschlands war ein Schutzbunker für die Bundesregierung
und sie hat es dümmstmöglich gemacht.
Also irgendwo ist das Ahrtal da unterlöchert, das ist ganz schlimm.
Ja. Gut.
Ich schlage vor, denn mein nächstes Thema ist Höcke gegen Vogt.
Und dein nächstes Thema ist Talkshows.
Dass wir zuerst hören, wie Journalisten über Politik reden. Mhm.
Ich nehme an, ich weiß ungefähr, in welche Richtung das geht und ich dann anschließe
mit, es sollten nur noch Politiker mit Politikern über Politik reden,
es können ja durchaus Journalisten daneben stehen und Begrüßungsworte sprechen, aber.
Das passt mir ganz gut, denn ich habe mal etwas gemacht, ich habe etwas aufgegriffen,
was du irgendwann mal in den Raum gestellt hast, nämlich man muss vielmehr die
Fragen kritisieren, man muss sich mit den Fragen beschäftigen und nicht so sehr
mit den Antworten. Also habe ich folgendes gemacht.
Ich habe einen Bekannten beauftragt, sich sechs Talkshows anzusehen und mir
bitte Clips zu machen, nur von den Fragen der Moderatoren an Politiker.
Ich kenne die Antwort nicht, habe die Talkshows nicht gesehen und lasse mir
nur die Fragen geben und die bekam ich dann ausgesehen.
Es waren über 200 Clips, die habe ich jetzt für uns alle mal durchgehört und
kuratiert und habe dann 80 Clips etwa mitgebracht.
80 Clips? Ja, es ist ja zum Teil sehr schnell, hasten wir da durch.
Und es ist doch erstaunlich, ich hätte es mir so nicht vorgestellt.
Und ich glaube, dass du mit deiner These dann recht haben wirst,
dass es vielleicht besser ist, wenn Politiker sich unterhalten.
Ich bin, sagen wir, maximal entsetzt.
Ja, okay, gut. Als Fernsehpodcast, da bin ich ja da. Schicksalsgemeinschaft, was das angeht.
Karin Miosga ist ja jetzt an den Platz von Anne Will getreten.
Sie hat den Finanzminister zu Gast und man könnte sich ja denken,
ich steige bei Christian Lindner direkt bei den brennenden Fragen ein.
Und genau das hat sie auch getan, denn ich denke, das ist genau das,
was jeder fragen würde, wenn er so eine Stunde Zeit hätte mit Christian Lindner.
So, den ersten Clip klicke ich noch an und dann darfst du 80 klicken.
Darf ich mit dem Jäger beginnen? Sie haben mir eben schon aufmerksam zugehört.
Das machen Sie, seit sechs Jahren haben Sie einen Jagdschein.
Und da könnte man sagen, ist die Einstiegsfrage. Aber hören wir uns Frage 2 an.
Machen Sie es regelmäßig? Ich mache es regelmäßig. Also passionierter Jäger,
wie das richtig heißt im Jargon.
Nächste Frage.
Lieber Ansitz oder Treibjagden?
Und wenn man dann so ein Tier erlegt hat, das heißt glaube ich nicht so,
also wenn man ein Stück zur Strecke gebracht hat, habe ich richtig hoffentlich
gelernt, dann muss man als Schütze auch den Aufbruch selbst machen. Stimmt das?
Kommt denn jetzt vielleicht eine politische Frage?
Fällt Ihnen das schwer, das dann? Wie geht Ihnen das? Wie bricht man das auf? Fällt Ihnen das schwer?
Nein, das nächste Frage. Ich gehe davon aus, klingt alles so,
als könnten Sie dabei entspannen, wenn Sie mal vom politischen Betrieb weit wund geschossen sind.
Wo informiert man sich eigentlich, wenn man jetzt so die wichtigste Polit-Talkshow moderiert?
Aber es bringt Ihnen schon eine Form von Entspannung. Ich habe mal,
ich glaube, in der Bunden gelesen, dass Sie sagen, es würde Ihnen helfen,
auch Abstand zu bekommen und dass Ihnen Kritik auch schwerfällt.
Also, dass Sie sich das auch zu Herzen nehmen.
Welche Kritik ist das? Welche nehmen Sie sich zu Herzen?
Abstand wovon denn? Was ist er denn von Beruf? Ich habe das jetzt bei den ersten zehn Fragen nicht.
Ich glaube, er ist eigentlich Jäger, aber so nebenbei leitet er noch ein Finanzministerium.
Ein wichtiges?
Nee, es ist nicht so wichtig. Es ist der reine Wahnsinn.
Und dann geht auch das weiter nur eigentlich damit, dass sie es mal so hören will.
Wie ist denn das jetzt gerade mit der Koalition und sind sie da eigentlich die Opposition?
Woher kommt denn die mangelnde Zustimmung zur FDP?
Sie haben jetzt zwei Drittel an Zustimmung verloren in den letzten zweieinhalb Jahren.
Könnte es was damit zu tun haben, dass Sie, zumindest ist das unser Eindruck,
Opposition in der eigenen Regierung sind?
Uiuiui, oder?
Haben Sie mir aber noch keine Antwort darauf gegeben, warum Sie in den Umfragen,
zuletzt ist es jetzt ARD Deutschland-Trend, diese Woche bei vier Prozent ist die FDP.
Warum vertrauen Ihnen Ihre Wähler nicht mehr?
Das ist mir aufgefallen, das ist so eine Grundfrage, die wann immer sich der
Moment ergibt, gestellt wird in politischen Talkshows.
Sie sind gerade bei sieben Prozent, sie sind gerade bei 23 Prozent.
Wo wird es sie noch hin entwickeln und was weiß ich.
Das ist also immer dieses, ich gucke in die Umfrage und stelle dann die Frage dazu.
Dazu, die Sache ist die, der Fairness halber sei gesagt, diese Sendung ist ja
noch etwas anders verlaufen deshalb,
weil Jens Südekum da zu Gast war und Jens Südekum dann mal erklärt,
wie irrsinnig das jetzt aktuell mit den Schuldenregeln ist und was man eigentlich machen könnte,
nur übernimmt eigentlich Jens Südekum eigentlich all das, was die Redaktion,
was Karin Miosga und all die Unternehmen sollten,
das kann er natürlich allein gar nicht aufwiegen.
Zudem hat er noch das Problem, dass da eine Journalistin, ich glaube,
das ist die Dunst, Dunst, Dunst, Christina Dunst, oder? Nee, nicht Christina.
Dunst heißt Christina Dunst.
Ja, also die natürlich dann auch nochmal irgendwas zur FDP sagen muss.
Also man hätte dann wenigstens in der, also es gibt ein Aufeinandertreffen von Südekum und Lindner.
Das interessant ist, weil Lindner da argumentativ sich total verirrt.
Notwendigerweise. Aber was geleistet wird von Karim Miosga ist gleich null.
Eigentlich müsste man sagen, es gab Berichte darüber, dass Miosga angeblich
pro Sendung 19.000 Euro bekommt. Weiß ich nicht, ob das stimmt.
Kann man aber in Berichten nachlesen. Diese 19.000 Euro müssten eigentlich nach
dieser Sendung einfach Jens Südeckum überwiesen werden.
Das spielen wir aber nicht, denn wir interessieren uns ja nur für die Fragen der Moderatoren.
Wir sagen noch kurz, Christina Dunz ist ja vor allem dafür berühmt,
Donald Trump die Stirn geboten zu haben. als das deutsche Journalistenchor das
mitflog mit Merkel Trump mal Fragen stellen durfte im Weißen Haus.
Ich gratuliere. Maischberger gibt es auch noch. Wir kommen zu Miosga nochmal zurück.
Aber Maischberger gibt es auch. Und da war Markus Söder zu Gast.
Nun ist es ja so, dass man mit Markus Söder vielleicht nicht so leicht ein gutes
Gespräch führen kann. Naja.
Aber wir hören jetzt erstmal etwas zuvor, bevor Söder auftritt.
Und zwar sitzt er immer diese Runde aus Journalisten, inzwischen auch Comedians,
Schauspieler, wer immer gerade Zeit hat und kommentiert so ein bisschen das Geschehen der Woche.
Das ist immer Hannes Jenicke.
Äh, ja, ich glaube, das ist richtig, aber ich glaube, hier war Kai Pflaume zu Gast.
Ah ja, oder Kai Pflaume.
Nun fragt Maischberger Dagmar Rosenfeld von der Welt Folgendes.
Es gab Kritik an dieser Reise unter anderem von Michael Roth von der SPD,
der sagt, dass es Größenwahn im Stile Ludwigs II.
An welcher Reise?
An der China-Reise von Markus Söder.
Ich verstehe.
Könnt ihr ihn wirklich mal über diese Handelsbeziehungen befragen und was man
eigentlich auf so eine Reise auf den Weg bringt oder welche Hindernisse dort
auftauchen? Aber stattdessen erleben wir das.
Sie wissen, es gibt Kritik, nicht nur wegen dieser Fotos, aber eben auch.
Da gibt es Menschen, die sagen, das ist halt einfach die netten Panda-Bilder,
die man so macht als Tourist.
Aber als bayerischer Ministerpräsident würde man da mit der Propaganda Chinas
auf den Leim gehen. Wie stehen Sie zu dieser Kritik?
Also Sie sind auch nicht der erste bayerische Ministerpräsident, der da ist.
Also Franz Josef Strauß, von dem gerade die Rede war, der war natürlich auch
in China. Es war aber auch Edmund Stolpernchimer und Horst Seehofer.
Und Horst Seehofer hat während seiner Reise oder einer seiner Reisen auch Dissidenten
getroffen. War das eine Überlegung bei Ihnen?
Ja.
Sie haben es nicht öffentlich gemacht. Nein, aber halt im Gespräch.
Aber warum nicht öffentlich?
Es gibt eine Bundeskanzlerin, die besonders häufig in China war.
Angela Merkel ist der Name.
Und die hat es eigentlich nie unterlassen, auch übrigens öffentlich und in China,
folgende Bemerkungen zu machen.
Insofern haben wir auch noch einmal deutlich gemacht, dass für uns erfolgreiche
Wirtschaftsentwicklung und Menschenrechts- und Zivilgesellschaftsentwicklung
ganz eng zusammengehören.
Öffentlich bei einer Pressekonferenz daneben der chinesische Kollege. Also es geht schon.
Das ist ja schon die siebte oder achte Frage. Zu der Frage haben Sie die Menschenrechte angesprochen.
Ein anderes beliebtes Genre im Fernsehen ist ja, Herfried Münkler zu fragen,
der da nochmal aufklärt, als war er immer in Norderstan zu sprechen.
Er hat uns eingelullt in so einer Art, als ob das da jemanden interessiert.
Wir haben doch im Salon das Buch von Heusgen gelesen und Heusgen geht ja auch
darauf ein, was passiert eigentlich, wenn die die Menschenrechte ansprechen.
Das bedeutet, dass man im Hintergrund versucht nochmal deutlich zu machen, dass das,
Manche Dinge sehr ungern gesehen werden. Man versucht vielleicht auch für den
einen oder anderen Dissidenten zum Beispiel, von dem man weiß,
der ist inhaftiert, noch irgendwas rauszuholen.
Also man versucht da diplomatisch gleichzeitig etwas auf den Weg zu bringen.
Man spricht dann die Menschenrechte aber eigentlich in der Form an wie,
hallo Stefan, wir machen jetzt einen Podcast,
lass mich noch gerade dich darauf hinweisen, dass Menschenrechte für mich unerlässlich
sind, dass diese eingehalten werden und das war es im Prinzip.
Also ganz wichtig ist auch, man sollte mal journalistisch nachschauen,
was war denn ein Jahr später mit genau diesen Dissidenten, die Merkel traf oder angesprochen hat.
Und dann könnte man diese Bilanz auch nochmal ziehen, hinsichtlich Semantik
und Struktur, dass es da vielleicht gewisse Differenzen gibt.
Und wenn man doch jetzt hier sitzt mit dem Ministerpräsidenten,
der reist ja nicht als Vertreter Deutschlands und der Menschenrechte dorthin,
sondern der reist als Vertreter der bayerischen Industrie dahin.
Und zwar Mitvertreter der bayerischen Industrie.
Ja, es geht um Direktinvestitionen etc. Das heißt, er hat ein wirtschaftliches Interesse.
Wenn er jetzt dort sitzt mit dem Chi oder mit sonst irgendjemand und haut da
auf die Pauke, dann braucht er die Reise nicht anzutreten, weil das überhaupt
nicht das Ziel dieser Reise ist.
Also indem sie ja selbst anfangs, also in dieser Diskussion da mit Rosenfeld
und den anderen, so zweimal sagt, naja, aber der ist ja aus wirtschaftlichen
Gründen, also hat sie sich doch eigentlich selbst schon die Antwort gegeben,
indem man sagt, ja, der reist aus wirtschaftlichen Gründen hin,
also sollte man ihn doch genau zu diesen wirtschaftlichen Dingen befragen.
Es geht aber immer so weiter.
Und wie genau haben Sie es angesprochen? Also was haben Sie denen gesagt?
Haben Sie denn zum Beispiel abhängig gemacht, zum Beispiel die Handelsbeziehungen
dann eben auch von der Einhaltung der Menschenrechte? Das war eine Forderung
zum Beispiel von der Gesellschaft für bedrohte Völker.
Ob er die Industriepolitik abhängig gemacht hat von der Lage der Menschenrechte,
hat sie ihn gerade gefragt.
Gut, dann brauche ich ja gar nicht losfahren.
Da würde Münkler jetzt wieder ein großes Referat über die Naivität der Deutschen halten.
Also ich will nur mal kurz, weil es passt, es ist ja nicht nur Söder da gewesen,
Scholz war ja auch da. Und das, was früher die Menschenrechte waren,
ist ja jetzt der Ukraine-Krieg.
Scholz hat natürlich den Ukraine-Krieg angesprochen, das hörte sich dann...
Da habe ich Präsident Xi gebeten, auf Russland einzuwirken, damit Putin seinen
irrenwirtsinnigen Feldzug endlich abbricht, seine Truppen zurückzieht und diesen
furchtbaren Krieg beendet.
Kein Wort von Olaf Scholz, wie Staats- und Parteichef Xi Jinping darauf reagierte.
Ja, was wäre denn los, wenn jetzt der Scholz sagt, aber der Xi,
der hat da nur die Augen verdreht und da war es dann nicht.
Also was ist denn das für ein Kindergarten? Aber in dieser Art ist ja wohl jetzt
wo journalistische Berichterstattung, also das war doch in dieser Gerhard-Schröder-Doku
auch, dass der Journalist dann Schröder fragte, ja und haben Sie Putin mal gefragt,
warum man das gemacht hat?
Und dann sagt ja Schröder, ja wir machen ja jetzt kein Märchen.
Also ich frage den doch nicht, warum haben Sie das dann gemacht?
Nee, das ist wirklich, das ist alles Comedy-Produktion.
Ja, und man will eigentlich nur dieses, ich treibe den Politiker in irgendeine
Enge und dann mal gucken, was passiert. Geht immer so weiter.
Sie haben es gesagt, es ist Real- statt Moralpolitik. Ist das ein Seitenheb
gegen Frau Baerbock? Nein.
Sondern? Das hat meine Auffassung. Sie hat den chinesischen Präsidenten einen Diktator genannt.
Ja, das muss sie selber entscheiden. Es ist ja auch das Problem,
dass wir in der Bundesregierung, glaube ich, nicht ganz einig sind. Das ist Moralpolitik.
Jetzt kommen wir nochmal zu den Menschenrechten.
Das war gerade nicht das Thema, sondern letztlich bei den Menschenrechten geht
es um Produktion. Sie haben mich gefragt zu Frau Baerbock.
Beispielsweise in Xinjiang, wo eben die Uiguren dann Zwangsarbeit verrichten müssen.
Da haben wir gemeinsam eine ganz klare Auffassung. Haben Sie angesprochen wahrscheinlich.
So, jetzt kam es eben schon. Baerbock hat ja gesagt, wir wissen es,
Xi ist ein Diktator. Sagt Söder das auch?
Einer, der Ihrer Meinung ist, den zeigen wir jetzt. Sie haben es vielleicht
vorher in der Dokumentation gesehen, Gerhard Schröder, in einer Dokumentation
mit unter anderem diesen Worten.
Ich halte das für überflüssig, das
öffentlich zu sagen als deutscher Außenminister. Das kann man ja meinen.
Aber ob man als deutsche Außenministerin das Staatsoberhaupt Chinas so bezeichnen
sollte, ist eine Frage, die auch mit Professionalität zu tun hat.
Und die ist offenkundig im Auswärtigen Amt eher unterentwickelt.
Gegenwärtig. War ja nicht immer so.
Das ist komisch, ne? Ich wollte gerne wissen, ob Sie den Präsidenten Chinas
auch in die Nähe eines Diktators rücken würden.
Also, Maischberger nennt ihn selbst den Präsidenten Chinas.
Dann kann sie doch erstmal anfangen, wenn sie der Meinung ist,
dass es ein Diktator ist, ihn Diktator zu nennen.
Genauso wie alle Journalisten zum Thema Putin.
Es wird uns immer beschrieben, dass Putin so ein Diktator ist,
aber er wird nicht Diktator genannt.
Wieso fangen Sie nicht einfach damit an? Ich wäre total dafür,
dass man jetzt einfach sagt, Diktator Putin,
allein weil die Aufmerksamkeitsspange des völlig unbedarften und zu Recht davon
eben nicht weiter befassten Publikums, einfach da fasst man mit Diktator,
schafft man halt einen anderen Denkrahmen auf, der dann auch viel besser passt.
Nur wenn sich die Journalisten selber nicht durchringen können und dann,
das ist ja wirklich eine totale Quatschfrage.
Sind Sie bereit, den Präsidenten Chinas einen Diktator zu nennen?
Da musst du doch nur sagen, nee, genauso wenig wie Sie. Ich bin nicht bereit,
den Präsidenten Chinas, Zitat Maischberger, einen Diktator zu nennen.
Vor allem, was ist denn das für eine Vorstellung von einem Interview?
Also ich würde fast mal sagen, hört mal auf, jedes Interview so zu machen,
dass ihr jemanden entlarven wollt.
Versucht doch mal mit einem Erkenntnisinteresse reinzugehen.
Also ich nehme ja ungern Söder in Schutz,
aber vielleicht hätte Söder von dieser Reise ja etwas Interessantes berichten
können, was uns weiterhilft im Verständnis von Geopolitik und wirtschaftlichen
Verflechtungen. Das wäre ja möglich.
Nur wenn der bayerische Ministerpräsident dorthin reist in dem Auftrag,
etwas für die bayerische Wirtschaft zu tun und dann eine Woche später an einer
Talkshow sagen würde, und Xi ist ein Diktator,
dann hätte er ja diese Reise sich schenken können, denn dann wird China sicherlich
seine Konsequenzen daraus ziehen. Stattdessen macht man immer weiter.
Ist es denn eine Diktatur?
Naja, auf jeden Fall ist es keine
liberale Demokratie, so wie wir sie vorstellen können. Was ist es denn?
Weiter.
Auch wenn die Partner schwierig sind. Wie würden Sie es denn nennen?
Sie sagen, es ist keine liberale Demokratie, es ist aber auch keine Diktatur. Was ist es denn?
Ja, was sollten Sie denn sagen, Frau Marschberger? Was ist es denn?
Und jetzt?
Die CSU hat früher sehr klar gesagt, dass die kommunistischen Systemen Diktaturen sind.
Die CSU ist ein kommunistisches System mit einer klaren, völlig autoritären
Struktur, die wir so nicht... Aber keine Diktatur.
Das Interessante ist ja schon das, wie man dann den Handel und den Wandel dann...
Ich frage mich immer, ich finde es eine spannende Diskussion, Frau Maischberg.
Darf ich das mal sagen? Ja, unbedingt. Warum wir in Deutschland Meister,
Weltmeister im Wortglauben sind, aber nicht Weltmeister mehr der Produktion
und der Schaffung von Arbeit. Das ist nicht der Punkt.
Ich finde es schade. Nein, der Punkt ist tatsächlich, wenn Sie sagen,
dass Sie Dialog statt Abgrenzung eben machen wollen, Wandel durch Handel wäre
das ja... Ich bin gespannt, was der Bundeskanzler gesagt hat,
wenn er Xi Jinping trifft.
Ich bin sehr gespannt. Ja, aber Sie sind ja nicht der Kanzler. Noch nicht jedenfalls.
Es geht darum, wenn man mit Leuten Geschäfte macht, wo dann tatsächlich,
wir haben es ja gerade am Beispiel Russland diskutiert, wo sind da die Grenzen?
Es gibt einen Mann, der gesagt hat, das Prinzip Frieden durch Handel ist mit
Blick auf Russland zunehmend, aber auch auf China vorerst gescheitert.
Wissen Sie, wer das gesagt hat? Nein, aber Sie sagen es mir bestimmt.
Alexander Dobrindt, CSU-Landeschef. Und es steht in einem Papier der Fraktion,
also der Unionsfraktion im Bundestag, da steht es genau so.
Frieden durch Handel ist gegenüber China gescheitert. Eine kommunistische Führung
in China, die nach Globalisierung unter ihrer Vorherrschaft strebt,
die Staatswirtschaft betreibt, die offen, ideologiegetrieben,
hegemonial, dabei auch militärisch agiert, droht auf Dauer kein verlässlicher
Handelspartner zu sein.
Und da muss man sich dann schon die Frage stellen, wie man Handelsbeziehungen
gestaltet. Genau. Das ist Herr Dobrindt und ihre Fraktion.
Sind Sie der Außenseiter dann in der Union?
Ja, und dann hätte man ja mal fragen können, und wie gestalten Sie denn die
Handelsbeziehungen zu China?
Und wie gestalten wir sie in Deutschland zu ganz vielen anderen Ländern,
die nicht demokratisch sind, die diktatorisch ziemlich organisiert sind und
die Menschenrechte verletzen?
Also ich habe nachher auch noch so einen kleinen Rundown, um zu zeigen,
dass Söder wirklich die dümmstmögliche Industriepolitik aller bayerischen Ministerpräsidenten macht.
Mittlerweile gehen ja wirklich im,
hohen, einstelligen Milliardenbereich in Einzelinvestitionen einfach an Bayern
vorbei. Obwohl das urbayerische Technik ist, zum Beispiel Batterien.
Diese Reise nach China scheint mir noch das Klügste zu sein,
was Söder die letzten Jahre gemacht hat.
Oder diesen pragmatischen Gesichtspunkten, dass es jetzt auch nicht hilft,
einfach die ganze Welt abzufackeln.
Sondern man hier auch einfach mal ein bisschen Vernunft walten lassen kann.
Möchte man wohl jetzt im politischen Berlin.
Und das ist das, was Herr Dobrindt gesagt hat, Wandel durch Handel oder eben,
wie es jetzt heißt, Frieden durch Handel ist eine Illusion, weil diese Länder das nur ausnutzen.
Am Ende werden sie die eigenen Interessen nur bestärken, sie werden sich nicht
ändern und wir sind am Ende abhängig. Das ist genau das, was Herr Dobrindt sagt.
Genau, abhängig ist ja nicht das Ziel. Das ist ja genau das Gegenteil.
Ja, aber die Frage ist, wo ist dann die Grenze?
Und noch eine Frage.
Aber wir machen ja im Moment keinen Handel mit Russland. Aus guten Gründen oder nicht? Ja, natürlich.
Was machen Sie, wenn China Taiwan überfällt? Ja, dann wird sich die Lage komplett
ändern. Was heißt das für die bayerischen Firmen dann?
Ja, dann werden die bayerischen Firmen vielleicht ein Problem haben.
Also, wir erleben da einfach 20, 25, 30 Minuten nur Nonsens-Gespräch.
Die letzte Frage ist wirklich kompletto inkonsistent. Sie wollte die ganze Zeit,
bitte opfern Sie unsere Industrie, damit Sie dort die Menschenrechte ansprechen
können. Das hat sie ja gewollt die ganze Zeit.
Und dann am Ende zu sagen, ja und was ist, wenn die jetzt Taiwan überfallen?
Das ist ja auch nicht gut für die Bayerische Industrie.
Und dann hätte sie dann sagen müssen, ja genau. Genau, also wenn Taiwan überfallen
wird von China, ja dann können wir auch jetzt einfach anfangen ihn Diktator
zu nennen, weil dann ändert sich nämlich alles.
Also vorher über den, nein wir wollen es nicht ändern, wir müssen es jetzt hier
und so weiter und dann dreht sich es komplett um und sagt, aber das ist dann
die Bedrohung für die bayerische Industrie, die ja so die ganze Zeit, für die macht er das ja.
Und daraus können wir doch den Schluss schon mal ziehen. Die gehen wieder besseres
Wissen in ein solches Interview rein und führen nur ein Spektakel auf.
Weil Dobrindt da einen Vortrag halten hat.
Sie könnten ein kluges Gespräch auch mit Söder führen. Ich glaube,
dass das möglich ist. Aber sie sind nicht daran interessiert.
Bist du bereit für meinen persönlichen Höhepunkt?
Natürlich.
Und zwar Karin Miosga, Lars Klingenbeil war dort zu Gast.
Ich sag mal so, nachdem ich jetzt Miosga häufiger gehört habe,
vor allem in Micky Beisengerts Podcast, Ich kann es gar nicht,
aber ja, und ich bin auch total, das ist ganz wichtig, dass wir auch diese Sachen hören und so weiter.
Mit so einer ganz weichen Stimme, die ich natürlich, ich habe ja keine weibliche
Stimme, mit einer ganz weiblichen Stimme muss dann so gesagt werden und so weiter und so fort.
Und am Ende hat man so eine Stunde zugehört und es ist nichts passiert.
Ja, wir erfahren aber vielleicht was über die Musik.
Klingmer, ich kenne einen Elftklässler, der hatte mal einen Rat für Sie.
Bloß nicht in die Politik gehen, ist viel zu anstrengend.
Dieser Elfklässler hat mal ein Praktikum gemacht im niedersächsischen Landtag
und heißt Lars Klingbeil.
Tja, wie kann das sein?
Können Sie gut mit Leuten, die einen anderen Musikgeschmack haben?
Also von Ricarda Lang weiß ich, dass sie Taylor Swift mag.
Und bei Christian Lindner weiß ich nur, dass er mal »Hurra, wir leben noch«
von Milva öffentlich gesungen hat.
Das kenne ich nicht mehr. Können Sie da etwas Toleranz sein?
Also, ist das eine wichtige Frage, die man stellen sollte? Oder warum brauchen
die jetzt so ein Warm-up? Also die kennen sich ja.
Diese Politiker und diese Talkshow-Moderatoren sehen sich ja jede Woche.
Die sehen sich ja häufiger als wir beide.
Warum macht man, wenn man wenig Zeit hat, immer solche merkwürdigen Warm-ups?
Und dass Lars Klingbeil Milwa nicht kennt, finde ich natürlich skandalös,
aber ich brauche die Info eigentlich auch nicht.
Da diese Sendungen mit mehrere tausend Euro pro Minute abgerechnet werden und
mehrere Millionen Menschen erreichen, ist es ganz wichtig, dass man sich da
Zeit nimmt für ein Warm-up.
Sonst geht das noch schief.
Ja, ja.
Sie machen nie zusammen Musik mal in der Ampel.
Ja, die Ampel macht nicht zusammen Musik.
Nee, wir spielen Fußball und da ist ja auch ein AfDler im Bundesliga-Dings hier im Bundestag.
Wir machen weiter mit Musik.
Dies ist nicht die Zeit für Fragen. Dies ist nicht die Zeit zu weinen.
Dies ist nicht die Zeit zu schlafen, während wir kämpfen.
Dies ist nicht die Zeit zu sterben. Sie wissen, von wem das ist.
Ich vermute, es kommt von Präsident Zelensky. Oh nein.
Mal auf Englisch. This is not the time to wonder.
Hey, Fury in the Slaughterhouse. Genau. Sorry, ich habe gerade eine ähnliche
Rede von Präsident Zelensky gedacht. Aber wir sind bei Fury in the Slaughterhouse.
Aber die Parallele stimmt natürlich.
Das muss man den Leuten jetzt erklären. Das ist ein Hit, Time to Wonder.
Muss man den Leuten jetzt erklären.
Ich glaube schon, einer ihrer Jugendbands aus Hannover. Eine Band,
die ich auch viel nachgespielt habe, wo ich gerne auf Konzerten war.
Und die ist mir unangenehm, dass sie mir das gerade nicht aufkommt.
Also das finde ich jetzt auch bedenklich.
Aber das zeigt eben auch, wie alt ich mittlerweile bin und dass die Jugend schon sehr lange her ist.
Okay, Entschuldigung bei Fury in the Slaughterhouse. Aber wo sie selber schon
die Parallele zu Sezenski gezogen haben, das könnte eine Ukraine-Hymne sein, oder?
Du hast jemanden beauftragt, diese Clips zu machen.
Ja.
Lebt dieser Mensch noch?
Ich habe ihn dafür bezahlt.
Ausreichend?
Ausreichend dafür bezahlt, ja. Ich habe ihn dafür bezahlt. Es war also nicht
ein Freundschaftsdienst, das kann man niemandem zumuten.
Nee, irgendwo hören Freundschaftsdienste auf. Ein Umzug, ja.
Das zu kuratieren hat mich schon fertig gemacht. Aber ja, also dem Menschen geht es gut.
Ich bin Fury in a slaughterhouse.
Er soll sich einen schönen Tag heute machen. Es ist eine Katastrophe,
dass das jetzt hier die große neue Talkshow ist.
Und wir haben es jetzt schon gemerkt, es geht jetzt rüber zum großen Thema Ukraine.
Und wir hören jetzt mal, was da jetzt eigentlich von Miosga angepeilt ist.
Bevor wir gleich über den Inhalt reden, was Rolf Mütze nicht gesagt hat.
Sie waren ja im Bundestag, wir haben Sie klatschen gesehen.
Ist Ihnen aufgefallen, wer alles nicht applaudiert hat? Ja.
Nämlich, dass keiner applaudiert hat. Kein einziger die Hand gehoben hat zum
Applaus. Was sagt Ihnen das?
Sieht nicht so aus. Gibt weiter Proteste und Widersprüche, auch in der Ampel.
Aber wir wollen jetzt vor allem über Rolf Mützenich reden.
Sie haben applaudiert, wir haben es gesehen. Krieg einfrieren.
Also das Thema ist jetzt Rolf Mützenich.
Also Lars Klingweil muss jetzt so deutlich machen, dass er die Position von
Rolf Mützenich versteht, aber auch Probleme damit hat. und trotzdem,
dass das eine Pluralität in der Partei ist.
Das scheint wohl, worauf das Ganze hinausläuft.
Also man kann auch hier kein vernünftiges Gespräch mit Klingbeil führen über
jetzt wirklich interessante Positionen. Was wäre denn zum Beispiel militärisch
zu tun, zu unterlassen, all das.
Sondern es geht jetzt nur darum, wie rechtfertigt er, dass Rolf Mütze nicht dies und das gesagt hat.
Aber was das heißt, das wollen wir auch den Zuschauern nochmal zeigen,
wenn wir uns eine Karte der Ukraine angucken.
Das können wir jetzt mal machen. Dann kann man nämlich ganz deutlich sehen,
was es hieße, frören wir jetzt diesen Krieg ein.
Also, die blauen Teile ist dann das, was ukrainisches Staatsgebiet wäre.
Und in dem grün schraffierten Teil würden Hunderttausende Ukrainerinnen und
Ukrainer unter russischer Herrschaft leben.
Und Sie wissen, was das bedeutet, das wissen wir aus den besetzten Gebieten.
Verfolgung, Verschleppung, Vergewaltigung, die Identität müssten sie aufgeben.
Das wissen wir alles und das weiß ….
Jetzt können wir ja mal darüber nachdenken, was hier insinuiert wird und was
jetzt jemand wie Rolf Mütze nicht gemeint haben könnte.
Also sagt er, und die überlassen wir ihrem Schicksal und wenn die da versteppt
werden, dann ist es halt so.
Oder würde man eine Einfrierung des Krieges beispielsweise an die Bedingung
stellen, dass es dort unabhängige Beobachter gibt, die aufpassen,
dass es dort keine Menschenrechtsverletzungen gibt, keinen Völkerrechtsbruch etc.
Das wären ja Fragen, die man stellen könnte. Das wird aber allefach hier so
gesetzt. Also ich finde es schon erstaunlich, wie sehr auch die Meinung so klar wird.
Das war auch das Amüsante bei diesem Podcast mit Anne Will, dass Anne Will bei
Matze Hitscher sagte, ja und jetzt kann ich auch mal selbst so Positionen beziehen.
So als würden wir die Positionen dieser ganzen Hosts nicht eins zu eins kennen.
Also wir würden doch wirklich aus allen Wolken fallen, wenn jetzt Anne Will sagen würde,
die sollen mal endlich aufhören Waffen zu liefern oder die würde jetzt sagen,
wir müssen jetzt radikal umverteilen, wir müssen da an die Vermieter ran,
dann würde man ja wirklich sagen, achso und das hat die jetzt über Jahre verborgen.
Aber wer weiß, was noch kommt. Der Peter-Hane-Erfahrung, die wir alle gemacht haben.
Ja, aber dann meistens in die andere, schlimme Richtung. Also das ist doch so
unglaublich, dass diese Position, dieser Haus doch so zentristisch und offensichtlich
sind, dass man doch gar nicht mehr darüber diskutieren muss.
Und hier bei Miosga wird es besonders deutlich immer, wofür sie eigentlich steht.
Nein, es gibt Zweifel daran, wenn ihr Fraktionsvorsitzender immer wieder solche
Dinge sagt. Und das ist nicht zum ersten Mal. Da kann ich Sie völlig beruhigen.
Mir klingt es immer wieder im Ohr, dass Rolf Mütze nicht immer sagt,
wer, wenn nicht wir, müssen mehr Diplomatie in diesem Konflikt fordern.
Und wissen Sie, lassen Sie mich ausreden, was das unterschlägt,
dass diese Diplomatie längst gibt.
Sie haben es schon angesprochen, seitdem Präsident Zelensky die Friedensformel
formuliert hat im Herbst 2022, gibt es unendlich viele Formate mit 80 Staaten,
die sich darüber Gedanken machen, wie dieser Krieg zu Ende gehen kann,
Was dann nachgeschehen kann. Und all diese Leute sind...
Da geht ja noch eine halbe Minute. Ich will jetzt einen Anker werfen,
einen kognitiven Anker.
Wir haben jetzt schon gehört, wie sie solche Floskeln machte.
Wie, lassen Sie mich ausreden. Oder, das macht ihr auch nicht zum ersten Mal.
Das setzt ja an, an so eine deutsche Erzieherpraxis. Also jeder Deutsche,
der das hört, ist so kulturell direkt auf so einem, oh Gott,
die Mama und so, hat irgendwas.
Und gleichzeitig aber diese sanfte, säuselnde, sehr viel Luft in der Stimme.
Vielleicht ist das viel wichtiger als so inhaltlich, dass man nochmal so diesen
Ton, lassen Sie mich ausreden, also einfach diese Einnordung auch des Zuschauers.
Klingbeil sozusagen nur stellvertretend da sitzt, weil der Vater wieder Scheiße gemacht hat.
Das ist ein sehr guter Punkt. Darüber habe ich auch nachgedacht.
Warum sitzen die eigentlich da?
Also den Söder, der soll jetzt auch eingenordet werden.
Also Söder kann natürlich, und das weiß sie ja vorher, also Söder wird nicht
in diese Talkshow kommen und also das weiß Maischberger vorher,
wird nicht sagen, der Chies ist ein Diktator und mit dem sollten wir alle Handelsbeziehungen
abbrechen, denn das Gegenteil sollte ja seine Reise bezwecken.
Warum macht man trotzdem genau
dieses Interview, als könne dieser Satz bei Söder am Ende bei rauskommen?
Ja, damit das Publikum genau das denkt, damit das Publikum sagt,
ja genau, sie ist der Diktator, das hat die heute auch nochmal erklärt.
Jetzt geht es darum, wie verhält man sich zur Ukraine, sollte man vielleicht
doch mal über Diplomatie nachdenken, nein, das wird jetzt am Exempel Mützenich-Klingbeil
uns deutlich gemacht, dass das gar nicht geht.
Kontakt mit Ländern, die Herr Mütze nicht auch in seiner Rede genannt hat,
Brasilien, China, die gar nicht
auf unserer Seite sind, die aber Einfluss hätten auf Präsident Putin.
Das Problem ist, Präsident Putin will nicht verhandeln.
Ich möchte Ihnen gerne einen O-Ton vorspielen, den er diese Woche im russischen
Fernsehen gesagt hat, was er von Verhandlungen hält.
Jetzt zu verhandeln, nur weil ihnen jetzt die Munition ausgeht,
ist für uns irgendwie lächerlich.
Mit wem will man da im Kreml verhandeln von Seiten der SPD?
Ja, ich sehe jetzt auch bei Putin nicht viele Signale zum Verhandeln,
aber das ist ja gerade der Witz.
Wenn man in Verhandlungen tritt, wird natürlich nach außen erstmal so getan,
als würde man nicht verhandeln.
Also der wird ja nicht im Fernsehinterview jetzt sagen, ich würde gern verhandeln,
leider hat mich noch keiner angerufen, sondern das passiert ja dann über die
diplomatischen Wege und dann wird verhandelt und das wird aber nicht vorher
schon angekündigt im Fernsehinterview, ich bin bereit zu verhandeln.
Also das vorzuspielen sagt genau gar nichts aus, es wäre ja geradezu idiotisch
strategisch jetzt von einer oder anderen Seite öffentlich erst zu bekennen,
dass man verhandeln will, ehe man das diplomatisch in die Wege geleitet hat.
Ja, wir haben das ja bei diesem... ehemaligen, ich weiß gar nicht,
aus dem diplomatischen Dienst, der da auch für Gaza so viel Geiselbefreiung
damals vor Jahrzehnten mitverhandelt hat, man macht natürlich dieses Bargaining.
Also man geht erstmal mit All-In und so weiter und dann ganz plötzlich wird
halt verhandelt, aber nicht in dem alle so ja, oh ja, jetzt hatte ich eigentlich
schon Lust zu verhandeln und so, weil dann befährt man sich halt gegenseitig.
Wir gehen es aber mal ein bisschen schneller durch. Weiter Mütze nicht.
Was das für Auswirkungen hat und was das für ein Signal nach außen gibt.
Ihr Fraktionsvorsitzender ist ja nicht irgendwer.
Rolf Mützenich ist doch kein Hintergeglacht. Aber was ist denn das für eine
Debattenkultur in diesem Land, wenn man diese Frage nicht mal stellen darf?
Wenn Rolf Mützenich so einen Satz im Deutschen Bundestag formuliert,
dann hört man das in Moskau, dann hört man das in Kiew, dann hört man das bei
allen internationalen Partnern, die nicht müde werden, immer zu sagen,
wir werden die Ukraine so lange unterstützen, bis sie ihr Territorium zurück haben.
Und aus dem Deutschen Bundestag kommt das Signal, Krieg einfrieren.
Lassen Sie uns wenigstens darüber nachdenken.
Haben Sie sich geärgert, dass Sie besonders viel Applaus von dem AfD-Vorsitzenden
bekommen haben und er bittet Sie, standhaft zu bleiben in dieser Position?
Oder auch eine schöne Frage.
Weil die ganz besonders gut ankommen im Osten, dort, wo im Herbst gewählt wird
in den drei ostdeutschen Ländern.
Versuchen Sie jetzt auch, in diese Richtung Wahlkampf zu machen und sich besonders,
das fällt ja auf, dass die SPD sich als Friedenspartei positionieren möchte.
Und noch eine Frage.
Wir wollen diesen Krieg beenden alle und alle möchten Frieden.
Das Problem ist aber, dass die Leute, die jetzt Waffen liefern,
wollen, dass die Ukraine in eine Position der Stärke kommt.
Wenn Rolf Mützenich sagt, wir wollen jetzt einfrieren, dann ist die Ukraine
in einer Position der Schwäche.
Einfach 20 Fragen zu dieser einen Formulierung Krieg einfrieren.
Nicht einmal wird gefragt, wie sieht eigentlich ein Einfrieren eines Krieges
aus, denn das wäre ja in der Tat interessant zu erfahren.
Es funktioniert ja nicht wie mit einem Becher Wasser, den man einfriert,
sondern Krieg einfrieren scheint sich irgendwie anders zu gestalten.
Da könnte man, wenn man ein Erkenntnisinteresse
hätte, jetzt einiges zu sagen, ist aber nicht der Fall.
Und so geht es dann, wenn man da irgendwann am Ende angelangt ist,
nur noch darum, ja, wie steht der Kanzler denn da und wie sieht Klingenbeil
denn, dass der Kanzler da steht?
Herr Klingenbeil, Sie sprechen ja oft, sind viel unterwegs mit Orts- und Kreisverbänden.
Wie oft müssen Sie den Kanzler erklären und rechtfertigen?
Da würde ich einfach darauf antworten, 26 Mal.
Ja, also hier stellt sich eh die Frage, warum reden die überhaupt noch mit Journalisten?
Das ist ja nirgendwo in der westlichen Welt so wie in Deutschland.
Also der französische Präsident macht solche Interviews nicht und sein Kabinett auch nicht.
In England, die BBC, die hat quasi nie Regierungsmitglieder im Gespräch.
In Amerika gibt es Debatten darüber, dass nicht mal Obama in den zwölf Monaten
vor einer Wahl auch nur ein Interview führt mit irgendeinem Journalisten. Hier die ganze Zeit.
Klingbeil könnte auch einfach da sitzen und sagen, naja, das sind alles tolle
Fragen, aber glauben Sie, hier ändert sich irgendwas?
Die nächsten Bundestagswahlen sind in zwei
Jahren und bis dahin sind die Mehrheitsverhältnisse, wie sie sind. Ja.
Nichts ändert hieran irgendetwas. So. Also, da wird eigentlich so eine Fata
Morgana an, wir haben hier so einen Zugriff auf die Politiker,
weil wir sie im Gespräch haben oder sowas. Das ist ja alles einfach gar nicht wahr.
Also, die ganzen Journalistinnen lügen ja auch dem Publikum was vor.
Also zeigen da so eine bewegliche Masse, wo irgendwas noch mitentschieden werden
kann, wo einfach nichts mitentschieden werden kann. Das ist wie,
da sagt er, ein Partizipationstheater.
Wir stehen halt als dass Zuschauer irgendwie und gucken ein bisschen zu, aber mehr ist da nicht.
Wie kann es sein, dass diese Shows jeden Abend noch geschaut werden?
Also das ist ja das Erstaunliche, dass diese Shows beliebt sind.
Und ich glaube, es liegt daran, dass die Fragen vergessen werden und man nur
so ein Aufeinandertreffen von Leuten sehen will. Also weiter heißt es dann.
Frau Bobrowski, 76 Prozent nach einer jüngsten Infratest-DiMAG-Umfrage sind
unzufrieden mit der Arbeit des Kanzlers. Wie erklären Sie das?
Ja, jetzt sind sie gerade wieder unzufrieden. Nächste Woche macht Scholz irgendwas,
dann sind sie wieder zufrieden. Wie erklären sie sich das?
Was sind das denn für Fragen, die hier gestellt werden? Also ich bin sehr erbost
darüber, dass wir jetzt die ganze Zeit nur so Diskussionen haben,
wie schlimm TikTok ist für den Zusammenhalt in der Gesellschaft und das politische Klima und so.
Diese Talkshows verblöden in solcher Weise die Leute, dass man einfach sagen
muss, nee, man kann um alles froh sein, was sich irgendwo bei TikTok rumtreibt
und nicht mehr diese Talkshows.
Soweit würde ich nicht gehen?
Ja, ich gehe soweit. Also ich bin ja inzwischen da sehr anarchisch unterwegs,
dass ich sage, hauptsache es passiert irgendwas, weil das ist ja nicht auszuhalten.
Und da spielt die Kommunikation und deswegen noch einmal wollen wir darauf zurückkommen,
dass Kanzler ist eine große Rolle.
Uns ist nämlich aufgefallen und wir sind nicht die einzigen,
denen das auffällt, dass der Kanzler sich gerne mal, wenn er sich über den Bundestag
an die Bevölkerung richtet, sich einer ganz bestimmten berühmten Liedzeile bemächtigt.
You'll never walk alone.
Dass wir gemeinsam die schwierigen Zeiten bewältigen, dass wir zusammenhalten, das ist entscheidend.
You'll never walk alone. Das ist das Motto dieser Regierung.
Die Bürgerinnen und Bürger können darauf vertrauen, dass der Staat seine Zusagen
ihnen gegenüber einhält. You'll never walk alone.
Das habe ich im vergangenen Jahr versprochen und dabei bleibt es.
Da muss ich jetzt natürlich den fußballliebenden Musiker zuerst fragen.
You Never Walk Alone ist eigentlich ein Broadway-Stück, das gecovert wurde 1963
von Gary and the Pacemakers.
Und seitdem ist es die Fußballhymne.
Auch in Deutschland, jetzt nicht bei Ihrem Verein in Bayern,
aber zum Beispiel in Dortmund.
Größtmögliche Gefühle, die ganze Tribüne flippt völlig aus.
Was hat dieser Bundeskanzler, der besonnen ist, der zurückhaltend ist,
der distanziert ist, dessen Lieblingswort sorgfältig ist, mit so großen Gefühlen zu tun?
Ja, Gegenfrage, was hat diese Frage in einer politischen Talkshow zu tun?
Also wollen die jetzt alle Hotel Matze spielen? Also das scheint es jetzt zu
sein, dass jetzt alle Hosts sagen, ich muss menscheln, ich muss die Gefühle
herauskitzeln aus meinem Gast.
Das stimmt, das ist alles Hotel Matze.
Es ist nicht nur Haushalten. Und jetzt aber interessant, es ist nicht nur Gefühl,
sondern man sieht dann doch jetzt auch wieder diese Miosga-Haltung und sie rechnet
jetzt mal vor, wie toll denn auch eigentlich das war, was schon geleistet wurde.
Es ist interessant, und das ist im Film auch schon angeklungen,
Herr Scholarik, dass ja viele sozialdemokratische Projekte innerhalb dieser
Ampel durchgesetzt wurden.
Mindestlohn, Bürgergeld, Rente,
über die wir gleich noch ein bisschen detaillierter sprechen wollen.
Warum verfängt das nicht, auch wenn die tatsächlich erfolgreiche Politik gemacht haben?
Sorry, weil die Inflation bei 15 Prozent war.
Und die Bürgergeldempfänger jetzt halt nur nicht mehr Hartz IV empfangen.
Wir werden übrigens einen neuen Grundbegriff lernen im Salon. Desinflation.
Es gibt Inflation, Preise gehen hoch, und Deflation ist Minus.
Also es ist nicht nur Stagnation, sondern das hatten wir ja lange als Gefahr,
dass der Anreiz ausbleibt, weil alles im Preis billiger wird.
Und jetzt hat man die Desinflation. Und das halte ich für Deutschland einen
sehr wichtigen Grundbegriff, denn nachdem die Inflation ja nicht mehr bei 10%
war, sondern nur noch bei 5%, haben wir ja diese Kolleginnen hier,
Maischberger und so, gefragt,
ja, war deswegen die Bürgergeldanhebung zu hoch?
Weil die Inflation ist ja gar nicht mehr bei 10%. Dass aber eine Desinflation,
immer noch Inflation ist,
die nur sinkt und deswegen die 10% trotzdem absolviert wurden und nicht zurückgenommen
wurden, das steckt ja in der Denke gar nicht drin. Dafür braucht man echt diesen Begriff Desinflation.
Ja, die Preise sinken nicht.
Ne, die Preise sinken nicht, nur weil die Inflation runtergeht.
Die steigen nicht mehr so stark. Das ist es.
Grotesk.
Jetzt wird aber hier so langsam eingeschworen auf das, was es ankommt.
Also wir werden mal so, achtet mal alle drauf, der Begriff Zumutung kommt jetzt
immer häufiger. Also man muss den Leuten was zumuten.
Das ist auf jeden Fall eine Zumutung.
Ja, aber es wird im Sinne von, wir müssen jetzt denen mal noch was aufbürden, Rente.
Es geht ja darum, dass viele Leute viel zu früh in die Rente gehen beispielsweise.
Wer denn? Lass uns das mal überreden. Warum, vielleicht Frau Bobowski mal,
warum hält die SPD so stur an der Rente mit 63 fest?
Also Renten, wird hier auch suggeriert, wäre doch eigentlich gut weiter.
Das Problem ist ja überall, dass es Geld kostet. Und zu viel Geld kostet.
Und ich glaube, Sie wissen das wahrscheinlich besser.
Der Rententopf betrifft, glaube ich, ein Viertel des gesamten Haushalts.
Wie sollen wir uns das leisten können, wenn man nicht an die Sozialetat rangeht?
Ja, also hier geht es, also man baut jetzt schon wieder den sozialen Stand ab.
Da muss doch mal langsam was und hat tatsächlich auch gleich eine Gewährsfrau dafür geholt.
Das Argument ist, dass die Frau, die die Rente mit 63 eingeführt hat,
nämlich die ehemalige Arbeitsministerin Andrea Nahles, die jetzt Chefin der
Bundesagentur für Arbeit ist, die sagt inzwischen, dass das gesamtwirtschaftlich
völlig indiskutabel ist.
Ja, also wenn Andrea Nahles das sagt, dann muss das doch stimmen.
Ist das Zitat, ja? Völlig indiskutabel, hat sie gesagt? Ja. Habe ich nicht gehört.
Habe ich auch nicht mitbekommen. Ich verfolge jetzt auch nicht so Meldungen,
die über Nahles umlaufen.
Ich schon. Rententhemen verfolge ich eigentlich. Und völlig dysfunktional habe
ich nicht gehört von Nahles.
Ja, ganz erstaunlich, wie wenn man jetzt da eine halbe Million verdient für
eine Talkshow im Jahr, dann sagt, jetzt sollen die aber mal alle anderen länger
arbeiten und es geht dann noch weiter.
Weil die SPD hat ja schon mal, als sie gespürt hat, dass sich was Grundlegendes ändern muss.
Sehr mutige Reformen angepackt. Und ich erinnere mich, dass Ihr Mentor,
den haben Sie sehr bewundert dafür, diesen jetzt in dieser Russland-Sache etwas
irrlichternden Altkanzler,
dass Sie den sehr dafür bewundert haben.
Was ich mich frage ist, warum traut sich heute keiner, sich hinzustellen,
zu sagen, Freunde, es gibt kein Geld.
Es gibt eine Zeitenwende, die kostet was. Es wird Zumutungen geben.
Warum tut das eigentlich keiner?
Warum soll man lügen? Es gibt doch Geld.
Eben, also warum redet man nicht über die ökonomischen Zusammenhänge, Schuldenbremse etc.
Und warum verkauft sie jetzt hier im Jahr 2024 nochmal die Agenda 2010 als tolles Reformprojekt,
das ja ein großes Verarmungsprojekt war, mit dem man den größten Niedriglohnsektor
in Europa geschaffen hat.
Das ist jetzt nochmal das Vorbild, also jetzt sagt uns hier eine reiche Journalistin,
ihr müsst mal all anderen, die ja nicht so reich seid,
nochmal so einen harten Reformprozess durchlaufen, denn wir brauchen Geld für
die Aufrüstung und ja, sonst so.
Für Bunker wahrscheinlich auch. Das ist doch absurd, dass wir hier ein öffentlich-rechtliches
Fernsehen haben, das hier eine Politik macht gegen die absolute Mehrheit der Zuschauer.
Wir können es ja ausrechnen. Also sie kriegt jetzt diese 19.000 pro Sendung.
Sie macht vier Sendungen im Monat. Das sind also 80.000 Euro.
Mit 500 Euro im Monat kriegt man eine Alleinerziehende in Deutschland aus der Armut.
So, jetzt nehmen wir ihre 80.000 Euro, teilen die durch 500 und dann haben wir
160 Frauen aus der Arbeit geholfen.
Das wären doch mal Zumutungen.
Genau, wo sind die Zumutungen? Wer will hier keine Zumutungen?
Ich finde, das kann man ja auch mal zumuten. Zumutung, auch ein Begriff,
den jetzt neuerdings Albrecht von Lucke im Munde führt. Er war im Presseclub,
das nur mal kurz eingestreut.
Und in der Hinsicht hat Olaf Scholz nie dazu beigetragen, die Debatten in die
Richtung zu führen, wie sie jetzt erforderlich sind.
Europa insgesamt zu ermächtigen, eine Kriegswirtschaft aufzubauen.
Was bereits vor einem Jahr im Raum war, eine wirkliche Unterstützung der Ukraine
in dem zentralen Bereich.
Ich bin ganz bei Ihnen, Herr Sturm. Ich bin der Meinung, eigentlich ein Kanzler
auf der Höhe der Herausforderungen müsste dem Land Zumutungen in einem Maße
diktieren, regelrecht.
Wo gesagt würde, dieses Land muss angesichts der Tatsache, dass wir gegen Russland rüsten müssen,
dass wir übrigens auch nach wie vor die ökologische große Herausforderung bewältigen
müssen und dass wir das Desaster in der Infrastruktur des Landes,
bröckelnde Brücken, kaputte Schulen, Sie müsste tatsächlich Zumutungen erteilen.
Erteilen, diktieren, also sind wir eigentlich noch in einer Demokratie.
Wir werden es ja nochmal bei Veit Selk dann nachlesen.
Die DEW-Zahlen sagen ja von Fratscher, die Hälfte der deutschen Bevölkerung hat einfach gar nichts.
Was auch bedeutet, im Falle eines Krieges und der totalen Zerstörung der Eigentumsverhältnisse
verliert diese Hälfte der Bevölkerung gar nichts.
Warum sollen die sich jetzt irgendwas diktieren lassen mit Zumutungen?
Sollen doch diejenigen, die was zu verlieren haben, das machen?
Also das ist doch völlig banal. an. Es ist auch logisch, hier gibt es doch gar keinen Sinn.
Ja. Wir müssen es ein bisschen abkürzen.
Ich will nur kurz, weil du ja auch noch auf dieses Thema eingehen wirst,
ich will noch kurz dazu kommen, dass Chrupalla von der AfD ja auch beim IOSCA
war und wir hören uns da auch mal ein paar Fragen an.
Herr Chrupalla, wie viel Bargeld haben Sie heute dabei? Ich habe jetzt glaube
ich gar kein Bargeld dabei.
Ne? Ne. Sind Sie so der Portemonnaie-Typ? Aber Ihre Partei hängt ja sehr am
Bargeld und kämpft schon lange dafür, dass es nicht abgeschafft wird. Warum eigentlich?
Dann blendet sie offenbar ein Foto ein, wo draufsteht Bargeld erhalten.
Das war mal so eine Kampagne der AfD und das kann man natürlich so und so interpretieren.
Im Zuge der Bargeld-Kampagne der AfD ist uns ein Foto aufgefallen,
das uns sehr schmunzeln ließ, als wir es jetzt entdeckten.
Kommt aus dem Jahr 21. Können wir es uns mal angucken?
Sie lachen auch, weil da muss ihnen zumindest ist für einen Moment die Doppeldeutigkeit
dieses Slogans nicht aufgefallen sein. Doch, die ist mir so.
Das sind die Scherzen, die man da am zweiten Abend noch macht.
Wie sieht es im Privatleben denn so aus?
Ihr Vater war Malermeister? Nee, das ist falsch. Ach, Quatsch.
Ja, das kann man gleich mal hier ausräumen.
Was war Ihr Vater?
Er ist Handwerker. Sie sind Malermeister, aber stimmt, dass einer Ihrer Söhne
auch Malermeister ist? Nein, auch das stimmt.
Dass aber der junge Tino aus Görlitz aus der Rolle fiel und nun ein bekannter
deutscher Politiker geworden ist. Was sagt Ihr Vater dazu?
Sie sollen sich mal furchtbar geärgert haben, dass der ehemalige Bundessprecher
Jörg Meuthen Sie Pinsel genannt hat. Das ist auch fies.
Ah, das ist aber auch fies. Und jetzt wird er immer auf den Malermeister reduziert.
Medien spielen auch weiter mit diesem Klischee, dass immer wieder geschrieben
wird, die promovierte, Perlenketten tragende Volkswirtin Magna Cum Laude abgeschlossen
und der geerdete Malermeister nebendran. Das ärgert Sie?
Ja, die Medien, sie macht das ja selbst die ganze Zeit. Also zum Thema Normalisierung
der AfD braucht man glaube ich nicht mehr viel zu sagen. Es geht mal weiter.
Inzwischen würden Sie sagen, Sie sind lieber in Berlin-Mitte oder in der Oberlausitz.
Also Schnitzel im Borchert oder Hacke-Peter in Görlitz.
Das kann doch alles gar nicht sein.
Und dann kommen, das habe ich jetzt mal weggelassen, etwa 15 Fragen zu Maximilian
Krah, was der dann da mit Bargeld empfangen hat und FBI und hin und her.
Da war noch nicht dieser neueste Skandal da.
Das sollte man vielleicht auch mal den Journalisten mitteilen,
dass die AfD keine Partei ist, in der es eine einheitliche Linie gibt,
Sondern es gibt ja dort Rivalitäten und die größte Rivalität ist wohl die zwischen Chrupalla und Krah.
Das heißt, Chrupalla anzusprechen auf Krah, ob der da irgendwie verwickelt sei, hilft dem Chrupalla,
aber ich habe nicht den Eindruck, dass man damit die AfD entlarvt,
sondern innerhalb der AfD irgendwelche Ränkespiele voranbringt.
Und was mir aber aufgefallen ist jetzt in dem Skandal um Krah mit diesem mutmaßlichen
Agenten, Spionen aus China,
dass jetzt alle so eine Politikberatungsmanier jetzt eingenommen haben,
wie kriegt man die AfD wieder auf Vordermann?
Also es gab zum Beispiel so einen Social Media Teaser bei der Welt, da stand Krah,
Böstren und Höcke mit einem solchen Personal ist eine politische Wende unmöglich.
Ja, beratet man jetzt schon? Überrät man jetzt die AfD?
Immer schon.
Wie man es besser machen kann?
Und genau so sind auch diese tausend Fragen an Krupalla gerichtet,
dass er sich jetzt quasi von Krah distanzieren soll.
Ja klar, kann er das machen? Es ist,
Es hilft ihm ja. Ich empfehle einen Artikel von Sebastian Friedrich im Freitag
zu diesem Fall Krah, wo er auf die inhaltlichen Differenzen zu sprechen kommt innerhalb der AfD.
Da heißt es, zwar werden inhaltliche Differenzen nach dem Weggang Jörg Meuthens
und veränderten Machtverhältnissen im Bundesvorstand nicht mehr öffentlich ausgetragen.
Doch Streit, Macht und Linienkämpfe bestehen weiter nur subtiler und disziplinierter.
Im Zentrum steht seit dem Krieg in der Ukraine die Geopolitik.
Die Partei ist in dieser Frage gespalten.
Auf der einen Seite stehen diejenigen, die weiterhin transatlantisch orientiert
sind, an Westbindung und NATO-Mitgliedschaft festhalten wollen.
Auf der anderen Seite sind jene, die eurasische Perspektiven bevorzugen und
die Nähe zu Russland und China suchen.
Gerade bei den älteren, häufig aus Westdeutschland stammenden Abgeordneten stößt
dieser Kurs immer wieder auf Widerstand, wie sich im vergangenen Jahr an offensichtlichen
Durchstechereien aus der Bundestagsfraktion an Medien zeigte.
Die Spionageaffäre könnte eine Gelegenheit für die Transatlantiker bieten,
die Verhältnisse zu ihren Gunsten zu verändern.
Das heißt, wer jetzt sagt, wir greifen mal richtig die AfD an,
greift oft nur einen Teil der AfD an und die andere kann sich wunderbar jetzt
in ihrer Macht stabilisieren.
Genau, also Grabesiegen.
Da macht die halbe der Partei mit. Ja. Und dann geht es weiter. Also das ist ja...
Also das ist, es ist absolut absurd. Deswegen überspringen wir das alles.
Sie zitiert dann irgendwelche Passagen aus Maximilian Gras Buch.
Und man kommt da aber auch nicht weiter.
Das einzig Sinnvolle ist, dass Joe Kaeser da sitzt und mal ein bisschen erzählt,
wie problematisch das ist, wenn man allen diktiert, dass wer nach Deutschland
kommen will, aber schon Deutsch können muss. Das können wir alles überspringen.
Ich will nur ganz kurz, wir haben da auch viele Clips, aber ich will da nur
ganz kurz darauf hinweisen, Klamroth hat ja auch diese Sendung von Plasbeck
übernommen, hat aber fair.
Und ich bin nicht zufrieden mit dieser Sendung, in dem Sinne,
dass ich sage, ich empfehle jetzt diese Sendung.
Ich will aber sagen, dass das unter den Talkshows, unter den Fragen,
die ich jetzt da alle bekommen habe, die einzige Talkshow ist,
in der es tatsächlich noch ein Erkenntnisinteresse gibt.
Und das ist vielleicht auch deshalb auszumachen, weil man eine andere Konstellation wählt.
Nämlich man hat Politiker da, setzt sie aber direkt Experten gegenüber.
Das heißt, da ist jemand, der arbeitet seit drei Jahren in der Flüchtlingshilfe
und ist auch noch Studierter so und so und kann Auskunft darüber geben, was los ist.
Oder jemand, der genau weiß, wie es mit den Arbeitskräften ist.
Deswegen gehen wir nun mal gerade in diesen ersten Klamroth-Clip rein.
Da wird Schuster gefragt.
Ja, Herr Schuster, Angela Merkel hat als Kanzlerin den Satz geprägt,
wir schaffen das mit Blick auf die Lage der Kommunen. Gilt das noch?
Ja, das sind also diese Fragen, die erst mal so kommen.
Frau Drüge, in Michebach leben 90 Einwohner. Ich habe es vorhin gesagt,
60 Flüchtlinge sollen kommen in einen Ort mitten im Nirgendwo.
Ich war da, da gibt es ja wirklich nichts.
Da gibt es einen Zigarettenautomat und einen Kaugummiautomat,
der sogar noch funktioniert.
Wie kommt so eine Entscheidung zustande? Können Sie das erklären?
Das sind ja alles erstmal berechtigte Fragen.
Hat er gerade gesagt, ich war da?
Ja, er war da und hat dann auch wohl eine kleine Reportage mitgebracht.
Herr Reichert, Michebach liegt in Rheinland-Pfalz, aber in ganz Deutschland
gibt es ja solche Fälle und solche Kommunen.
Sie sind Landrat in Günzburg in Bayern. Wie angespannt ist die Lage bei Ihnen vor Ort?
Also hier wird erstmal ganz konkret abgefragt bei Landräten,
was ist eigentlich los. Jetzt aber wird die andere Perspektive eingeladen.
Herr Haidari, Sie sind 2015 aus Afghanistan nach München gekommen,
arbeiten da jetzt auch beim Flüchtlingsrat.
Sie kennen das also anzukommen und erstmal an einen Ort zu kommen,
den man sich nicht aussucht.
Sie waren, glaube ich, in einer Sammelunterkunft, 1500 Menschen ungefähr waren da.
Wie viel Zeit haben Sie da verbracht und wie war das?
Sofort wird daraus ein anderes Gespräch, wenn man solche Fragen stellt.
Aber man braucht natürlich auch die entsprechenden Gäste dafür.
Aber es kommt doch auf die Fragen an.
Auch wenn die Fragen dann mitunter auch so sind, dass man sagen kann,
naja, muss man jetzt nochmal die Gefühle abtropfen.
Können Sie verstehen aus Ihrer Perspektive, wenn die Leute in Michelbach,
wo ich war, sagen, das kann nicht funktionieren, wenn da jetzt 60 Menschen kommen
aus anderen Ländern in einen Ort mitten im Nirgendwo. Können Sie das verstehen?
Viel interessanter wird es aber dann, wenn beispielsweise jemand da ist,
der Bäckereien besitzt, so eine Kette.
Und der ist natürlich auf Zuwanderung angewiesen.
Wie viele Flüchtlinge haben Sie bei sich schon ausgebildet? Was sind die größten
Schwierigkeiten dabei?
Ja, konkrete Fragen. Wie ist die Situation? Alles andere ist ja nur Stimmungsmache.
Jetzt könnte man ja auch sagen, wenn das mit so Schwierigkeiten verbunden ist,
die Politik vielleicht nicht richtig darauf vorbereitet ist,
sie womöglich illegal so Leute woanders melden müssen, warum machen sie es dann
mit Flüchtlingen, warum nehmen sie nicht Menschen, die schon deutschen Pass haben?
Ja, illegal woanders, also die melden die in irgendwelchen anderen Kommunen
an, obwohl die die da brauchen, nur weil die Kommunen das nicht abbilden können, wie die Bedarfe sind.
Ja, und da wird aber die Lebenswirklichkeit plötzlich präsent.
Da ist nicht, sollen wir mal neuen Begriff für irgendwas suchen und finden und
irgendwas abklopfen, sondern hier wird die Lebenswirklichkeit präsent.
Genauso dann auch, wenn man mit jemandem spricht, er leitet jetzt,
also er ist Flüchtling und leitet jetzt da eine Filiale.
Also Sie haben ja bei Herrn Wiese gelernt, wir haben es ja auch eben im Film
gesehen, kommen aus Syrien und vor ihrer Flucht haben Sie angefangen,
glaube ich, Informatik zu studieren. Genau.
Und wie schwer ist es dann gefallen, aufs Bäckerhandwerk, Bäckerei-Fachverkäufer zu lernen?
Ja, also da haben wir dann auch jemand, der zu Wort kommt und wir springen mal gerade zu 5.2.18.
Es geht dann nochmal um diese Bezahlkarte und hier finde ich auch,
ist die Fragestellung, ich kenne die Antworten ja nicht, Aber die Fragestellung
macht schon was Transparentes.
Also dieser Schuster wird jetzt hier gefragt zur Bezahlkarte und wo das geht.
Und in Sachsen wird das teilweise schon am 1. April eingeführt,
nämlich die Bezahlkarte.
Das ist eine Karte, die sollen Flüchtlinge bekommen, die sich im Asylverfahren
befinden, worauf dann ihnen das Geld, was ihnen zur Verfügung steht, überwiesen wird.
Herr Schuster, in was für Geschäften kann man damit einkaufen?
Ich will es mal nur ganz konkret verstehen. Verstehen.
Konkret verstehen. Das ist genau die richtige Sache. Wo kann man denn damit einkaufen?
Ja, dann kommt man da irgendwas, erzählt wohl. Ich habe es ja nicht gehört. Nächste Frage.
Geht das bundesweit? Kann man überall damit bezahlen? Das heißt,
mit der Karte könnte man nicht in Berlin bei Frau Kieseltepe einkaufen. Nein.
Das heißt aber, wenn jetzt aus Sachsen jemand Freunde zum Beispiel in Eberswalde
besuchen wollen würde und da einen Kaffee trinken möchte bei Herrn Wiese in
der Bäckereifidiale, Dann könnte er das nicht, weil...
Genau die richtige Frage.
Im Internet wird das ja alles zusammen diskutiert und die AfD sagt dann, nee, Bargeld.
Hier macht die AfD sogar flüchtlingsfreundliche Politik. Und die Leute finden
das nicht blöd, sondern die finden sowas gut.
Und jetzt hat er das schon so hingeleitet, naja, wenn die jetzt woanders hinfahren
und dann dort in der Bäckerei gehen wollen, wie ist das dann?
Und dann spitzt er noch einmal das in der Frage zu oder beziehungsweise liefert
jetzt in der Frage die Konklusio. Also wir brauchen jetzt gar nicht mehr die
Antwort, weil der Schuster kann ja sagen, was er will, aber die Frage ist jetzt entscheidend.
Interessanter Punkt. Ist das dafür gedacht,
die Bewegungsfreiheit von Flüchtlingen einzuschränken?
Also wenn in der Frage schon eine entsprechende Antwort liegt,
dann hat man in gewisser Weise was richtig gemacht.
Ich glaube, das große Problem bei dieser Sendung hat aber fair ist,
dass da zu viele Leute sitzen.
Da sind sechs Leute, dann vielleicht noch ein Publikum, eins, zwei.
Man hat zwar zehn Minuten länger Zeit als in den anderen Shows,
aber es sind einfach zu viele Leute. Ich glaube, hätte man es so,
dass zwei Politiker, zwei Experten sich gegenüber sitzen würden und hätte diese
Fragen, würde das deutlich mehr helfen.
Wir könnten jetzt noch durch diese Maybrit Illner Sendung gehen,
wo einfach nur nochmal abgefrühstückt wird, was dann jetzt zu tun ist mit Migration
und das große Problem. Ich will nur mal zwei Punkte rausgreifen.
Und zwar einmal eine für mich neue Wendung nimmt das hier so, zwar der Clip 6.3.1.5.
Da fragt Ilna Folgendes.
Und offen denen zu gehen, dann ist die Frage, mit welchem Image diese Stiftung weiterarbeiten kann.
Frau Rennefans, und wir sind bei der Frage, dass wenn die Ukraine tatsächlich
nennenswert Gebiete an Russland wieder abgeben muss und wieder verliert,
ist eine politisch nächste Konsequenz, dass wir mehr Flüchtlinge in diesem Land haben werden.
Wohin tragen Sie da Ihre Gedanken?
Sind wir jetzt an dem Punkt, dass wir darüber reden, der Krieg muss weitergehen,
die Ukraine muss gewinnen, damit die ja nicht als Flüchtlinge zu uns kommen?
Wohin tragen dich da deine Gedanken?
Tja, vielleicht zum nächsten Clip.
Wir sind damit bei einem Thema, das auch Deutschland sehr bewegt.
Und meine erste Frage würde an Dirk Neubauer gehen, nämlich...
Ähnlich versucht ich schon gerade mal zu stellen, wie groß eigentlich die Sorge
von Ihnen ist, dass wir mit einem schlecht ausgehenden Krieg in der Ukraine
noch mehr Flüchtlinge in Deutschland hätten.
Also wir fürchten uns jetzt vor ukrainischen Flüchtlingen, dass da noch mehr
kommen können, wenn da irgendein Friedensschluss oder was stattfindet.
Das kann doch alles nicht mehr wahr sein.
Gut, das wird dann nur noch dadurch übertroffen, dass Wolfgang Bosbach dort zu Gast war.
Wolfgang Bosbach tingelt jetzt durch den Osten, um Wahlkampf zu machen für die
CDU, weil man sagt, naja, wer könnte denn im Osten noch was reißen aus dem Westen?
Das muss also ein Hardliner sein, der schon immer ein Merkel-Gegner war und
das ist natürlich Wolfgang Bosbach.
Und wir hören uns hier, nur um nochmal den Irrsinn der Talkshows deutlich zu machen, zwei Fragen an.
Einmal 6.1, wenn wir da mal gerade uns das reinziehen.
Du soll jetzt im Osten, Herr Bosbach, Wahlkampf für die CDU machen.
Und nun sagt Friedrich Merz, er ist jederzeit in der Lage und bereit zu übernehmen.
Er möchte Kanzler werden, offensichtlich schon dieses Jahr. Glauben Sie, dass er das schafft?
Was soll Bosbach darauf antworten? Ja.
Ja, ich glaube, dass er das schafft.
Das schafft er.
Oder vielleicht auch nicht.
Noch besser, die nächste Frage.
Und weil das ja eine Sendung ist, in der die Wahrheit gesprochen werden soll,
und ganz besonders die Wahrheit.
Würde es die Union heute denn besser machen im Angesicht dieser Krisen, vor denen wir stehen?
Nee, wir würden es auf keinen Fall besser machen.
Wir wären auch inkompetent. Ja.
Also wir halten fest, diese Polit-Talkshows sind in einem Maße schlimm,
dass man es kaum rechtssicher ausdrücken kann.
Und sie sorgen auch dafür, dass wir...
Permanent das als Politik wahrnehmen und alles andere nicht als Politik wahrnehmen.
Also wir haben jetzt mal ganz kurz mitbekommen, es geht also auch darum,
dass so jemand, der Bäckereibetriebe hat, Leute sucht und sowas,
das kriegen wir jetzt bei Hart aber fair mal mit.
Wirklichkeit, Begegnung mit der Wirklichkeit. Das andere ist ein reines Theater
von einer Handvoll Leuten.
Das ist eigentlich ein festes Ensemble, in dem immer wieder neu ausgesucht wird.
Also heute Abend setzen wir diese drei zusammen und man stellt dann Fragen,
bei denen man sich fragt, was machen eigentlich diese Redaktionen da?
Ich weiß von diesen Talkshows, weil ich schon Leute kenne, die da waren,
dass diese Redaktionen groß sind.
Da sind ganz, ganz viele Leute. Also wir machen ja hier alles zu zweit,
aber es gibt ja Leute, die haben, also Talkshows, die haben einfach 10,
15, 20 Leute dort, die lesen den ganzen Tag Nachrichten, rezipieren, machen, tun.
Und dann kommen Fragen dabei heraus, wie glauben sie, dass die Union es besser
macht und die SPD steht jetzt bei sieben Prozent, wird das im Osten noch was?
Diese Fragen könnte ja jeder stellen. Also beziehungsweise, ich frage mich,
haben die nicht einen viel zu großen Overhead?
Sollten die nicht sagen, ja, die Talkshow zu produzieren kostet fünf Millionen
im Jahr? Ich glaube, so sind so die Zahlen etwa.
Aber wir geben alles einfach einer einzigen Person und die bereitet sich dafür
vor oder alle anderen werden entlassen.
Also ich weiß von meinem Besuch bei Lanz, war ja in der letzten Sendung des
Jahres, dass zum Jahreswechsel da relativ viele Arbeitsverträge ausgelaufen
sind, weil Karim Miosga alles abgegrast hat.
Und sie hat rekrutiert in diesen bestehenden Redaktionen.
Und dann war auch meine Frage konkret an jemanden, der dort Redaktionsmitglied
war und zu Karim Mürsker wechselte.
Ja, aber ist das nicht totaler Quatsch? Also wenn du hier bei Lanz Sendung machst,
dann kannst du ja einfach in die Redaktion gehen und sagen, ich habe eine richtig
krasse Idee, auf die seid ihr noch nicht gekommen, lasst uns dazu mal eine Sendung machen.
Mit dem und dem, da sitzen ja noch zwei andere, wir können ja mal was,
also so bin ich ja auch da reingerutscht, wir können ja mal was versuchen.
Also ging es in einer Sendung über Demografie und ich war da zu Gast.
Das ist ja bei Karim Joska gar nicht möglich, weil du musst dich ja in diesem
Ensemble bedienen, du kannst ja nicht Sonntag nach dem Tatort Oma Erna irgendwen
hinsetzen, den sie noch nie gesehen hat. Nee. So.
Also wechseln da relativ viele von, wie ich finde, relativ interessanten Jobs,
nämlich Landsendungen zu bestücken und zu konzipieren, in dieses Karamioska-mäßige,
ja, kannst du mal Robert Habeck fragen, ob er Zeit hat? Er hat keine Zeit.
Kannst du mal Alain Baerbock fragen, ob sie Zeit hat? Er hat keine Zeit.
Kannst du mal Christian Lindner fragen, ob er Zeit hat?
Du rufst quasi nur noch zehn Leute an und willst, dass die da einfach reden
und holst dann entweder den Chef oder einen Mitglied der Chefredaktion,
Spiegelzeit, Dings und dann gehst du dir einfach so durch.
Und das war's. Also die arbeiten da ja gar nicht.
Ich frage mich ja auch, wie kann man eigentlich noch Karteikarten benötigen,
wenn man doch nur nach den neuesten Umfragen fragt. Also was muss man da noch machen?
Weil da der Sendungsname draufsteht, relativ präsent im Bild.
Ja und der Gast mit dem Bild, dass man weiß, oh das ist Lars Klingbeil oder
das ist Herr Kruppaller.
Das ist Lars, das ist Kruppaller.
Wie kann das sein? Also ich bin wirklich entsetzt über dieses Niveau und Und
es ist, glaube ich, hilfreich, wenn man mal sagt, ich höre nur die Fragen,
weil diese Politikerantworten, die überdecken immer so sehr die Fragen.
Und hier wird es deutlich und ich würde auch so weit gehen, dass ich sage,
die Talkshow an sich hat ihre Limitierungen durch das Medium.
Aber die Talkshow könnte etwas besser wahrscheinlich schon noch sein,
als das, was wir gerade geboten bekommen.
Und wir sehen dann gewisse Ausreißer und auch bei Lanz gibt es dann interessante
Diskussionen, die stattfinden, aber ich glaube generell leiden diese Shows alle
darunter, dass oft zu viele Gäste da sind,
zu wenig Zeit ist, zu viel angeschnitten wird und dass man immer glaubt,
sobald Politiker da sind, dass man entweder so verrückt menscheln muss und mal
nach Musikgeschmack und Portemonnaie fragt.
Oder man sagt, jetzt muss ich auf Angriff und muss irgendwas rauskitzeln.
Statt einfach mal eine Position zu befragen, dass sich jemand,
der es sieht zu Hause, einen Eindruck von dieser Position machen kann und dann
selber auch vielleicht Einordnungen vornimmt.
Aber diese komischen Treibjachten, um einmal in diesem Bild zu bleiben von Christian Lindner,
die dort allabendlich organisiert werden, helfen niemandem außer diesen Sendungen,
um eine gewisse Quote zu erreichen und um diesen Hosts den Eindruck zu vermitteln,
dass sie die großen Dompteure sind.
In Wahrheit aber sind sie ja eigentlich nur so Steigbügelhalter für den absoluten
Mainstream des Mainstreams.
Ja und ich möchte gerne allgemein anfügen als Kritik.
Die haben da Humor, aber den total falschen. Das ist dieser bräsige Boomer-Humor und so.
Der ist einfach unattraktiv, man. Klar, die Zuschauer 60 plus sind nicht nur
die größte Gruppe, sondern auch die am schnell wachsende Gruppe.
Aber es führt trotzdem irgendwie in die Irre. Es ist nicht unbedingt ein Produkt,
das den Zusammenhalt in dieser Gesellschaft fördert,
sondern umso mehr so im Fernsehen Ensemble-mäßig das durchgespielt wird,
umso So mehr sitzt die Jugend daneben und denkt sich, was, also die wollen jetzt was von mir.
Naja, beziehungsweise ich glaube die Jugend bekommt ja ganz viel von diesen
Talkshows dadurch mit, dass die ganze Zeit Clips gemacht werden.
Also in den sozialen Medien sind die vertreten.
Nur aus diesen Clips kann ja auch nichts wirklich Erkenntnisbringendes rauskommen,
wenn man solche affigen Fragen stellt.
Und da sehen wir ja, dass eigentlich das, was wir bei TikTok bemängeln,
dass man sagt, da geht es nur noch um so ein paar Affekte. und ob jemand eine
gute Pointe oder Punchline hinlegt.
Das ist ja nichts anderes dann im Langformat in den Talkshows.
Also diese Differenz, die hier gemacht wird, TikTok und hier ist das seriöse
Fernsehen auf der anderen Seite, das ist eine völlig falsche Differenz,
sondern eben habe ich TikTok so verteidigt, aber ich würde jetzt eher dazu tendieren
und sagen, beides ist schlechter.
Ja, das ist eine Abwärtsspirale von beidem.
Gut, weshalb es nur einen Ausweg gibt, Journalisten dürfen nicht mehr mit Politikern
reden, nur noch Politiker dürfen mit Politikern reden.
Auch eine Idee.
Fragen wir uns natürlich, welche? Wünschenswerterweise?
Ja, nicht die, die du uns jetzt gleich vorlegst.
Ja, aber es war ein kleiner Schreckmoment. Irgendwann hatte Simon Strauß,
als er den FAZ-Podcast verantwortete an dem Tag, den Vogt von Thüringen zu Gast,
der ihm in der letzten Antwort auf die Frage von Simon Strauß,
und sie würden so ein Duell, Rededuell mit Höcke machen. Und dann sagte er so, ja, ja, würde ich.
Dann hatte ich die große Angst, dass die FAZ das veranstaltet.
Weil man weiß ja nicht mehr, wie weit die mittlerweile abdriften.
Dann war es ja sehr lange ruhig darum und jetzt plötzlich stellte sich raus, dass die Welt das macht.
Ich habe dann auf Twitter noch so einen fiesen Tweet dazu gemacht,
in dem ich mich eines Adam-Tooth-Zitates zum Thema der Rechtsradikale Matthias
Döpfner und sein, was weiß ich, Springer und so weiter.
Und, nee, der Militante Matthias Döpfner und sein rechtsradikales Medienhaus
oder irgendwie so hat er es formuliert.
Und, muss man im Zweifel nochmal nachlesen, ich lege jetzt nicht die Hand ins
Feuer für dieses Zitat. hat.
Und dass dieser Matthias Döpfner jetzt den Deutschen den Hahnenkampf in seiner
Arena gibt, indem er Höcke gegen Vogt antreten lässt.
Dann wurde das gesendet und Leute hatten irgendwie Meinung dazu und dann habe
ich so mit zwei Wochen Verspätung dann oder in einer Woche geguckt und fand
es doch ganz interessant, insbesondere durch meinen Besuch in,
Thüringen jetzt im April und ich denke, wir sollten das jetzt auch mal gucken,
allein unter der Maßgabe,
wie wurde dort gesprochen und Und meine Vermutung ist, dass wir doch einige
Thüringer so ein bisschen bewegt oder aufgeschreckt haben, denn der Vogt hat
es zum einen nicht schlecht gemacht.
Er hat nämlich den Höcke an einen Satz gebunden.
Die EU muss sterben, damit das wahre Europa leben kann.
Das kennen wir aus allen auch autokratischen oder autokratischeren Systemen,
wie zeitweise Polen oder Ungarn.
Die Leute wählen gerne solche Haudegen, die irgendwie den Molotow-Cocktail nach
Brüssel werfen, aber ein Austritt aus der Europäischen Union wird dort überall mit entdeckt.
80, 90 Prozent abgelehnt. Auch in diesen No-Go-Areas, wo man noch so gegen Genderwahn
und so weiter in Polen. Eine EU-Austritt können die sich alle nicht vorstellen.
Und da wollte ich dann wissen, okay, wie bereden die das da?
Weil in dieser Falle wird ja wohl der Höcke nicht tappen, oder?
Da einfach all in zu gehen, bei so einem Thema.
Wohl wissen, dass auch seine Thüringer nicht so abgedreht sind,
zu sagen, ah ja, das ist eigentlich ganz gut.
Wir wollen Deutschland aber normal, dass alles ruhig ist. Wir wollen unser Deutschland
zurück haben. Also was machen wir? Wir machen einen Dexit.
Das passt ja irgendwie nicht zusammen. Uns passt ja auch wirklich nicht zusammen.
Also hören wir uns das mal an. Thema Nummer 1 war gleich Europa.
Zu Beginn wird natürlich Höcke begrüßt und wir schließen hier,
wenn wir das hören, direkt an, was du bis jetzt besprochen hast.
Ich begrüße Björn Höcke, den Fraktionsvorsitzenden und Spitzenkandidaten der Thüringer AfD.
Ein Mann, den der Verfassungsschutz als Rechtsextremist einstuft und seinen
Landesverband als erwiesen rechtsextremistisch. Na, die Einleitung musst du
ja sagen, aber ich freue mich trotzdem sehr, dass ich heute hier sein darf.
So, mich als Nazi darstellen, weil irgendwer vor Gericht keinen Widerspruch
erntet, in einem Urteil zu sagen, ich sei ein Nazi und so weiter.
Das musste ja sein, dass sie das sagen. Also so können wir Agnes Stag-Dimmermann
seit heute übrigens auch als Kriegstreiberin bezeichnen, denn sie klagte dagegen,
dass sie als Kriegstreiberin bezeichnet wurde und hat vor Gericht verloren.
Aber ich glaube nur in diesem einen Fall, ne?
Ja, genau, aber da können wir ja sagen, sie ist nicht immer kein Kriegstreiber
oder irgendwie so. Also so rutscht das ja dann rein, so war das ja auch bei Höcke.
Das ist so über Bande, also es hat nicht die Bundeszentrale der politischen
Bildung festgestellt, das und der Verfassungsschutz sagt auch,
sondern es gab halt so Gerichtsurteile, die das irgendwie sagen und dann wird
es immer wieder aufgegriffen, er macht sich drüber lustig und so weiter. davon.
Nun haben wir es so, er wurde von den Journalisten so begrüßt.
Der Vogt hat natürlich einen Teufel getan, ihn irgendwie so pauschal und paradigmatisch
irgendwie abzustempeln.
Sondern, und das ist jetzt das Besondere, da kann man wirklich drauf achten,
wenn zwei Politiker miteinander reden, dann ist das ein Nullsummspiel um die Mobilisierung.
Wenn der Höcke hier in,
Rückräume kommt, dann sind das Raumgewinne für den Vogt.
Ja.
Weil hier in Thüringen, das muss man leider einpreisen, steht jetzt nicht Ramelow
mit auf der Bühne, es ist nun mal das TV-Duell der beiden, die da die Stimmen
anführen, die klären es jetzt unter sich, was eben bedeutet,
weder kann Vogt jetzt einfach sagen, er ist Nazi und so, und Höcke kann jetzt
nicht auch sagen, sie sind ja Systempresse, Altpartei oder irgendwas,
sondern jetzt muss es eben richtig diskutiert werden Und entsprechend war das
wirklich klug von Vogt gewählt, diesen Ausgangspunkt zu wählen.
Ich zitiere diesen Satz von Herrn Höcke jetzt nochmal wörtlich.
Diese EU muss sterben, damit das wahre Europa leben kann.
Um an diesen Satz anzuknüpfen, geht die erste Frage an Sie beide.
Ist die Europäische Union für Deutschlands Wirtschaft und Wohlstand verzichtbar?
So, ist die Europäische Union verzichtbar? Das ganze Publikum sagt nein, auch in Thüringen.
Höcke weiß das aber irgendwie nicht so richtig. er versucht jetzt...
Meinst du, dass das so ist?
Dass Höcke es nicht weiß. Also ich weiß, dass die... Das kriegt man überall, auch in Thüringen.
Die Leute haben Angst davor, dass sich die Welt so grundlegend ändert.
Die wollen erst recht keine EU austreten.
Okay, das würde bedeuten, die Leute wollen,
jetzt mal, also wir gehen jetzt mal gar nicht in diese tiefen ideologischen
Gefilde hinein, inwieweit die nationalsozialistischen Gedankengut offen gegenüberstehen,
aber jetzt in Bezug auf die EU,
würdest du sagen, die Leute wollen in Ruhe gelassen werden, sie wollen vielleicht eine,
Gemächlichkeit haben, aber sie wollen nicht einen Dexit, der jetzt ihr Leben auf den Kopf stellt?
Also, die Thüringer wollen gesicherte Außengrenzen.
Und sie wissen auch, dass diese Außengrenzen nicht die Thüringer oder die deutschen
Außengrenzen sind, dass ihre Handhabe also politisch organisiert werden muss,
und das macht die Europäische Union.
Also das klingt jetzt nach einem sehr komplizierten Gedanken,
der für die Thüringer zu hoch ist oder so, aber nein, es ist einfach nicht alternativ denkbar.
Wollte es jetzt nicht so sagen, ja.
Ja, aber es ist einfach keine Alternative denkbar.
Also ich würde zustimmen, weil also das Lagerhöcke in der AfD und die AfD als
Ganzes will ja den Bruch mit allem.
Also die wollen Tabula Rasa machen, soweit es nur irgend möglich ist.
Die müssen das aber verstecken. Und das müssen sie verstecken.
Ganz richtig.
Und wir hören jetzt raus.
Wie sehr das nicht versteckt wird. Bevor du damit jetzt kommst,
möchte ich mal bekräftigen, wie sehr dieses, glaube ich, in der Bevölkerung
verankert ist, dass man nicht Tabula Rasa will.
Und zwar eine Momentaufnahme vom Wochenende, Zeit Online, die Kulturseite,
da wird ja immer angezeigt, welche die meistgelesenen Artikel sind.
Da sind ja viele Texte zu Filmen, Büchern, Kanzlerkulturdebatten, was auch immer.
Platz 3 leuchtet noch ein, Tino Chrupalla bei Karin Miosga.
95.000 Aufrufe. Platz 2, Harvey Weinstein, Verurteilung wird aufgehoben, 115.000 Aufrufe.
Was könnte auf Platz 1 sein?
Keine Ahnung.
Klaus Otto Nagorsnick ist tot.
Der Ratefuchs von Gefragt gejagt im Vorabendprogramm ist gestorben im Alter von 68 Jahren.
Eine Million Aufrufe.
Ja.
Also das interessiert. Am Ende ist es Vorabend, am Ende ist es der Ratefuchs lebt nicht mehr.
Wie geht es weiter mit unserer geliebten Ratesendung? Und ich gebe da noch was hinzu.
Ich freue mich eigentlich, dass es diesen Gemütszustand auch noch gibt in Deutschland.
Dass man sich für den Ratefuchs interessiert. Und meine große Hoffnung ja gegen
den Rechtsruck ist Horst Schlemmer. Aber Harpe Kerkeling hat gesagt,
dass er jetzt diese Figur wieder zum Leben erwecken will.
Er wird als Horst Schlemmer zurückkommen. Und du weißt, welcher Satz von Horst
Schlemmer genau der richtige ist, den wir brauchen. Ja, den vielleicht auch.
Aber der andere Satz war, macht euch nicht verrückt. Und dieser Satz,
macht euch nicht verrückt, der wäre so hilfreich in fast allen Debatten,
aber ich glaube auch ganz klar, dass man da nochmal den Leuten sagen müsste,
wollt ihr wirklich den Faschismus jetzt hier haben oder geht es eher darum,
er sagt, macht euch nicht verrückt.
Wenn ihr noch eine Bratwurst essen wollt, dann esst die ruhig,
aber ihr müsst da nicht gleich die AfD für wählen.
Die Thüringer und die Alten Republik allgemein ist eine Trägergesellschaft, vor allem kognitiv.
Sehgewohnheiten sind alles. Wir wollen das Bargeld behalten.
Warum? Wir haben schon immer Bargeld gehabt. Ohne Bargeld, das geht doch gar nicht.
So, wir wollen reisen können. Schengen-Raum, also dann wird so eine Abwägung gemacht.
Ja, also Urlaub muss schon sein. Das ist ja auch gut für die Länder,
zu denen man reist. Man hilft denen ja auch mit dem Urlaub und so.
Aber die hierher, nee, das bringt alles durcheinander und so weiter.
Das wird aber bisher auch immer, also Europa hat es ja zusammengehalten.
Am Ende ist ja immer die Frage, Bernd Ulrich hat diesen einen Tweet gemacht,
nachdem die AfD im Bundestag zog mit, seien wir mal ehrlich,
in allen von uns steckt 13% AfD.
Und meine Vermutung ist, 2015, 16, 17 haben relativ viele gesagt,
was die AfD da macht ist ganz falsch und die Flüchtlingspolitik ist ja ganz
schlimm und die Flüchtlingsroute da mit Österreich und so weiter,
das ist alles und so, so kann man ja mit Menschen nicht umgehen,
aber es ist irgendwie doch gut, dass jemand geregelt hat.
Weißt du? Ich glaube, Sebastian Kurz hat relativ viel Publikum mit diesem Satz.
Als ich habe die Balkanroute geschlossen, gewonnen, die öffentlich auftreten
und sagen, es ist ganz schlimm, wie da mit Menschen umgegangen wird.
Aber zugleich gibt es ja ganz viele Maßnahmen,
die jetzt migrationsfeindlich sind, die extrem restriktiv sind,
die sich aber nicht in positiven Wahlergebnissen für die etablierten Parteien
abzeichnen, sondern eher sieht man dadurch.
Dass die AfD eher Zuwachs hat. Strukturell ist das alles nicht von Ausschlaggebend.
Kriminalstatistik, vielleicht schauen wir es auch erst im Teaser dann,
aber der Münch, der BKA-Chef, war bei Marietta Slomka im Fernsehen und hat dort,
eindeutig erklärt, wie diese Kriminalstatistik zu lesen ist.
Corona-Nachwehe, junge Menschen, Ausländeranteil, ja, ist beträchtlich,
aber der Ausländeranteil an sich, in der Bevölkerung, ist stärker gestiegen
als der kriminelle Ausländeranteil.
So. So, dieses Gespräch mit dem Münch wurde aber eingerahmt von,
Nancy Faeser sitzt in der BBK und sagt, wer sich hier nicht an die Regeln hält, fliegt raus.
Die CSU mit mehreren Sprechern, Innenminister Herrmann aus Bayern und der Dobrindt
dürfen nochmal sagen, also wer sich hier nicht an die Regeln hält, fliegt raus.
Und schämtste mir auch nochmal als Vorbilddeutscher.
Es hat kein empirisches Korrelat. Es schließt an eine Sehgewohnheit an.
Wir sind hier einfach fremdenfeindlich. Wir wollen einfach nicht,
dass sich etwas verändert und der Fremde ist Veränderung. Deswegen, ja.
Aber es ist ja furchtbar.
Hauptsache es kümmert sich jemand und im Zweifel, man sagt einfach,
ja man ist zufrieden, wenn man sieht, die haben auch was gegen Ausländer und so weiter.
Dieses typische, wir gucken die Nachrichten, um uns zu vergewissern,
dass sich nichts ändert.
Wir wollen keine innerliche Aufklärung.
Wenn dann jemand kommt mit, ja, das Arte-Channel macht ja viel bessere Informationen.
Ja, die Leute wollen keine Informationen.
Die wollen die Vergewisserung, dass sie ins Bett gehen können mit,
und wenn ich morgen aufwache, ist Deutschland noch da. Und jetzt kriegen sie sie serviert.
Macht euch nicht verrückt.
Macht euch nicht verrückt, ja. Und so ist das hier auch.
Vogt weiß, was die Thüringer Wähler wollen und Höcke erstaunlicherweise nicht.
Also ich war echt ein bisschen überrascht und ich glaube, dieses Gespräch,
das kommt gar nicht so aufregend daher eigentlich, aber das wird sehr viele
Thüringer, manche vielleicht, die zum ersten Mal Höckes Stimme so hören, die immer dachten,
der Höcke ist dieser Zampano im Hintergrund, der hält ja nicht mal beim AfD-Parteitag
reden und wird trotzdem immer gehandelt als der große Chef, der hält den Laden
da zusammen und so weiter.
Das ist genau dieses, ja die Merkel, die macht das schon.
Sie ist einfach da, sie schwebt so über den Dingen das Präsidiale irgendwas ich finde.
Das ja ganz erstaunlich, dass in den Podcast da von Schneiroda also das ist ja das,
sehr das ist ja das das rechtsintellektuelle Lager das Höcke berät und zu diesem
Kreis da gehört und dann sagt Kubitschek ja auch immer ja,
wir müssen das Land dann wieder aufbauen und solche Dinge und dann denke ich
immer Ja, und dann denke ich immer, ich sehe dann so.
Ich sitze da bei… Du holst mal die Schippe in die Hand und baust das Land wieder auf. Was? Kein Bock.
Ja, ich sitze ja einmal die Woche bei so einem Italiener in einem größeren Supermarkt
und kann dann immer auf die Kasse blicken, trinke dort einen Espresso und sehe
dann dort die Leute vorbeischleichen in so einer großen Lethargie.
Und da dachte ich schon, soll ich denen mal zurufen, hey, habt ihr Lust nächstes
Jahr das Land aufzubauen?
Dann sagen die, nee, also da hinten ist auch noch was im Angebot,
da wollten wir eigentlich nachher noch vorbeifahren.
Ja, und jetzt hören wir mal und ich sage es dazu, man muss sich jetzt auch ein
bisschen Mühe geben, sich in den Thüringer Rhein zu versetzen.
Wenn man das aber schafft.
Das sind ganz neue Töne von dir hier, Stefan.
Wenn man das aber schafft. Was ist passiert?
Komm, warst du einmal ein Weimar, kommst du hier als Ossi zurück?
Ja, also wenn man es schafft, sich jetzt in den Thüringer Bumer hinein zu versetzen,
der übrig gebliebene, der es noch schaffte, sich in den Gartenzaun hinzusetzen
und seine Ruhe haben will.
Dann wird man von Höcke jetzt aufgestört. Ansonsten hört man einfach nur, was man so hören will.
Also versetze ich in den Thüringer rein. Höcke beginnt.
Die AfD will einen neuen Bund europäischer
Staaten mit einem robusten Grenzschutz, mit einem freien Markt,
mit dem Schutz unserer Identität und mit einer strategischen Entwicklung hin
zu einer militärischen Autonomie, die Europa als neuen Pol in einer entstehenden
multipolaren Weltordnung stark macht.
Ja, verfängt überhaupt nicht. Das war ja schon damals die These von Harald Schmidt zu Norbert Röttgen.
Der hält eine Rede und sagt irgendwas von transatlantischer Partnerschaft und multipolarer Welt etc.
Die Leute sitzen in der Eifel und sagen, was redet der da? Wer redet von Identität
und Autonomie? Können die nichts mit anfangen.
Mhm. So, jetzt kommt Vogt.
Die Europäische Union könnte in den großen Dingen viel mehr bewegen und sollte
sich aus den kleinen Dingen raushalten. Aber es ist das Haus,
was uns immer geschützt hat. Und dieses Haus...
Das hat ein stabiles Fundament. Da erleben wir unsere Freiheiten, da begegnen wir uns.
Das ist die zweitgrößte Demokratie der Welt. Das ist im Kern vor allen Dingen
auch der größte Binnenmarkt. Wir als Deutsche profitieren davon.
Und diese Stabilität, die braucht es. Nur weil mal irgendwie eine Lampe kaputt
ist oder eine Tür quietscht, reißt man doch nicht das ganze Haus ab.
Und das ist das, was Herr Höcke möchte. Herr Höcke möchte, dass die Europäische Union stirbt.
So, die Ossis können sich beschweren, wie sie wollen. Sie wissen,
dass sie eigentlich gut beschützt werden.
Sie wissen, dass sie zu den Top 5% der Welt gehören.
Und sie wissen, dass das ganz viel damit zusammenhängt, dass sich irgendwelche
Wessis um sie kümmern die ganze Zeit.
Das steckt da einfach in dieser DNA nach 30 Jahren drin.
Dass sie dagegen opponieren, weil sie gern selber ihr Schicksal in der Hand
hätten, hier gerne auch irgendwie so einen alten Goethe-Kranken,
die nochmal aufstehen und irgendwie Frankfurt als Weimarer und so.
Funktioniert alles nicht. Es gibt diese Ossis einfach nicht.
Aber es steckt in dem Ossi drin, dass dieser Satz das Haus, das uns immer beschützt
hat, war die Europäische Union.
Und das ist stabil. Der verfängt da einfach. Also das ist ein Satz,
der richtig gut funktioniert.
Wie kommt er eigentlich, dass Deutschland die zweitgrößte Demokratie ist?
Nee, Europa ist die zweitgrößte Demokratie als Pol in dieser Welt.
So, und jetzt versucht Höcke, Europa, dieses große Haus, das uns immer beschützt
hat, was stimmt, man kann sich ja nicht richtig vorstellen, 1989 war für die
Ossis so ein, wir wissen es nicht genau, morgen gibt es entweder Krieg oder nicht.
Also ja, es war so richtig so ein, wir bereiten uns mal drauf vor, keiner weiß es.
Und dann gab es aber keinen Krieg. Und ja, es gab dann Massenarbeitslosigkeit
und so weiter, aber es war auch irgendwie klar, hier scheint die Sonne,
wir können jetzt in den Urlaub fahren, wir kriegen unsere Bratwürste in Magdala,
alles ist geregelt, so irgendwie. Wir haben unser Bauhaus, wir können auf die Goethe stolz sein.
Nichts droht hier zerstört zu werden. Das ist so ein ganz wichtiges,
nicht nochmal so eine riesige Katastrophe.
Wir hatten schon eine im Erleben, dann kommt ja der sachsen-anhaltinische Hasselhoff
und sagt dann, jetzt ist der Westen dran.
Das sind so die Sätze. Wir haben uns genug verändert, wir haben genug Aufregung
im Leben gehabt, Jetzt ist der Westen dran, wenn dann die großen,
Also Transformations- und Digitalisierung, also wir haben das tollste Mobiltelefonnetz
der Welt und so weiter, weil es ist alles ganz neu.
Die besten Autobahnen jetzt ist der Westen. Das ist die Haltung.
Und Höcke mit diesem, nee, wir brauchen jetzt hier die multipolare irgendwas,
Pol, Welt und so, das ist alles verwirrend.
Und jetzt versucht Höcke dieses große Haus, wie er es eben dargestellt hat,
das uns immer Schutz geboten hat, so ein bisschen, ich weiß auch nicht.
Wir möchten, dass die Europäische Union stirbt, in dem Sinne,
damit das wahre Europa leben kann.
Und Herr Vogt hat sich hier nicht sehr gut ausgedrückt, denn Fakt ist doch,
dass die CDU mit ihrer Agenda in EU-Europa auch für das Verbrenner ausgesorgt
hat. Dieses Verbrenner aus deindustrialisiert Deutschland.
Sie sagen Ja zur Agenda der Europäischen Union, die da heißt Fit for 55,
die da heißt Klimaneutralität 2050, die da heißt Green Deal,
die da heißt Dekarbonisierung, die da heißt Luftbesteuerung,
das heißt CO2-Bepreisung.
Alles das macht Deutschland konkurrenzunfähig auf dem globalen Markt.
Die Energiepreise gehen durch die Decke. Die Deindustrialisierung Deutschlands ist ihr Werk.
Sie sind der Wohlstandsvernichter Deutschlands mit der EU, die eben diese Politik
durchzieht, die Deutschland schadet. Deswegen müssen wir raus aus dieser EU.
Er geht einfach all in, wir müssen raus aus dieser EU, weil Luftbesteuerung.
Das kann keiner nachvollziehen, das macht keinen Sinn. Da muss man ganz schön
viel TikTok und Telegram gelesen haben, damit man dann so ah ja,
jetzt bringt er meine Punkte oder so. Also wen das unvermittelt trifft,
Da denkt man sich einfach, wegen Verbrenner, außer wenn man jetzt aus der EU
raus, nee, dann kaufe ich mir lieber ein Elektroauto und fahre weiter durch
mein stabiles Europa, irgendwie so.
Also es funktioniert einfach nicht. Und es ist insbesondere,
wenn die Inkonsistenzen dann zunehmen, Höcke versucht das mal, ganz aktuelle Sachen,
also tagesaktuelle Politik im Fernsehen umzumünzen auf, das große,
stabile Haus soll zerstört werden, das uns Vogt da in den Raum gestellt hat.
Jeder Unternehmer, der wirklich nachdenkt, der ist mittlerweile der festen Überzeugung,
dass die Bürokratie unerträglich geworden ist, dass die Gängelung unerträglich
geworden ist, dass die weitere Zentralisierung Europas unerträglich geworden
ist, dass vor allen Dingen die Energiepreise, die,
wie ich gerade skizziert habe, durch die EU in immer größere Höhen getrieben
werden, für ihn nicht mehr haltbar sind.
Ja, die Energiepreise haben dann wirklich, also klar haben die irgendwas mit
der Europäischen Union zu tun, aber das ist nun mal, da ist ein Krieg,
da ist eine Nachrichtenlage, da ist irgendwas.
Das ist nun wirklich unberührt von diesem großen Haus, das uns immer beschützt
hat, in das wir ja auch erst mitten in unserer Biografie reingerutscht sind,
dankbarerweise, weil wir es uns gewünscht haben und so weiter.
Ja, das ist mehr so eine Blaupause, der könnte jetzt ja auch das Ganze gegen
Washington oder Berlin richten, das würde genauso wenig funktionieren,
aber klingt erstmal so einigermaßen empört.
Ja, große Talking Points, große Semantik, irgendwas, aber es ist nicht runterbrechbar,
das ist nicht nachvollziehbar.
Er redet sich im Grunde im Kopf und Kragen und für den Fall,
dass noch Leute Aufklärung brauchen, hat er auch eigene Anmerkungen.
Das Verbrennerverbot hat die CDU verhindert.
Steht in Ihrem Europawahlprogramm, gucken Sie nach. Das verhindert die CDU.
Aber jetzt machen wir doch erstmal, wir gehen... An die Zuschauer,
es gibt auch einen alternativen Faktencheck auf meinem X-Account.
Wir bleiben einfach mal sachlich. Ja, natürlich.
Sie müssen nicht nervös sein hier. Sondern es geht im Kern um eine ganz simple
Frage. Das, was Sie wollen, ist, aus der Europäischen Union aussteigen.
Einen alternativen Faktencheck gibt es auf meinem X-Account.
Das heißt, da kriegen die Schweißausbrüche.
Ja, da sind 0,5% der Zuschauer kennen X.
Ja.
So muss man es festhalten.
Ja, also X kennt niemand, selbst wenn man Twitter sagt.
Wird es schwierig. Ja, also das ist nur für die paar Eingeweihten.
Ich möchte auch nochmal sagen, dass Vogt natürlich in einer Lockerheit da steht.
Also er formuliert so ruhig und langsam. Vogt hat sich wirklich vorbereitet.
Als wäre das Leben und Tod für ihn. Ja. Das ist geübt, das ist geprobt.
Aber genau das merkt man ihm ja nicht mehr an. Er steht da ja so,
als würde er sagen, gut, jetzt wollen wir mal nicht verrückt spielen.
Ja, es erfordert von uns jetzt auch, dass wir, man kann sich erstmal nicht ganz frei machen,
das kann man in der Nachhinein immer noch aufklären, aber wenn er jetzt sagt,
wir haben als CDU das Verbrennerverbot verhindert, dann sympathisieren wir jetzt
so ein bisschen damit, weil das ja ein Argument gegen Höcke ist.
Da würde ich sagen, lass dem erstmal Raum.
Wir haben es hier leider mit Thüringen zu tun.
Ja, nur, dass man hier nicht missverstanden wird. Man muss das manchmal sagen,
sonst kriegen wir böse E-Mails. Wir sind jetzt keine Vogt-Fans geworden.
Wir raten auch nicht zur Wahl oder sonst irgendwas.
Das CDU-Wahlprogramm habe ich bei Wohlstand für alle mit Ole besprochen. Das ist wirklich irre.
Ja, alles zugestanden. Wir wollen jetzt unter dieser Prämisse,
wie reden die und welche Argumente kann man machen und wie kann man ein Publikum erreichen,
dies jetzt betrachten und erlauben uns dann auch hin und wieder Vogt zu loben,
auch wenn wir jetzt nicht uns darüber freuen, dass die CDU nochmal den Verbrenner
ein paar Jahre länger erhalten will.
Ja, genau. Also, dass hier Ramelow keine Rolle spielt in der Anbahnung solcher
Gespräche, hat die bundestagslinke Fraktion zu verantworten.
Also, Ramelow wurde mit seiner Regierungsarbeit einfach durch einen Bundestrend rausgekegelt.
Und das können wir nun nur betrauern.
Es ist nun so, dass Vogt hier Höcke wirklich entzaubert.
Wir haben natürlich nur Zuhörer, die auf Zack sind.
Diese folgenden Sachen hier sind so irre, also ich konnte es nicht ganz glauben,
schon einzusteigen mit, Herr Höcke, Sie haben bei einer Rede gesagt,
vor Ihrem eigenen Publikum, in einem Monolog, wir müssen aus Europa,
aus der EU aussteigen, damit das wahre Europa leben kann.
Vogt hat gesagt, den Satz möchte ich gerne mit ihm im Dialog vor nicht nur ihren eigenen Leuten.
Und Höcke hätten alle Alarmglocken läuten müssen. Mach das nicht.
Das ist dumm. Die Leute, mach noch mal eine demoskopische Erhebung.
Die Leute haben Angst davor, wenn jemand sagt, aus der EU aussteigen. So. Vogt,
Die reden hier schon 10 Minuten, kommt dann hier mit.
Das, was Sie wollen, sind leere Regale in Supermärkten in Deutschland.
Sie wollen, dass... Das hatten wir in der Corona-Zeit ja zur Genüge.
Ich lasse Sie ausreden, es wäre in Ordnung, wenn Sie mich auch ausreden lassen würden.
Und wenn wir uns angucken, leere Regale im Supermarkt, Arbeitslosigkeit und
vor allen Dingen Wohlstandsvernichter.
Sie legen quasi die Axt und brechen das Rückgrat der stärksten Exportnationen,
die es innerhalb Europas gibt.
Und das, was sie hier wollen, das gibt es am Leben. Ein Beispiel.
Gucken Sie sich das doch an. Der Brexit, den wir gerade erlebt haben.
So, er legt jetzt den Brexit auf den Tisch. In England ist eine riesige Diskussion,
nicht darum, ob der Brexit falsch war, sondern ob er falsch gemacht wurde.
Nigel Farage und so weiter, gerade wieder großer Aufwind. Der Brexit wurde falsch
gemacht. Den hätte man besser machen müssen.
Ja, also dieses typische, wenn eine Verschwörungstheorie sich als haltlos erweist, geht man all in.
Ja.
Es ist völlig Banane. Wenn Vogt hier sagt, sagt der Brexit.
Alle Welt sagt, der Brexit war die dümmste Entscheidung, die ever irgendwo stattfand.
England ist abgeschmiert, die brauchten dafür auch gar kein Corona,
sondern das ist einfach, jedes fünfte Kind lebt in absoluter Armut.
Man kann sich das eigentlich gar nicht vorstellen. Höcke so,
ne, wenn ich ja schon keine roten Flacken sehe beim Thema, wir sollen aus der
EU aussteigen, da gehe ich natürlich all in.
Wenn er den Brexit wirft, dann sage ich, ja, Brexit ist doch eine tolle Sache.
Ich glaube, Höcke ist der einzige Politiker auf der Welt, der einfach sagt,
Brexit ist eine tolle Sache.
Es geht nur darum, dass Sie jetzt ganz viele Sachen in den öffentlichen Raum
gestellt haben, die nicht unkommentiert bleiben können.
Es ist falsch, dass der Brexit Großbritannien geschaltet hat.
Gucken Sie auf die aktuellen Zahlen zum BIP.
Deutschland steckt in der Rezession. Es ist so. Und die amerikanische,
die britische Wirtschaft, die ist zumindest stabil und die Perspektiven sind
wesentlich besser für Großbritannien als für den Euroraum.
Das sind die aktuellen Zahlen. Nochmal, die Klimapolitik der EU,
die die maßgebliche Agenda ist, hinter der sie stehen, deren Folge die CO2-Bepreisung
ist, deren Folge ist, dass die Energiepreise in der EU immer weiter durch die Decke gehen,
hat dazu geführt und der Kampf gegen den Verbrennermotor als Kampf gegen die
deutsche Automobilindustrie und das ist das Rückgrat unserer Wirtschaft,
das werden sie nicht in Abrede stellen.
Ja, jetzt kommen wir wieder mit diesen Detailsachen, die so Tagespolitik sind,
wo man sagen muss, ja, da ist gegen Corona und da sind irgendwie Lieferketten
gerissen und klar, im Diskurs wird es dann zeigen, keine Zentralbank der Welt
weiß, was Inflation ist und so weiter, also alle sind verwirrt, aber der Brexit,
das ist falsch, dass der Brexit kein Erfolg war, weil Deutschland ist jetzt
in der Rezension und England nicht.
Jeder, der nur irgendwelche Bilder aus England sieht, und die Ossis sind wirklich
viel nach England gefahren.
Das ist so ein bisschen wie die Polen, die sind gleich nach England gezogen,
aber die Ossis, die wollten London sehen und Paris und so. Sie wissen im Grunde.
Ich meine, wenn man so Kinder hat oder so, irgendwie so einen Schüleraustausch.
Also England ist einfach ein abschreckendes Beispiel. Niemand sagt,
das ist ein Positiv. Also es war für mich ganz überraschend,
dass eigentlich ein Profi wie Höcke dann plötzlich sagt, der Brexit sei ein Erfolg.
Also ein noch deindustrialisierteres und ärmeres Land hat man doch eigentlich
gar nicht, um das zu verdeutlichen und er macht das trotzdem.
Nun gut, er klopft noch ein bisschen Sprüche.
Wir brauchen eine EU für den kleinen und Mittelstand. Wir brauchen eine EU für
die Angestellten und Arbeit, für die Familien, aber wir brauchen keine EU der
Großkonzerne. Genau das ist es.
Diese EU ist eine Globalisierungsinstanz, die die Nation und den Wirtschaftsraum
Europa in einer Art und Weise gleichschaltet, wie das der europäischen Tradition zuwiderläuft.
Die reden ja miteinander. Das heißt, die Moderatoren stehen mal dabei,
geben Stichworte, aber eigentlich führen die ein Gespräch miteinander.
Das ist ganz erstaunlich.
Also die Journalisten hatten ja das auf 45 Minuten angesetzt und dann haben
die aber so miteinander gesprochen und dann haben die es einfach laufen lassen.
Es ging am Ende anderthalb Stunden oder so.
Dadurch, dass es ja Welt-TV ist, im Internet war ja keine Sendezeit.
Und Höcke hat sich hier, entweder war es Kopf und Kragen, oder er hat sich,
also ich meine, bevor dieses Brexit war ein Erfolg, sagt er,
hat er sich ja ins Gespräch reingekämpft.
Ihm wurde ja nicht das Gespräch erteilt und er war dann dran und hat dann ein
Argument gemacht, sondern er hat sich das Wort erobert und man fragt sich gleich
wieder, warum jetzt eigentlich?
Also sitzt man ja dann auch davor und fragt sich so, das macht doch gar keinen Sinn.
Du erkämpfst dir jetzt die Möglichkeit, hier was zu sagen und dann sagst du
aber, der Brexit war ein Erfolg.
Also das ist eine ganz große, wie soll man sagen, das ist wirklich einfach doof,
das so zu machen, gerade vor unbedarftem Publikum, das ihn vielleicht das erste
Mal sieht und wirklich ein anderes Bild von ihm hat.
Migration. Höcke will ganz viel Geld sparen. Bei sowas würde ich auch sagen,
der Brexit hat es gezeigt.
Man kann mit so einem Bus rumfahren, wo drauf steht, wir sparen jede Woche 60 Millionen für das NHS.
Und es ist das kaputteste Krankensystem der Welt. Also die Leute warten im Schnitt
acht Monate auf eine Behandlung. Wenn du einen Krankenwagen rufst,
kommt der manchmal erst nach 18 Stunden.
Also in England fallen reihenweise die Leute einfach tot um,
weil niemand mehr für einen ordentlichen Gesundheitsservice sorgen kann. und genau so...
Aber das weißt ja nur du.
Ja, das ist jetzt wieder so ein, da müsste man schon eine Reportage dazu dann
jetzt mal gesehen haben oder so.
Ja, ja, eben.
Aber wir wissen, wie der Brexit losging mit diesem Bus. Also den Bus kennt glaube
ich jeder, dass Boris Johnson damit zum Bus rumfuhr.
Ja, der fuhr mit dem Bus da rum, aber ich versuche mich jetzt nochmal rein zu
versetzen in den potenziellen Wähler und der weiß das garantiert nicht.
Wahrscheinlich. Außer man hat irgendeinen Bezug zu England, dann hat man es
auf jeden Fall mitbekommen.
Ja, aber es mag ja sein, dass da manche mal waren vor Jahren,
aber ich habe immer noch den Verdacht, dass wir jetzt hier auf einer faktischen
Argumentation sind und da glaube ich, kann Höcke sagen, was er will.
Also ich glaube nur da, wo jetzt Vogt es tatsächlich schafft,
eine Kommunikation zu pflegen, die so intuitiv verständlich ist,
wie das ist das Haus und das wollen wir beschützen.
Alles was darüber hinaus geht, ist glaube ich etwas, was so oder so für den
einen oder anderen ausgehen kann.
Also Verbrennerhaus würde ich sagen, das reicht nicht als Nadelstich,
um gegen dieses Bild des großen Hauses irgendwas zu erreichen.
Ja, das würde ich auch sagen. Das ist ja eine ganz interessante Geschichte,
dass das jetzt nochmal so neu aufgekocht wird, auch von der CDU,
also natürlich auch, weil die AfD das als Großthema macht.
Auch weil Söder davon nicht ablassen kann.
Verbrenner aus wird glaube ich auch das nächste halbe Jahr erledigt,
dadurch dass Tesla jetzt einfach Platz macht.
Im Automarkt. Denen geht es ja richtig schlecht. Also es waren ja alle überrascht
von diesen Zahlen, dass da so ein riesiger Gigant einfach so richtig wegbröckeln kann.
Nun gut, Migration. Also Höcke will einsteigen über, wir können da ganz viel deutsches Geld sparen.
Die legale Einwanderung, die leider ja auch von der CDU maßgeblich initiiert
worden ist, kostet uns pro Jahr 50 Milliarden Euro.
Jetzt nehmen Sie die Entwicklungshilfeposten und nehmen Sie die 50 Milliarden,
da sind Sie schon bei 60, also insgesamt bei 110, aber wir wollen die Entwicklungshilfe
nicht ganz zusammenstreichen, aber wir sind auf jeden Fall bei 70,
80 Milliarden Euro im Jahr.
Das Geld ist da, es wird nur nicht im deutschen Interesse ausgegeben und das
muss wieder das Primat der deutschen Politik sein.
So, und ich erhalte jetzt nochmal, was ich eben gesagt habe.
Vogt führt jetzt nicht unsere Meinung vor.
Also damit will ich nicht uns freisprechen von Vogts Meinung,
sondern ich möchte, dass jeder Hörer jetzt kurz versteht, hier redet die CDU
gegen die AfD beim Thema Migration für ein ostdeutsches Publikum.
Hier ist alles schon verloren. Das ist schon verbrannte Erde.
Hier gibt es nicht nochmal irgendeinen Kleeblatt zu gießen.
Hier kann man nicht mit einem progressiven Vorschlag machen.
Genau. Wir wollen jetzt nur performance-mäßig sehen, wie sich der Vogt darauf
vorbereitet hat, hier Höcke auseinanderzunehmen.
Vogt erklärt erstmal seine Migrationspolitik.
Ich habe bei mir im Wahlkreis Kindergärten, da können Deutsche keine Plätze
erhalten, weil sie für Ausländer reserviert sind.
Das ist der falsche Weg. Und deswegen müssen wir bei dem Thema illegale Migration
eine ganz klare Strategie fahren.
Null illegale Migration in Deutschland.
Das ist auch nicht so kompliziert eigentlich. Es gibt ja keine illegale Migration.
Das voraus, harte rechtsstaatliche Unterstützung für unsere Polizei,
für unsere Justizbehörden.
Zweitens konsequentes Rückführen und Abschieben. Und das dritte,
absolute Begrenzung durch Außengrenzenschutz bei der illegalen Migration.
Und jetzt sage ich Ihnen eins, wir haben ein klares Prinzip als CDU in Thüringen. Wer arbeitet...
Wer sich an Recht und Gesetz hält, wer zu Recht hier ist und wer sich an unsere
Leitkultur hält, der bleibt.
Ja, dem wird applaudiert. Also der darf dann bleiben, gönnerhafterweise.
Vogt greift jetzt an diesem Punkt, er braucht also eine kleine Rampe, Höcke direkt an.
Wissen Sie was, die AfD hat einen einzigen Landrat in Deutschland,
in Thüringen, in Sonneberg.
Und die harte Haltung, die Herr Höcke immer versucht zu vertreten,
würde ja bedeuten, dass die AfD dort beginnt. Aber was passiert?
Keine Bezahlkarte, keine Arbeitsverpflichtung, nichts.
Und das ist die Backen aufblasen, Probleme beschreiben, aber kein einziges Thema lösen.
Ja, der eine Landrat, nichts.
Wir erinnern uns, ja.
Also man muss halt auch, ja man muss einfach feststellen, dieser Landrat dort
scheitert halt wirklich daran, dass die nicht wissen, wie das funktioniert.
Also wenn die sagen, wir wollen eine Bezahlkarte einfüllen, dann wissen die
einfach nicht handwerklich, wie man das juristisch macht, sodass sie dann gilt.
Also die leiden wirklich an Inkompetenz. Und deswegen kann er ihn auch einfach hier so vorführen.
Der macht da nichts. Er hat plakatiert mit irgendwas Diesel und so.
Und jetzt muss er Bezahlkarten einführen. So, und das kann er nicht.
Er müsste sich halt wirklich jemanden aus Bayern oder so da holen.
Das ist ja so ein Best Case. Irgendwas, sich das gegenseitig vorführen.
Wir können im Prinzip dankbar sein, dadurch, dass lange Zeit ...
Der Faschismus in Deutschland keine politische Rolle mehr spielte nach 1945,
haben sich also auch keine Strukturen gebildet, wo Kompetenzen da sind.
Weil das ja immer ganz entscheidend ist, wenn man irgendwo zur Macht kommt,
dass man auch Leute hat, die irgendetwas umsetzen können. Und das zeigt sich
auf mehreren Ebenen, auf der Personalebene, aber auch beim Verständnis dessen,
was man eigentlich wirtschaftlich vorhat.
Also die wollen Tabula Rasa, die würden, wenn sie jetzt einen Dexit machen,
Deutschland garantiert ins Chaos stürzen und das ist ja auch der Grund dafür,
warum so viele Unternehmer jetzt gerade warnen vor der AfD.
Das ist natürlich zum einen deshalb, weil sie die Arbeitskräfte aus dem Ausland
wollen, zum anderen aber auch, weil sie wissen, wenn die wirtschaftspolitisch
irgendwo in Ministerien das Sagen hätten, ging alles drunter und drüber und
insofern kann man noch dankbar sein.
Dass die Inkompetenz der AfD so groß ist, dass sie also auch diese schlimmen
Projekte, die sie vorhaben inklusive Remigration wahrscheinlich gar nicht so
leicht umsetzen könnten, weil ihnen einfach das Know-how dafür fehlt.
Es ist ja auch ganz interessant, was sie so alles ja nicht akzeptieren.
Adam Tooze hat in einem Vortrag bei Fiscal Future ja so eine Statistik gezeigt,
dass bei der AfD und die AfD-Wähler eine große Angst haben vor ukrainischen Flüchtlingen,
also vor Frauen und Kindern, die weiß sind, worauf Adam Tooze das dann zuspitzte.
Ja, man muss eigentlich sagen, mit der AfD ist nicht mal ein Faschismus zu machen.
Also so inkompetent sind die.
Und er sagt ja auch, man kann im Prinzip noch froh sein deshalb bei der AfD,
weil sie vollkommen an dieser Schuldenregel, Austeritätspolitik,
also das ist, da ist sie ja total Anhänger von, denn wirklich gefährlich würde
es, man hätte eine faschistische Partei, die….
Progressive Wirtschaftspolitik im völkischen Sinne machen würde und sagt,
wir brauchen Investitionen, denn das war ja das Programm der Nazis gewesen,
das war ja eine große Investitionsoffensive mit dem Ziele eines Krieges dann, den man anzettelt.
Und das sehen wir also hier nicht, also maximale Inkompetenz auf allen Ebenen,
das kann sozusagen die Rettung sein,
insofern als man sich nicht rhetorisch oder so entlarvt, sondern man entlarvt
sich dadurch, dass man die Dinge, die man verspricht, nicht im geringsten umsetzen kann.
Und dann ist die CDU natürlich als eine Partei, die so sehr in den Strukturen
drin ist und verwurzelt ist, immer eher die Partei, die als kompetent wahrgenommen wird.
Und die hat halt auch einen Rekrutierungsbetrieb, der zumindest die Personallage
unterfüttert, wenn man dann in Regierung wechselt.
Das ist ja auch eins der großen Sachen von Trump 1 und Trump 2 Präsidentschaft.
Trump 1 Präsidentschaft war am Ende nur noch Executive Orders unterschreiben,
weil man gar nicht weiß, wer mehr als Unterschrift, was, wie und so.
Und der The Daily von der New York Times hat heute am 30.
April ein Gespräch mit Maggie Haberman und noch Kollegen veröffentlicht,
wo sie mal diese Präsidentschaft 2, die machen da so eine Textreihe jetzt,
durchgehen, dass jetzt schon Vorkehrungen getroffen wurden, was alles demnächst
unter Executive Order am Kongress vorbei geregelt werden kann,
weil relativ viel war einfach nur in Normen historisch gesichert,
aber nicht juristisch festgeschrieben.
Und dazu zählt auch das Verhalten des FED-Präsidenten, das demnächst dem Weißen
Haus unterworfen werden kann.
Also in der Sicht und natürlich dieses Justice Department da zertrümmern wollen,
die ja sowieso relativ nah, anders als in Deutschland eine Staatsanwaltschaft,
die ja immer selbst gesteuert ist.
In Amerika läuft das ja alles unter politischem Vorbehalt, wie das alles auf
Seiten des Weißen Hauses umgemodelt wird, aber,
Hat eben da auch acht Jahre gedauert. Also dieser Wissenstransfer von Huch,
wir sind ja Präsident, zu, ah ja, so kann man das dann machen,
dauert eine Weile. Und mit einem Landrat ist eben nichts zu gewinnen.
Und in der Hinsicht hat er diesen Punkt gemacht.
Höcke ist Erwiderung. Naja, er ist ja Geschichtslehrer, er macht also eine Geschichtsstunde draus.
Herr Höcke, nur zu. Herr Vogt, es war Ihre CDU-Bundeskanzlerin Angela Merkel,
die die Grenzen geöffnet hat, beziehungsweise nicht geschlossen hat und die
die Willkommenspolitik ausgerufen hat.
Ab 2015 sind in den Vorgängern 10 Millionen Menschen zu uns gekommen,
viele von denen illegal.
Ja, 2015 ist natürlich immer noch ein Hashtagjahr, das man leicht erinnern kann,
aber es ist trotzdem neun Jahre her.
Also mit Angela Merkel als Galleonsfigur und so weiter kommt man vielleicht
alsbald nicht mehr so weit, insbesondere nicht, wenn man die Jungen so dafür
begeistern will, weil die kennen Angela Merkel nur noch aus dem Geschichtsbuch,
in dem auch, was weiß ich,
der Sonnenkönig drinsteht oder so.
Irgendwann verschirmt alles im Hintergrund.
Vogt versucht es ein bisschen lebensweltlicher.
Irgendwann wird der Höcke vielleicht auch mal in einem Klinikum liegen.
Und wenn er dann den Knopf drückt und wenn seine Politik Wirklichkeit wird,
dann kommt dann irgendwann niemand, wenn er den Knopf drückt.
Und das ist die Realität.
Genau das, wir haben ja das Buch damals von Parakana gelesen und der hat dort
eine sehr böswillige Passage, in der er schreibt,
wie man eigentlich Migration im Osten gestalten müsste und dann wird man denen
klar machen können in Ostdeutschland,
dass sie irgendwann jemanden brauchen,
der sie noch in den Betten rumdreht und dass das Migranten sein werden.
Und genau diese Argumentation hat er jetzt hier aufgegriffen.
Und anders als viele unserer Hörer, also die Ostdeutschen haben sehr viel Kontakt
mit dem Gesundheitssystem.
Denn da ist einfach demnächst jeder Zehnte bis Zwanzigste, je nach Landkreis, mit Pflegestufe.
Geht also jeden Monat mindestens zum Arzt. Und die wissen genau,
dass sie da Personal brauchen.
Vogt macht hier einen Spruch, ich muss ein bisschen lachen.
Wissen Sie, wir werden keine neuen Unternehmensansiedlungen und auch keine neuen
Fachkräfte gewinnen, wenn der Reichskanzler Höcke zur Eröffnung kommt.
Und deswegen kann ich Ihnen nur eins sagen, das ist genau das Problem.
Sie sind Gift für das Land, was meine Heimat ist. Und genau deswegen stehen
wir heute hier. Jetzt werden sie aber radikalpopulistisch.
Einen politischen Witz muss man genau so machen. Man macht eine Pointe und schließt
danach noch eine andere an, damit man sich nicht bei der ersten verfängt.
Und jetzt lachen sie immer bitte alle oder so. Das ist ja kein Comedy-Programm.
Also sagt man zuerst und dann kommt der Reichskanzler Höcke zur Eröffnung und
danach macht man irgendeinen harten Spruch mit, das ist das Gift und so weiter.
Also es ist wirklich sehr gut, es hat mir sehr gut gefallen.
Höcke erklärt, warum Deutschland eh unattraktiv für die Fachkräfte ist.
Ich würde sagen, ja, damit hat er nicht ganz Unrecht. Es fehlt nur so ein Punkt noch.
Wo ist das Problem? Das Problem ist, dass Deutschland für wirkliche Fachkräfte
so unattraktiv geworden ist, auch für internationale Fachkräfte,
dass die einen großen Bogen um Deutschland machen.
Die wollen gar nicht nach Deutschland, weil die Steuer- und Abgabenlast so hoch
ist, weil der Bürokratiewahnsinn hier über alle Grenzen aufgewuchert ist,
weil dieses Land ein Land ist, in dem man nicht mehr richtig atmen kann,
weil die Meinungsfreiheit eingegrenzt ist.
Das ist die Situation.
Sie brauchen jetzt hier keine Luftblasen zu produzieren. Sie sind ja zuständig bzw.
Verantwortlich für den miserablen Zustand dieses Landes.
Also Fugt ist Oppositionschef und nicht zuständig für und so weiter.
Warum machen Ausländer großen Bogen um Thüringen und warum verlassen sie Thüringen
wieder, wenn sie einmal da waren?
Weil es da einfach fremdenfeindlich zugeht.
Das hat er irgendwie vergessen in seiner Liste, aber gut aus Gründen.
So und jetzt kommt er auf seine, wir haben ja alle gelernt, jetzt die letzten
Monate Remigration. Wir haben es ja auch hier groß thematisiert,
was hat es mit dieser Remigration auf sich? Das war wirklich sehr amüsant.
Das heißt, Deutsche, die einen Pass haben, die sollen Deutschland verlassen.
Das ist Remigration für ihn.
So, und jetzt 25 Prozent, ich übersetze es mal, das ist so ungefähr ein Viertel
unserer Bevölkerung. Das heißt doch nichts anderes.
Wie soll es denn ablaufen? Wie weit wird denn dann im Stammbaum zurückgegangen?
Wer passt denn dann nicht ins Bild?
Heißt es dann eins, zwei, drei, raus?
Das ist doch in gewisser Weise die Philosophie, die Herr Höcke hier vertritt.
Und deswegen, das ist eine absolut menschenunwürdige Vorstellung.
So, ich weiß noch, dass ich damals sehr dafür geworben habe,
wenn die sagen 25 Millionen, spielt das einmal durch.
Und sagt nicht irgendwie, oh, das ist aber ganz schlimm oder so,
sondern spielt das einmal durch.
Er macht das hier plakativ, vier Leute im Studio, eins, zwei,
drei, vier, einer muss gehen. So, das ist einfach die Kalkulation, die stattfindet.
Höcke jetzt mit irgendwelchen, ich habe es gar nicht verstanden,
also ich habe mich ja wirklich viel mit Demografie beschäftigt,
aber ich verstehe nicht, was er hier sagt und damit würde ich sagen,
auch Oma Erna in Thüringen nicht.
Jeden Tag remigrieren, remigrare, lateinisch zurückwandern, migrieren Menschen
zurück in ihre Heimat. Das ist ein normaler Vorgang.
Aber mir geht es vor allen Dingen um die hochpassizierten...
Die tun das auch meistens freiwillig, Herr Höcke.
Ja, mir geht es aber vor allen Dingen um die deutschen Staatsangehörigen,
die im Ausland leben, weil sie auf Deutschland geflohen sind.
Das ist eine ganz neue Definition.
Die haben wir von Ihnen bisher noch gar nicht gehört. Das ist eigentlich eine
alte Definition von mir.
1,5 Millionen Menschen, das muss man sich wirklich auf die Zunge zergehen lassen,
sind in den letzten 30 Jahren ausgewandert.
Ja, das kann ich lösen. Ich habe ja das Wahlprogramm der AfD gelesen.
Und sie haben folgendes vor, also neben der Remigration im Sinne von du gehörst
hier nicht hin, du wirst abgeschoben,
soll es auch eine Remigrationswelle in eine andere Richtung gehen,
nämlich man möchte im Ausland werben, vielleicht im Silicon Valley und sonst wo,
bei jenen Deutschen, die vor Jahren, Jahrzehnten Deutschland verlassen haben,
doch bitte jetzt nach Deutschland zurückzukommen, weil die AfD jetzt alles so schön gemacht hat.
Und das kann man sich ja vorstellen, dass da die Leute, die in San Francisco
es geschafft haben, jetzt sagen, prima, die AfD regiert, da komme ich doch zurück
und arbeite für ein Achtel.
Okay, aber das ist selbst für sich eine Argumentation, die noch kein Fernsehzuschauer
mal gehört hat, die muss man dann nachlesen.
In der Hinsicht ist das überraschend. Er schließt aber direkt an,
das muss man sich mal vorstellen, 1,5 Millionen Auswanderer in den vergangenen 30 Jahren.
Ich kann mir nur erklären, dass er hier meinte, seit der deutschen Einheit sind
1,5 Millionen Ostdeutsche nach Westdeutschland gegangen.
Das meint er mit 30 Jahren, weil was war vor 30 Jahren? Kann ja nur die deutsche Einheit meinen.
Naja gut, ins Ausland werden ja sicherlich innerhalb von 30 Jahren 1,5 Millionen
Deutsche gegangen sein.
Ausland sind, also es wandern jedes Jahr 4.000 bis 600.000 Menschen aus Deutschland ab.
Darunter sind viele, die vorher erst zugewandert haben. Aber wenn man auf 30
Jahre geht, müsste man hier von zig Millionen Menschen reden,
die Deutschland verlassen haben oder hin und her pendelt oder was auch immer.
Also dafür, dass er schocken will mit 1,5 Millionen Menschen aus 30 Jahren.
Ich würde sagen, selbst die Abwanderungswelle aus Ostdeutschland lag über 1,5 Millionen.
Ja, bestimmt.
Also in der Hinsicht, das ist, man weiß nicht so genau. Weder die Remigrationsidee,
die er vorgestellt hat, ist irgendwie eine Sehgewohnheit, noch diese Zahl.
Also man sitzt da vorne und denkt sich, ja, macht keinen Sinn.
Vogt hat sich eine Phrase zum Universalismus zurechtgelegt. Wir sind ja große
Fans des Universalismus.
Wir wollen jetzt nicht erwarten, dass Vogt unsere politische Haltung hier teilt.
Es ist die Thüringer CDU, die auch schon mit der AfD zusammengearbeitet hat,
für die Familienfamilien.
Das Grunderwerbssteuer von 6,5 auf 5,5 gesenkt, was auch immer.
Aber er versucht sich hier mal am Universalismus.
Jetzt sage ich Ihnen was ganz Simples. Es gibt viele Unterschiede,
die christliche Demokraten von Ihnen als AfD-Mann unterscheiden.
Aber das ist der Kernbestandteil. Der Kernbestandteil besteht darin,
dass ich jeden Mensch wertschätze.
Dass ich ihn nicht auf ein einziges Merkmal reduziere. Sei es seine Hautfarbe, sei es seine Religion.
Sondern ich glaube daran, dass
jeder etwas kann. Das ist die Würde des Menschen, das ist unantastbar.
Aber hier im Grundgesetz steht das drin. Und das, was sie wollen,
ist diejenigen, die anders sind, die nicht in den Kram passen.
Das ist ihre völkische These.
Die wollen sie alle raushaben. Irgendwann sind es die Brillenträger.
Und genau deswegen, Herr Höcke, dieser völkische Müll, der darf mein Heimatland
Thüringen nicht führen. Und deswegen kämpfe ich.
Ja, ist ausgezeichnet gemacht auch von der Performance, also wer da mal reinschauen
will, Höcke hat einen viel zu großen Kragen, viel zu großen Hemdkragen,
also da kannst du ja zehn Finger reinstecken an der Seite, das funktioniert gar nicht.
Und während Vogt ihm zugewandt ist die ganze Zeit,
er sagt wirklich, verstehen Sie doch, ich will doch, ich erzähle es Ihnen ja,
blickt Höcke ins Nichts an ihm vorbei und sieht sich vermutlich schon im Sportpalast.
Und genau dieser Eindruck, der da entsteht, ist einer, der auch beim Zuschauer sich überträgt.
Denn hier ist auch wieder ganz wichtig, das Auge hört mit.
Es sind nicht nur die Argumente, die gebracht werden, die hier sehr gut vorgebracht
werden, sondern es ist die Art.
Er hat nach dem Grundgesetz gegriffen, um es ihm kurz hinzuhalten.
Auch dann nochmal zu dieser Verweis, und irgendwann sind es dann die Brillenträger.
Und greift sich an die eigene Brille dabei.
Warum haben wir dieses rhetorische Talent vorher nicht erkannt?
Ich würde mal sagen, er musste so viel dafür üben, das kann man auch nur einmal im Leben machen.
Meinst du?
Also Vogt wusste, dass das seine Chance des Jahrhunderts ist,
hier nennenswert zu sein.
Als er sich dann mit einer Bratwurst oder sowas hat ablichten lassen,
weil es da noch Giersprenkel darum gibt, was ist jetzt eine Bratwurst und so,
hat Marcel Schütz drüber geschrieben, nur noch wenige Sekunden bis Kanzler- Diskussion.
Ja, das ist ganz erstaunlich, wie er das macht.
Nee, Vogt hat selten erkennen Politiker den Moment.
Vogt hat ihn hier erkannt und gut genutzt, muss man wirklich sagen.
Höcke reagiert jetzt auf du hast es ja beschrieben, er taucht so wieder auf
aus seinem, ich bin ja gerade irgendwo gewesen, schon in meinem Walhalla oder
so und jetzt wird es richtig peinlich, also es ist auch wirklich,
man ist ein bisschen Fremdscham.
Lieber Herr Vogt das ist ja schön, dass wir mal einen Halbsatz aus meinem Buch
zitieren, den hätten sie aber nicht aufschreiben den hätten sie aber nicht aufschreiben
müssen den hätten sie eigentlich auch aus dem Kopf zitieren müssen,
diese Passage ist ja eingebettet in einen Kontext, vielleicht lesen sie sich
zumindest die Seite nochmal durch, wenn Sie auch nicht das ganze Buch lesen,
dass ich Ihnen aber wirklich zur Lektüre empfehle, weil das sicherlich auch
einiges noch in Hintergrundinformationen bietet.
So, Höcke sagt nicht nur, ich habe ein Buch geschrieben, sondern er hat ein
gutes Buch geschrieben.
Es ist so gut, nehmen Sie mal diesen Teil, den Sie zitiert haben,
lernen Sie den auswendig und die Passage drumrum ist für Sie bestimmt auch interessant.
So, das heißt, Höcke kennt sein Buch ziemlich gut.
Bis er es dann 30 Sekunden später plötzlich gar nicht mehr gut kennt.
Müsste also die Bundestagsvizepräsidentin in Deutschland verlassen,
wenn Sie an die Macht kommen? Also ich habe, das Buch ist mittlerweile jetzt schon sechs Jahre alt.
Aber dann distanzieren Sie sich jetzt von Ihrem eigenen Buch?
Als Zitat, ich distanziere mich von überhaupt gar nichts.
Nur Sie können jetzt von mir nicht voraussetzen, dass ich nach sechs Jahren
noch jede Passage meines Buches mit Verlaub.
Aber ich habe Sie ja nach heute gefragt. Aber bleiben Sie denn dabei,
dass Frau Özoguz in Deutschland nichts verloren hat? Nochmal.
Ja, da rutscht er fast in den Dialekt, weil er so überfordert ist mit der Situation.
Ja, das ist wirklich kreativ.
Und was die gerne sehen wollen. Das ist das A und O.
Ja, es ist die der Saumagen.
Die Burger-Connection über Saumagen. Oder über das Bier.
Die Kanzler haben ja immer Bier, Saumagen, irgendwas. Das ist ja dann erst,
bei Merkel wusste man es nicht mehr und Scholz, der fotografiert sich ja nur
noch mit Büchern, die er angeblich liest.
Apropos der Götz.
Er wird hier kurz angesprochen.
Also Ihre großen Wortschweilen und dieses Rumgeeiere, das finde ich bemerkenswert.
Ich hätte wenigstens erwartet, dass Sie heute den Mumm haben,
zu Ihren Thesen zu stehen.
Aber dass Sie hier anders reden als auf Ihren Parteitagen, das zeigt mir doch nur eines.
Dass Sie nicht zu der Konsequenz stehen, die Sie eigentlich wollen.
Sie wollen Leute, die nicht in Ihren Kram passen, die einen deutschen Pass haben.
Und ich habe mir Ihre Passage en detail angehört. 12.
Dezember 2023. 23. Da geht es um das Thema doppelte Staatsbürgerschaft und Sie
sagen, ja, diejenigen, die den Pass haben, die müssen sich entscheiden und dann
gehen sie halt raus und 20 bis 30 Prozent, auf die können wir verzichten.
Das ist ein ganz anderes Thema, der Doppelpass. Nein, nein, nein.
Entschuldigen Sie bitte.
Sie haben über Remigration von 20 bis 30 Prozent von Deutschen geredet.
Und das, was Sie auf Ihrem Nazischloss da in Schnellroda diskutieren mit Ihrem
Spiritus Rector, das ist einfach die große Gefährlichkeit, dass da eben Sellner
und andere ein- und ausgehen.
Das ist so gut, weil das ist nämlich genau diese Rolle, die Höcke,
auf die er Jahre hingearbeitet hat.
Ich bin der große Denker, der da im Hintergrund die Sachen regelt und so weiter
und jetzt ist es einfach so ein Nazischloss mit ihrem Spiritus Rectus und so.
Und natürlich, der normale Bürger interessiert sich nicht für die großen Denker.
Wie gesagt, dann wären bei Zeit Online, bei den meistgelesenen Artikeln ganz
anderes vorne und es ist der Ratefuchs. Das sollte man sich immer vergegenwärtigen.
Es ist der Ratefuchs, der interessiert eine Million Menschen.
Wir überspringen ein bisschen, was ich zu Familie sage. Natürlich sind sie alle
große Familienfreunde.
Verweise auf die Redeanteile. Hier merkt man dann immer, Höcke weiß einfach
nicht, wo er da gerade ist und was da mit ihm passiert.
Ihre Redeanteile sind auch deutlich vor denen von Herrn Vogt.
Das kann ich mir fast gar nicht vorstellen.
Das ist so, ich kann es Ihnen ganz genau sagen. 32 Minuten. Wir brauchen Frieden
mit Russland, wir brauchen Kooperation mit Russland und wir brauchen keinen
Hass zwischen Deutschen und Russen.
Wenn wir etwas gelernt haben aus der Geschichte des 20.
Jahrhunderts, dann das Frieden mit Russland für uns absolut ist es.
Sie wollen doch auch über Thüringen sprechen, oder nicht?
Sie wollen doch auch über Thüringen reden, oder? Wollen Sie sich im Kopf vom Kragen weiterreden?
Dieses, ich habe ein bisschen drüber nachgedacht, ich weiß nicht,
wie du das, du bist häufiger, nee, du machst ja immer Monologe,
aber so Podiumsdiskussionen oder so.
Ja, ja.
Ich war die Woche auch wieder bei einer, wo es so um wissenschaftliche Kommunikation und so weiter ging.
Und ich finde, wenn man konzentriert bei der Sache ist, ist man sich ziemlich
genau im Bilde darüber, wer hier gerade wie viele Redeanteile hat,
ob man gerade das Recht hat, nochmal zu sagen, oder ob erstmal jemand anders dran ist oder so.
Es ist, dass er da aus allen Wolken fällt, muss ich sagen, wo ich niesen muss.
Es ist ja so, dass er offenbar nicht jemand ist, der in irgendeiner Weise,
auf soziale Interaktion aus ist, dass er glaubt, dass wenn alle anderen reden,
dass einfach nur die Störung seines Gesprächs, dass er mit sich selbst führt ist, ist ja logisch.
Also er sieht ja nur seine eigene Position und lässt sich ja,
also man sieht es ja gestisch schon, und dass er sich auf kein Gespräch einlässt,
sondern eigentlich gerne jetzt eine Rede halten würde von einer Stunde.
Genau, also er hat es einfach sehr falsch eingeschätzt, wo er da ist.
Er hat sich überhaupt gar nicht vorbereitet. Deswegen auch so alberne Sprüche.
Kollege Vogt, ich finde es unterhörig, wenn Sie mir unterstellen,
ich wäre ein Mensch, der hasst.
Der Hass als Gefühl ist mir völlig unbekannt. Ich war 15 Jahre Lehrer.
Ich war viele Jahre Vertrauenslehrer.
Jetzt hat er auch versucht, mal so gefühlig zu werden.
Der Hass als Gefühl ist mir völlig unbekannt. Das ist sehr inkonsistent.
Ja.
Weil erstens, jeder, der das sagt, lügt.
Und er ins Besondere. Er wird ja nicht ohne Grund von Michael Friedmann als
Partei des Hasses und so weiter.
Da muss man dann halt, klar, man muss es ja nicht bekräftigen oder so.
Ja. Aber man muss es auch nicht aufgreifen, wenn es der andere nimmt.
Das ist der Fehler der ganzen Veranstaltung.
Ja. Ein Achilles-Zenensatz wie, wir müssen aus der EU aussteigen,
ist dann plötzlich für ihn, ja, ja, mache ich.
Das erkläre ich Ihnen gerne, warum ich aus der EU aussteige.
Und dann so ein Quatsch, also es ist wirklich ganz schräg.
Und es schwankt immer hin und her zwischen, was weiß ich, was weiß ich nicht,
was steht in meinem Buch, lesen Sie es, lernen Sie es auswendig oder nee,
ich weiß selber nicht, was da drin steht.
So auch bei seinen gerade laufenden Prozessen zum Thema Alles für Deutschland.
Das ja eine Losung ist, die verboten ist, wenn man sie in gewissen Kontexten sagt.
Man darf natürlich Werbeplakate mit, alles für Deutschland oder so weiter oder
wie auch immer, aber man darf es halt nicht in so einer politischen Rede,
die nun wirklich darauf ausgelegt ist, Anleihen zu finden und jetzt hat er gemeint,
er ist ja Geschichtslehrer gewesen und so weiter.
Was hat es damit auf sich, Sie greifen es kurz auf.
Ich habe es in einer Wahlkampfrede in diesem Dreiklang, alles für unsere Heimat,
alles für Sachsen-Anhalt, alles für Deutschland.
So ausgesprochen, weil ich es nicht wusste.
Ja, glauben wir ihm das. Ich finde, man kann auf vieles plädieren,
aber nicht auf Dummheit.
Das ist für einen Politiker einfach nie gut.
Ja.
So dieses, da hatte ich Gedächtnislücken und so.
Es ist mir einfach eine zu blöde Frage, die ich mir gar nicht stellen will,
wie absichtlich er was macht.
Ich traue ihm zu, dass er weiß, was er sagt.
Ja, ich finde auch, hier kommt es ja nicht darauf an, dass er jetzt verurteilt
wird oder so, sondern der Prozess alleine. Ist doch Verurteilung genug?
Ja, beziehungsweise muss man ein bisschen vorsichtig sein. Dieser Prozess,
von wem wird er wie rezipiert? Also wir würden sagen, ja, das ist Verurteilung genug.
Für andere kann das aber dann sowas sein wie, ja, da sieht man es ja, sobald man mal was sagt.
Kommt man vor Gericht.
Also ich würde sagen, dass der Prozess, egal was dabei herauskommt,
wird in keiner Weise Höcke schaden.
Ja, vor dem Prozess sitzen zwei, die Staatsanwaltschaft und er.
Für die einen ist doch klar, allein, dass der Prozess läuft.
Und so sage ich auch, allein, dass der Prozess läuft. Es geht halt aus beiden
Richtungen, aber es vertieft die Gräben. Ist in der Endzeit vielleicht nicht
so besonders konstruktiv.
Aber wir reden jetzt gerade hier rüber und würde da auch nochmal sagen,
jetzt haben wir diesen ganzen Skandal um Maximilian Krah und dessen Mitarbeiter.
Aber glaubst du, dass das tatsächlich dafür sorgt, dass ein Wählerpublikum abgeschreckt ist?
Ja, in dem Fall ja.
Die Leute sagen, ja, also der kungelt offenbar mit der chinesischen Diktatur.
Diese Nähe zu den autokratischen Herrschern, die könnte auch für Trump gefährlich werden.
Und Trump sagt ja wirklich öffentlich, dass er Orban für ein Vorbild hält,
dass er Putin bewundert und Xi, also diese Auf-Lebens-Zeit, das ist ja genial,
hat er damals schon gesagt.
Und ich glaube, das ist nicht klug.
Also in einem Schafpelz auszutreten ist nicht nur ein Spruch,
sondern das lohnt sich auch manchmal einfach zu praktizieren.
Sondern diese Diskussion, weil in der Art wie John Oliver, nicht John Oliver,
sondern John, der Dingsdabums Daily Show, der jetzt montags wieder,
wie heißt der denn, Stuart, John Stuart das macht.
Das ist ja wirklich wahnsinnig interessant, beide Seiten zu drangsalieren.
Also bei beiden zu sagen, ihr sagt uns immer, der ist im Oval Office total auf
Zack und ist in allen Diskussionen beteiligt, dann zeigt uns doch Filme davon.
Also ihr zeigt uns immer nur das, wo er öffentlich irgendwie rumstampelt.
Dann zeigt uns doch, wie er im Oval Office seinen Geschäften nachgeht.
So, diesen Verdacht zu nähren, finde ich absolut richtig.
Und bei Donald Trump immer wieder darauf hinzuweisen, das ist schon so ein bisschen,
wir sind doch eigentlich Land of the Free und so. Und das ist absolut inkonsistent.
Jetzt zu sagen, nee, am liebsten hätten wir eine Corona-Pandemie nochmal,
damit wir so eine App da durchregieren können, das verfängt dann schon.
Also ich finde, bei all diesen Fragen, es gibt immer so eine Gefühligkeit,
die man selber aus der Leistungsrolle heraus hat.
Also man ist der Wahlkämpfer, der die ganze Tour mitmacht und so.
Und dann gibt es aber diese Publikumsrolle.
Und so wie man bei dem Thema EU austritt,
Vorher sich wirklich hinsetzen muss und es demoskopisch analysieren muss,
was man dann in so einem Gespräch sagt.
Muss man das auch bei diesen, ich finde die Art Autokraten cool.
Ja, ich habe nur meine Skepsis, dass das von potenziellen Wellen auch als so
eine große Gefahr angesehen wird, also dass die nicht eher sagen,
naja, die haben ja alle irgendwo ein bisschen Dreck am Stecken,
so wird dann die Politik publiziert und dann ist das nun da auch irgendwas gewesen.
Aber man muss halt klug machen.
Dass es die AfD-Wähler kostet. Da bin ich überhaupt nicht von überzeugt,
denn das ist so ein diffuses Bild und damit müsste man sich näher auseinandersetzen.
Da ist dann doch am Ende die Performance wieder entscheidend und wenn wir jetzt
hier über Performances reden,
dann können wir ja festhalten, dass sowohl Tino Kruppaller als auch Maximilian
Krah wahnsinnig gut funktionieren vor der Kamera im direkten Gespräch,
in der Art der Ansprache.
Wenn wir feststellen, dass so viele junge Männer Wenn die Männer bereit sind,
die AfD zu wählen, dann liegt das glaube ich auch an der Tonalität,
die angeschlagen wird, wenn Krah spricht.
Das ist nicht so ein Wischiwaschi, das ist so ein klarer Standpunkt.
Er spricht oft so, wie wahrscheinlich sich manche jungen Leute doch wünschen,
dass mal ein Erwachsener mit ihnen spricht.
Also das beherrscht er ja wahnsinnig gut und ich glaube, dass diese Stärke,
die er da rhetorisch hat, dann den eigentlichen Skandal stark überdecken wird.
Ja, also….
Mein Argument zu sagen, es sollten nur noch Politiker mit Politikern reden und
nicht mehr Journalisten mit Politikern, rührt nicht nur daher,
dass im Fernsehen so viel Quatsch stattfindet, sondern die sechs Stunden mit
Graber, Jung und Naiv, die ich nicht geguckt habe, nur punktuell.
Aber die Sachen, die ich gesehen habe, es macht keinen Sinn,
einem Politiker, in dem Fall ist es nämlich egal aus welcher Himmelsrichtung,
der irgendwas Vernünftiges sagt, ihm dann zu sagen, das haben die Nazis auch gemacht.
Denn so wie Höcke hier sagt, ich bin gegen den Krieg, was wir gleich noch hören,
weil ich nicht will, dass da junge Menschen sterben.
Ja, sehr gut, das ist schon mal richtig.
Da gibt es jetzt gar keinen Grund, Widerstand zu üben, nur weil er im Übrigen
auch möchte, dass die Jungs der anderen gerne im Mittelmeer ertrinken sollen,
statt hier irgendwie ein Leben zu finden.
In der Hinsicht muss man sich als Journalist super sorgfältig darauf vorbereiten,
wo man hier Widersprüche übt und insbesondere, welche Fragen man stellt.
Und ich habe noch kein Beispiel gesehen, also wirklich gar kein Beispiel,
wo ein Journalist mit einem AfD-Politiker so redet, wie ich finde,
dass der Vogt das sehr gut gemacht hat, mit dem Höcke hier zu reden.
Das gibt es einfach nicht. Und ich würde jetzt sagen, es gibt es einfach prinzipiell nicht.
Also es kann es einfach gar nicht geben. Wir müssten hier mal eine theoretische
Analyse der Arenendifferenzierung machen.
Die beiden kämpfen im Nullsummspiel um Publikum.
Wenn der Höcke hier keine Punkte macht, macht sie in diesem Falle der Vogt automatisch.
Und wenn Vogt scheitert, gewinnt Höcke.
Das ist ausgeschlossen in dem Gespräch mit dem Journalisten.
Ja, weil Journalisten mit AfD-Politikern reingehen mit der Maßgabe,
ich muss den entzaubern, entlarven und das Publikum darüber unterrichten, dass der rechts ist.
Das funktioniert aber nicht, wenn, also das kann man machen,
wenn man eine SPD- oder CDU-Politiker vor sich hat, der irgendwas zum Thema
Migration sagt, wo man dann ihm zeigen kann,
das ist aber eine echt rechte Position, die du da vertrittst.
Lieber Herr So-und-So, wenn du aber jemanden hast wie Maximilian Krah,
der sagt, ich bin rechts, ne ich bin nicht konservativ, ich bin rechts,
was willst du entlarven?
Genau, entscheidend ist nicht die inhaltliche Aufklärung. Also Aufklärung im
Sinne von inhaltlich nochmal eine Schippe drauflegen und dann ist plötzlich
so ein Siedepunkt des Wissens erreicht, dann können wir die Nudeln in den Topf
geben, ist einfach nicht.
Am besten Beispiel darstellbar an diesem nächsten Beispiel,
es geht um eine politische Diskussion, ist Herr Höcke jetzt Neonazi oder nicht,
weil wenn er solche Sätze in diesem Kontext wie alles für Deutschland verwendet,
muss man sagen, ja, irgendwie schon.
Und dann mit der berechtigten Frage, was haben wir dann gewonnen,
wenn das festgestellt wird.
Die einen werden sagen, na seht ihr, alle werden hier wegen einzelnen Worten
irgendwie ewig lange in Prozesse verwickelt.
Und wir sagen, das hat man vorher schon gewusst, dass der irgendwie durchgedreht
ist. Also niemand gewinnt irgendetwas.
Aber Politiker untereinander können vor einem Publikum, wenn sie ungefähr wissen,
was sie von diesem Publikum wollen, und das ist ganz entscheidend,
nämlich beide dasselbe.
Ein Journalist wäre ja etwas ganz anderes von einem Publikum als ein Politiker.
Deswegen schaffen die es nicht, diese
entsprechende konstruktive Erregung herzustellen. Die beiden aber schon.
Und jetzt achten wir mal drauf, wie Vogt diese inhaltlichen Fragen,
was machen Sie da vor Gericht, was haben Sie da gesagt, wie haben Sie das gemeint
und so weiter, was bedeutet das?
Einfach ablöst als Problemstellung für sich und sagt, ich mache das über Performance.
Wir sind die Partei des Rechtsstaates und Recht und Ordnung.
Und desavouieren Sie das nicht, gehen Sie in Ihrem Verfahren,
das wird ein deutsches Gericht behandeln und da können Sie Ihre Argumente vortragen.
Aber bitte weinen Sie jetzt hier nicht.
Bitte weinen Sie jetzt hier nicht. Das sind doch die Sätze, die ich hören will
in einer politischen Diskussion. Also ernsthaft.
Ganz richtig. Also der Vorschlag wäre jetzt, wir wollen jetzt einen richtigen
Formatvorschlag machen.
Der Vorschlag ist, es gibt eine Redaktion, die ist nur dafür da,
die Leute anzurufen, da hinzubringen, eine Taxiquittung entgegenzunehmen.
Aber die Sendung sieht so aus, dass man sagt, wir haben da zwei oder vier Stühle,
da könnt ihr euch hinsetzen, hier sind die Kameras, die sind an,
nach 90 Minuten holen wir euch hier wieder raus und jetzt redet miteinander.
Das wäre die Politik-Sendung, die vielleicht interessant wäre.
Nicht ganz. Aus Erfahrung wissen wir, aus dem österreichischen Präsidentenwahlkampf,
als damals Van der Bellen gegen den Typen im Stock von der FPÖ,
die haben ja wirklich ohne Moderation miteinander gesprochen und es ist komplett
daneben gegangen. Also die haben sich ja wirklich geprügelt fast.
Das nicht, aber die Journalisten stellen Fragen, um Themen aufzuwerfen und Themen abzuschließen.
Und das war's. Also das TV-Duell an sich, aber mit Duell sind die Politiker
gemeint. das einen moderativen Rahmen bekommt.
Auch da wieder die österreichische Erfahrung. TV-Duelle haben wir in Österreich
mindestens 50 pro Nationalratswahl.
Also da gibt es dann das Duell von den beiden in dem Sender,
in dem Sender, in dem Sender, in dem Sender. Man kann es auch übertreiben.
Also es ist kein Patentrezept gegen eine FPÖ-ÖVP-Regierung.
Aber das TV-Duell an sich, anhand dieses Beispiels hier, wo es wirklich um was
geht, weil die beiden wissen, Thüringen ist so unwichtig, wir kriegen nur einmal
eine bundesweite Bühne.
Und zwar, wenn wir als Pioniere dieses Gesprächs führen. Und das hat der Vogt
verstanden und der Höcke nicht.
Höcke kriegt jetzt auch keine zweite Chance, das bis September nochmal gerade
zu biegen. Das war jetzt das TV-Duell.
Und wie überrascht er ist, wir hören es nochmal an diesem Beispiel.
Einmal der Hinweis, Herr Höcke, weil Sie sich vorhin etwas benachteiligt fühlten,
was die Redeanteile angeht. Wir haben mal auf die Uhr geguckt,
Sie haben deutlich mehr geredet bisher als Herr Vogt.
Das nur so als kleiner Zwischenstand. Es kommt immer anders vor selber.
Kommen wir zum nächsten Thema.
Wie ein kleiner Schuljunge. An dieser völlig unhintergehbaren,
jeder Zuschauer kann das selber überprüfen, Information scheitern sie,
weil sie gefühlsmäßig ganz daneben liegen.
Und so, das ist wirklich beispielhaft für dieses ganze Gespräch.
Ein kleines Thema noch, weil Sie das am Tag des Gedenkens der Befreiung von
Buchenwald aufgenommen haben.
Drei Clips zum Thema Krieg und Vernichtung und so weiter.
Hier die kurze Einführung der Journalisten nochmal.
Dafür sind Sie dann da und sagen, es ist ja ein besonderer Tag.
Und ich finde, jemand, der im KZ Buchenwald Hausverbot hat, der darf nicht Thüringer
Ministerpräsident werden.
Und deswegen ist auch der richtige Tag, heute darüber zu diskutieren.
Herr Höcke, auch an Sie die Frage, welche Bedeutung hat dieser Tag für Sie?
Die Stiftung Buchenwald entscheidet darüber, wer in Thüringen Ministerpräsident wird.
Sie haben ein Demokratieverständnis. Kollege Vogt, das entscheidet immer noch
der Thüringer Sovereign.
Warten wir mal ab, was der 1.9. bringt. Dann kommen wir zurück bitte auf die
Frage, die ich Ihnen beide...
Wirkt ja fast so, Ihre nachdenkliche Antwort, wirkt ja fast so,
als hätten Sie die Frage im Vorfeld... Herr Höcke, ganz kurz die Frage,
die ich Ihnen beide gestellt habe. Was bedeutet dieser Gedenktag heute für Sie
persönlich? Das ist meine Frage. Genau.
Das ist ein wichtiger Erinnerungstag und ich persönlich würde gerne auch mit
meinen Kollegen aus der Landtagsfraktion diesen Gedenktag auch im ehemaligen KZ Buchenwald begehen.
Ja, ob das jetzt die Hörer anders gehört haben, für die es gedacht ist,
aber hier noch so ein Streit, obwohl er weiß, worauf die Journalisten hinaus
wollen, nämlich auch ihn zu fragen, was mit dem Gedenktag ist.
Und da noch in so einem Grangel drin zu stecken.
Ganz Banane. Und Höcke durfte dort einfach so Ethnopluralismus vortragen.
Da würde ich ja wieder sagen, ja gut, da muss man jetzt ein bisschen drin sein
in diesen Argumentationsmustern, aber dass das einfach so passiert.
Der Islam ist eine alte Religion. Der Islam hat einen Kulturraum,
wo er sich auch entfalten kann.
Und da möchte ich ihm auch nicht reinreden. Aber dieser Kulturraum kann nicht
Europa sein. Und ich kenne kein Land in der Welt mit einer islamischen Mehrheitsgesellschaft.
Also man kann das Argument so machen, im Sinne von keine persönliche Freizügigkeit,
aber dann auch keine Freizügigkeit für Güter und Finanzen.
Denn wir räumen diese Gebiete da aus, lassen in Bangladesch irgendwie unsere
3-Cent-T-Shirts herstellen und dann sagen wir den Menschen aber,
du hast kein Anrecht darauf, auf die gute Seite des Profits da zu wechseln. Das passt nicht.
Gut, aber das sieht die CDU ja auch nicht viel anders.
Das sieht die CDU auch nicht viel anders und die Journalisten haben das irgendwie,
Also ich hätte gedacht, hier gäbe es eine Pflicht, wenn man eines der Top-3-Argumentationsmuster
einfach mal so nennt, dass man da sagt, ey, sorry, aber das ist ja kurz vorher
alles für Deutschland, das geht nicht.
Gut, zwei Clips zum Abschluss zum Ukraine-Krieg.
Die Bilder, die uns erreichen vor der Front, sind unerträglich.
Hunderttausende junge Männer, Russen und Ukraine, sind in den letzten zwei Jahren dort verblutet.
Junge Männer, die keine Familien gründen konnten, die kein Leben weitergeben konnten.
Das macht mich sprachlos und
fassungslos. Und meine Großeltern haben mir noch erzählt, was Krieg ist.
Also, nach ungefähr einer Stunde Gespräch kommt er mit diesem Tonfall und inhaltlich,
ich will es so sagen, ich finde es amüsant.
Die Punkte, die er anspricht und wie er sie anspricht, sind, die verbluten da,
also das Blut wird verschwendet, sie konnten kein Leben weitergeben,
also die Gene sind im Nichts verendet und seine Eltern haben ihm noch gesagt,
was Krieg ist, obwohl es er hier so auf den Bürgerkrieg anlegt. Ja.
Aber trotzdem glaube ich.
Dass genau diese Ansprache wahnsinnig gut funktioniert.
Die kann in Thüringen gut funktionieren.
Und daraus sollte man nämlich jetzt nicht die Schlussfolgerung ziehen,
dass wenn man das Leid der Soldaten dort beklagt, dass man dann gleichzeitig rechts ist.
Das ist ja das, was jetzt gerade stattfindet. Man hat das ja auch bei Krah gesehen.
Krah hatte das ja besser bei Thilo argumentiert. Krah hat das ja auf sich persönlich
gemünzt. Er sagte ja, ich habe einen 21-jährigen Sohn, der wäre eigentlich perfektes Kanonenfutter.
Dessen Mutter ist gestorben, da war er zehn Jahre alt.
Dann haben seine Großmutter und ich zusammen diesen Jungen aufgepäppelt und
haben uns um den gekümmert und aus dem ist heute was geworden.
Keine Regierung soll doch jetzt kommen und mir diesen Sohn für irgendwelche
hehren Werte nehmen, dass der an der Front verheizt wird.
Diese Argumentation ist egal von wem sie vorgetragen wird, immer richtig.
Also die Schlussfolgerung, nur weil er was
gesagt hat, ist genau diese Irrsinnsargumentation von Karin Miosga sonst,
die Lars Klingbeil fragt, haben sie gesehen, dass bei der Rolf-Mütze-Nicht-Rede
auch AfD-Leute applaudiert haben?
So, als würde man durch diesen Applaus schon beweisen können,
dass die Rede von Rolf Mütze nicht falsch war.
Genau, also da muss man ganz sensibel mit dem, was wirklich gesagt wird, umgehen.
Und meine Taktik wäre, immer darauf zu achten, denen das dann nicht durchgehen
zu lassen, sondern sie dann zu fragen, ja, das klingt nach einer sehr vernünftigen
Meinung, da bin ich auch, aber warum müssen deswegen jetzt so viele Menschen im Mittelmeer sterben?
Richtig.
So, man muss dann das Thema immer wieder zurückholen. So viel Mühe es sich Höcke
auch gegeben hat, hier für das
Thüringer Publikum, kurz vor Ende wirklich diesen Spruch hier zu machen.
Putin weiß auch, außerdem hat er den Druck der Chinesen aus dem Osten,
er hat den Druck des Islam aus dem Süden. Russland ist auch ein bedrängtes Land
und ich glaube, Russland will Frieden.
Und ich glaube, dass Putin trotz dem, was man über ihn ausführt,
ein rationaler Mann ist.
Warum? Russland will Frieden und Putin ist ein rationaler Mann.
Es ist schon, ich finde es aber sehr gut.
Dass Höcke sich wirklich gar nicht darauf vorbereitet hat, wie dieses Gespräch
sich entfalten könnte und deswegen einfach in die offenen Messer gerannt ist.
Dass es die CDU war, okay.
Es ist halt, wie es ist. Wir haben noch kurz Zeit, falls du nicht noch ein großes
Thema hast, würde ich gerne kurz in die Kriminalstatistik reinhören. Okay.
Denn das auch, weil es in Deutschland mittlerweile so ein Usus ist,
es wird die Kriminalstatistik vorgestellt, man hört auf der Bühne die immer
gleichen Phrasen, aber auch im Publikum.
Also ihr konntet jetzt glaube ich im April in jedem Podcast hören,
dass die Kriminalstatistik irgendwie Mumpitz ist. nichts zu gebrauchen.
Das sind ja nur angezeigte Fälle und nicht, was die wirklich machen.
Ermittlungsergebnisse, nichts spielt eine Rolle. Ich würde sagen,
das stimmt eben nur so halb.
Diese Kriminalstatistik wird immer zuerst an die Springerpresse gegeben.
Die nehmen sich die Zahlen raus, publizieren die, danach reden alle über die
Zahlen. Wir kriegen auch Fragen.
Werdet ihr jetzt am Monatsende über die Ausländer und die Kriminalität sprechen?
So im Sinne von, seht ihr, hier kommt nämlich doch nicht drum rum,
zu sagen, dass sie alle kriminell sind und so.
Und es Das stimmt eben nicht so ganz. Klar, man kann hier so einsteigen und
einfach sagen, was hat denn jetzt die Innenministerin in der BBK zum Thema gesagt?
Sieht beinahe aus wie ein Krimi, ist aber echt.
Nur selten unterhaltsam, insgesamt wenig erfreulich.
Es gibt eine gestiegene Gewaltkriminalität, es gibt mehr Jugend und es gibt
mehr Ausländerkriminalität.
Deshalb geht es heute um das notwendige, Notwendige, aus meiner Sicht harte
Durchgreifen des Rechtsstaates, ebenso wie um stärkere Prävention.
So, was für Joachim Herrmann, Innenminister in Bayern, gleich bedeutet,
na ja, dann rede ich mal, weil es um die Kriminalstatistik geht,
gleich über das Kindergartenalter.
Wahr ist aber, dass überdurchschnittlich viele Ausländer straffällig werden.
In der Summe überfordert das unser Land in der Integration.
Nicht nur in der Frage, wo die Unterkünfte geschaffen werden,
sondern auch, wie setzen sie Schulklassen zusammen, wie sieht es in den Kitas aus.
Und wenn da zu viele aus völlig anderen Teilen der Welt hier ankommen,
dann hapert es offensichtlich mit der Integration.
Also wir können gar keine Kinder in irgendeinen Kindergarten schicken,
weil irgendwas mit der Kriminalstatistik ist.
Also alle gehen all in, weil sie genau wissen, die Journalisten machen da mit.
Entsprechend ist dann, nennen sie FESA auch zugeschaltet, hier zum Beispiel in den Tagesthemen.
Professor, der Aspekt, der sofort ins Auge fällt, die deutlich gestiegenen Zahlen
bei Straftaten durch ausländische Tatverdächtige.
Sie sagen, wer sich nicht an die Regeln hält, der muss gehen.
Ja, sie ist ja im Gespräch. Sie können es eigentlich auch selber sagen.
Und sie hat es ja an dem Tag auch schon in der BBK gesagt, nein,
er muss es auch nochmal sagen.
Ist damit das Problem dann gelöst?
Ähm, lass uns kurz überlegen.
Wahrscheinlich nicht.
Es gibt vielfältige Ursachen. Insofern muss man natürlich darauf achten.
Erstmal gilt Null-Toleranz gegenüber Straftaten.
Wir brauchen ein hartes Durchgreifen des Rechtsstaates. Das ist erstmal für mich sehr wichtig.
Und ja, es ist so, wer sich nicht an die Regeln hält, muss gehen.
Wir müssen das erstmal differenziert beobachten. Es gibt viele Ursachen.
Ja, das ist so, wer sich nicht an die Regeln hält, muss gehen.
Das ist ja gut. Danke, Frau Feser. Können Sie uns das nochmal sagen?
Wir sehen ja, wie schwer das ist, Menschen abzuschieben, für die das dann zutrifft
und wie wenige das dann sind. Das wird sich dann in der Kriminalstatistik doch
nicht dann ausgewiesen, eine kleine Minderheit eigentlich nur.
Ich glaube, man muss zweierlei unterscheiden. Das eine ist, dass wir in der
Tat mehr Menschen zurückführen wollen und auch ausweisen wollen.
Gerade auch Straftäter, mehrfach Intensivstraftäter. Deshalb haben wir ja als
Koalition auch die Gesetze verändert.
Wir haben ein großes Abschiebungspaket verabschiedet.
Ja, also wer sich nicht an den Ring hält, muss gehen oder was?
Ich habe es noch nicht ganz rausgehört.
Diejenigen, die hierher kommen, müssen sich an die Regeln halten,
die in Deutschland gelten. Und wer sich daran nicht hält, muss eben gehen.
Okay, okay, okay. Das war ja nun dann auch der Tenor. Also die Kritik.
Wer sich nicht an die Regeln hält, muss gehen.
Also wir haben das alle gehört. Und die Kritik daran ist sehr einfach und sehr richtig.
Und jetzt hören wir aber kurz Holger Münch zu. Der war nämlich auch im Heute-Journal dann zugeschaltet.
Und da zeigt sich doch ein sehr differenzierteres Bild. und wenn man auf den
BKA-Webseiten und der Kriminalstatistik nachliest, dann kann man das da auch
lesen. Also man kann sich durchaus die Mühe machen, jenseits der Kritik,
die man dann immer an was Frau Faeser bei der BBK sagt,
diesen Gesprächsfaden hier aufzunehmen.
Und dann wollen wir das noch vertiefen mit dem Chef des Bundeskriminalamts,
Holger Münch. Guten Abend, Herr Münch.
Guten Abend, Frau Slomka. Die Statistik, die Sie heute vorgelegt haben,
die wird ja auch von Kriminologen betrachtet.
Und die sind dann gar nicht unbedingt so begeistert im Sinne von,
oh toll, frische Zahlen, sondern meistens sehr zurückhaltend.
Manche sagen sogar, so eine Statistik hat eigentlich gar keine Aussagekraft. Wie ordnen Sie das ein?
Ja, gar keine, das würde ich so nicht sagen. Man muss natürlich immer sehen,
dass es eine Ausgangsstatistik ist. Das heißt, sie sagt, was wissen wir über
die Straftaten, die in dem Jahr bearbeitet wurden.
Das ist nicht das Gleiche, wie was ist in dem Jahr passiert.
Aha, wir haben ja also schon mal eine Differenzierung. Es gibt also Effekte,
die für diese Verzerrung sorgen. Welche sind das denn?
Natürlich gibt es Verzerrungseffekte. Wir haben ein Problem,
gerade bei der häuslichen Gewalt, dass dort viel eben im sozialen Nahraum passiert
und eben nicht angezeigt wird, weil Täter und Opfer eben an einem sehr engen
Verbindung miteinander stehen.
Umgekehrt ist es so, dass wir auch aus einigen Forschungen wissen,
dass wenn mir jemand sehr fremd ist, ich auch leichter anzeige.
Das heißt, tatverdächtige ausländische Herkunft eher zur Anzeige gebracht werden als deutsche.
Auch das ist ein Verzerrungseffekt, den man sehen muss.
Was gibt es noch zu diesem hohen, immens hohen Ausländeranteil zu sagen in der
Kriminalstatistik, der ja Felser und Herrmann und so weiter alle da so ans Mikro brachte?
Man muss ganz klar sagen, dass Nichtdeutsche erst einmal häufiger straffällig
werden oder der Anteil der Tatverdächtigen höher ist unter Nichtdeutschen als bei Deutschen.
Das liegt aber nicht an der Herkunft, sondern das liegt an verschiedenen kriminogenen Faktoren.
Also Beispiel geringerer Bildungsabschluss, Zugang zur Leistungsgesellschaft,
einen Beruf ausüben können.
Das schützt vor Kriminalität und wir sehen, dass eben die Bildungsabschlüsse
bei Nichtdeutschen deutlich geringer sind. Wir haben teilweise mehr Gewalterfahrungen
unter denen, die nach Deutschland kommen, bis hin sogar zu traumatischen Erfahrungen.
Auch das ist ein Faktor. Das heißt, es gibt schon deutliche kriminogene Faktoren.
Der jetzige starke Anstieg, der ist aber, wenn man es im Verhältnis setzt zu
dem Bevölkerungsanstieg von Nichtdeutschen, nicht so, dass diese Auffälligkeiten
zunehmen, sondern man kann sagen, das entspricht auch dem Anstieg in der Bevölkerung.
Das ist ein Befund. Der zweite ist, dass wir doch deutliche Anstiege in den
letzten beiden Jahren deshalb sehen, weil wir eine hohe Migrationsdynamik erkennen.
Das heißt, im Zusammenhang mit sehr vielen Zu- und Wegzügen passiert noch mehr
Kriminalität. Die Ankunftssituation ist belastend, man ist fremd im Land.
Es gibt Konflikte auch zwischen den zu uns kommenden Zuwanderern.
Das heißt, auch auf der Opferseite sehen wir einen sehr starken Anstieg von Nichtdeutschen.
Was wir ja bei Felser, Herrmann und diesen ganzen populistischen Diskussionen
erleben, ist ja dieser Wunsch danach, dass man von uns und den anderen spricht,
dass man doch glaubt, dass die eigenen Leute in irgendeiner Weise höherwertig
sind und deswegen auch weniger kriminell sind, während die anderen irgendetwas
in sich zu tragen scheinen, dass sie krimineller macht.
Und das weist dann Höcke in ganz andere Worte nochmal zu kleiden,
aber im Prinzip ist es dasselbe.
Jetzt sehen wir hier einen Experten, der uns sehr klar auftröselt,
womit hängt was eigentlich zusammen.
Also Leute, die Gewalterfahrungen gemacht haben, dann nach Deutschland kommen,
dass die möglicherweise aufgrund dieser Gewalterfahrungen ein anderes Verhältnis
zu Gewalt haben, leuchtet einem sofort ein.
Vor allem wenn es Flüchtlinge sind aus Kriegsgebieten.
Dass jemand in einem schlechten, ja das meine ich ja damit, dass jemand in einem
schlechten ökonomischen Status vielleicht eher die Not hat,
sich etwas zu beschaffen und dies dann auch über Wege tut, die nicht legal sind,
ist leicht verständlich und jemand, der ein dickes Portemonnaie hat,
denkt nicht darüber nach, oder muss ich es vielleicht klauen,
muss ich vielleicht schwarz fahren, muss ich vielleicht dies und das machen.
Das heißt, hier wird das ja sehr stark relativiert und ich finde das sehr wichtig
und ich glaube auch, dass deshalb das so wichtig ist, weil von linker Seite,
und das ist jetzt mal nicht hier Preaching to the Acquire.
Wenn solche Zahlen rauskommen, man das generell unter dieses,
ah das ist wieder was ausländerfeindliches, sondern man könnte ja genau diese
Argumentation mal aufnehmen, sagt, ah es gibt da eine soziale Bedingtheit,
Aber es gibt auch die Fakten, die jetzt da sind, die Bedingtheiten, die Gründe dafür,
für diese Fakten sind da, aber die Fakten sind nun mal auch da.
Also die Fakten zu leugnen ist genauso falsch und das ist ja oft was stattfindet,
auch in anderen Zusammenhängen, also beispielsweise homophobe Übergriffe.
Dass dann auch das gerne von linker Seite ausgeklammert wird,
wenn das in irgendeiner Weise einen Migrationsaspekt tangiert.
Wenn man aber erkennt, aus welchen patriarchalen Strukturen das oft herrührt,
dann sind damit die Taten weiterhin zu verurteilen, sind aber auch gleichermaßen
diese Beweggründe anzugreifen und darüber nachzudenken, wie man etwas verändern kann.
Nur indem man anfängt, Fakten zu leugnen und einfach so tut,
das gibt es alles gar nicht und die Welt ist immer super in Neukölln und sonst
wo, macht man sich natürlich auch für etwas vor.
Und das ist ein ganz großes Problem.
Ja, also Kriminalität fällt ja soziologisch unter einfach Devianz,
also Abweichungen von so Erwartungen, die man so hat oder vielleicht sogar Normen,
normativen Vorstellungen, institutionellem.
Und damit sehr in engen Korridoren gerichteten Verhalten. Und jetzt ist man
ja gerade auf linker Seite, das ist ja auch ein großer Kulturkampf.
Begrüßt man Devianz oder nicht? Und dann sagt man so Sachen wie,
nee, ich finde Homosexualität sollte man jetzt mal als normal ansehen.
Also da wird eine Normalität ausgeweitet auf einen ehemals devianten Bereich.
Und man hat sich dann doch vielleicht sehr daran gewöhnt, dass man alle möglichen
Abweichungen so normalisiert.
Und deswegen die Betonung einer Abweichung, da ist jemand kriminell,
immer gleich, nee, nee, das ist nur der Rassismus, der da dahinter steckt.
Und es führt wirklich nicht weiter. Also man kann sich das auch anschauen,
denn, will es nicht zu extreme sagen, aber sehr viele Täter sind ja auch immer gleich Opfer.
Und es wäre ja durchaus eine Win-Win-Win-Situation, wenn man denen dann hilft,
sodass sie ein nützliches Mitglied der Gesellschaft sind.
Nur diese Hilfe muss halt angeleiert werden. Und der Ursprung dafür ist die
Erkennung und Bewertung einer Devianz, die man dann eben nicht in Abrede stellt,
sondern einfach konstruktiv wendet, auch wenn das sehr aufwendig ist.
Also in dieser Berichterstattung hier vom Heute-Journal oder Tagesthemen waren auch Repertagen dabei,
wie gezeigt wurde, wie über Jahre im 1 zu 1 Sozialarbeit aus 15-jährigen Kriminellen,
25-jährige wertvolle, also auch im Selbstbild wertvolle Mitglieder für die Gesellschaft wurde. oder?
Die dann auch von sich sagen, das ist ja gut, dass mir hier geholfen wurde und
ich helfe jetzt auch. Also die stehen dann durchaus auch bereit.
Kennt man ja immer, dass diejenigen in der Schule die Aufklärung machen,
die selber mal vorher die Seite gewechselt haben und so.
In der Hinsicht gibt es hier viel zu wissen und zu erfahren,
wenn man die polizeiliche Kriminalstatistik mal nimmt, liest...
Und dann mit den Leuten darüber redet, die auch darüber reden wollen,
weil sie aus der Praxis kommen, wie dem Münch zum Beispiel.
Und der letzte Clip dazu, der ist auch ganz interessant, weil er nochmal anknüpft,
wo wir auch begannen. Was ist mit den jungen Leuten?
Wir sehen hier zwei Faktoren, die zuletzt noch eine Rolle spielen.
Zum einen nimmt die gefühlte und auch tatsächliche wirtschaftliche Belastung von Menschen zu.
Das war gerade in den Jahren 22 und 23 sehr auffällig. Also die Inflation,
die man spürt, die Angst vor wirtschaftlichem Abstieg ist ein Faktor,
der korreliert direkt auch mit dem Thema Gewaltkriminalität.
Dann haben wir auch in der Corona-Zeit natürlich Effekte gehabt,
die jetzt im Nachgang nachwirken.
Also gerade der junge Teil der Bevölkerung, Kinder und Jugendliche,
war sehr stark betroffen von den Corona-Maßnahmen.
Jetzt sind sie wieder viel mehr unterwegs. Wir haben also eine höhere Mobilität.
Man trifft mehr aufeinander und damit findet auch mehr Kriminalität statt.
Was wir aber zusätzlich sehen ist, dass Forschungsergebnisse zeigen,
dass psychische Belastung gerade bei Kindern und Jugendlichen über diese Zeit
der Beschränkung hinaus wirkt, also aktuell noch andauert.
Und das ist ein Faktor, den müssen wir weiter im Auge behalten,
weil diese psychischen Belastungen offensichtlich auch ein Faktor sind,
der zu einer höheren Kriminalität beiträgt.
Mhm. Man kann also einfach die polizeiliche Kriminalstatistik nehmen und daran
anknüpfen und mit ihr zusammen konstruktive Argumente machen,
statt nochmal sich an Faser abzuarbeiten.
Und dabei auch wieder die Kriminalstatistik links liegen lassen.
Übrigens ist man dann kein Sonderfall, sondern es ist im Grunde so,
dass alle, wir hören hier mal die Presseschau vom Deutschlandfunk der Tag vom 9.
April, dass mittlerweile alle Journalisten so ein bisschen wissen.
Nicht der Pass macht kriminell, sondern die Lebensbedingungen, meint Zeit Online.
Was gegen Kriminalität wirkt, ist längst bekannt, aber mühselig.
Bessere Betreuung, Kenntnis der deutschen Sprache, Arbeit.
Das alles gilt auch für deutsche Staatsbürger.
Ähnlich argumentiert die Glocke aus Oelde. Vielen Migranten fehlt die Perspektive,
wenn noch nicht über ihren Asylantrag entschieden wurde oder wenn sie bereits
abgelehnt wurden, aber weiter im Land bleiben.
Hinzu kommen Traumata durch Fluchterfahrungen sowie fehlende Beschäftigung,
wenn Geflüchtete in Massenunterkünften untergebracht sind und keiner Arbeit nachgehen können.
Die Freie Presse aus Chemnitz Jetzt geht auf den Anstieg der Jugendkriminalität ein und analysiert.
Die neuen Zahlen zeigen, wie massiv sich die Corona-Pandemie bis heute auswirkt.
Schulen blieben über Wochen geschlossen, Kinder konnten keine Gleichaltrigen sehen.
Ganz gleich, zu welchem Zeitpunkt und wie lange dies zu rechtfertigen gewesen
sein mag oder auch nicht, dass das Konsequenzen hat, ahnten damals schon viele.
Also nächstes Jahr, liebe Mit-Podcaster, wenn die Kriminalstatistik kommt,
Nicht den gleichen Sing-Sang wie immer, sondern die Statistik nehmen,
steht da alles drin und mit den Journalisten zusammen, die das auch schon machen,
Fernsehen und im Radio positiv aufgreifen.
Und wir haben noch Zeit für ein kleines Thema, oder?
Dann machen wir doch Indonesien. Wir sind ja heute so sehr in der Bundesrepublik unterwegs.
Das wollen wir doch gar nicht.
Wir gehen also ganz runter zu den Eklips, zu Nummer 9.
Und wir haben mitbekommen, es gab da vor einigen Wochen eine Wahl und es gibt
auch einen neuen Präsidenten jetzt, der jetzt auch von der Wahlkommission bestätigt wurde, Prabowo.
Ist es nicht mehr der Dings?
Es ist nicht mehr Yoko Widodo, sondern es ist jetzt Prabowo.
Ah ne, Philippinen waren die mit diesem Typen, der alle erschießen wollte.
Ja, ja, nein, nein, also Indonesien hat sich ja da recht gut Jetzt ist es aber
die Frage, also dieser ehemalige Verteidigungsminister, der jetzt nun Präsident
wird, wie ist das mit dem?
Da gibt es sehr viel aus seiner Vergangenheit, wo er eine sehr unrühmliche Rolle gespielt hat.
Das soll jetzt hier unser Thema aber nicht sein. Nein, man kann das alles sehr
gut nachhören, auch bei Deutschlandfunk und sonst wo, woher der so kommt.
Man kann es auch nachlesen. Also er ist Kommandeur gewesen, dem werden Menschenrechtsverletzungen
nachgesagt, verschwinden lassen von Personen, wird ihnen vorgeworfen.
Er ist jemand, der ja auch zu der dunklen Seite der Geschichte Indonesiens gehört.
Die Geschichte, die können wir jetzt auch nicht erzählen, vielleicht nur mal
ganz kurz so als Zahl in den Raum. Raum Indonesien hat 275 Millionen Einwohner,
ist also ein sehr großes Land.
Und dieses Land ist auch ein sehr besonderes, da es ja aus Inseln besteht.
Aus 200 Millionen Inseln?
Nicht ganz, aber es sind 17.500 Inseln. Und...
Was jetzt für uns interessant ist, ist der Umgang mit dem Klimawandel und für
uns ist interessant, wie dieser Wahlkampf stattfindet.
Wir hören jetzt nur mal kurz Jennifer Johnston im Deutschlandfunk über Prabovo.
Tatsächlich, der Älteste ist tatsächlich der Beliebteste bei den jungen Wählerinnen und Wählern.
Er hat sehr gute Berater und ein sehr, sehr gutes Social-Media-Team.
Ich habe mir das vor der Wahl einmal angeschaut, war in deren Zentrale.
Und sie verkaufen ihn da als den süßen Opa mit großen Rehaugen und nutzen dafür
auch künstliche Intelligenz, haben ihn zu so einer Zeichentrick-Figur gemacht,
die seine Katze streichelt, tanzt, Herzen in die Luft malt.
Also ihn wirklich so als den sympathischen Opa verkauft.
Und seine Beliebtheitswerte sind wirklich, seitdem er diese Kampagne im November
gestartet hat, durch die Decke gegangen.
Wir reden ja ganz viel darüber, was wird AI machen und Fake News und so weiter.
Das ist etwas sehr interessantes.
Also man hat hier nicht Videos gemacht, in denen Prabowo auftritt und die aber
von einer AI gestaltet wurden und man aber nicht mehr sagen kann,
ob es AI ist oder der echte Prabowo, sondern man hat gleich eine Figur gemacht,
ich würde sagen wie aus einem Pixar-Film.
Der könnte jetzt auch der nette Opa aus Oben sein oder irgend so einem trolligen Film.
Muss man mal ihn in echt angucken.
Und das hat man jetzt hier mit Bravovo gemacht und hat damit ganz stark Wahlkampf
betrieben in den sozialen Medien und konnte so diesen Mann, der eine durchaus
dunkle Vergangenheit auch hat,
als den lieben guten Opa wie aus einem Pixar-Film verkaufen.
Er hat aus sich eine Ikone gemacht.
Die erste AI-Ikone der Politik.
Also wir haben...
Ein Futterbär. Aber das war ja unfreiwillig.
Ja, das war unfreiwillig. Aber wir haben hier jemanden, der wird von jungen
Leuten gewählt, weil das doch der ist, den wir kennen aus den sozialen Medien,
der eigentlich als eine Cartoon-Figur aufgetreten ist.
Also sollte jeder mal googeln, Prabovo und einfach Cartoon oder Comic dahinter
schreiben, dann wird man sofort unglaublich viel Material finden.
Wir wollen uns aber jetzt gar nicht mit dieser Wahl weiter beschäftigen,
sondern mich hat wirklich diese Sache mit dem Klimawandel mal interessiert.
Denn wir kennen alle den Diskurs, wir haben die Bücher hinreichend besprochen im Salon.
Der Kapitalismus wird bald zu Ende sein, das kommt ohnehin, denn der Klimawandel,
die Klimakatastrophe steht vor der Haustür und deswegen gibt es dann viele,
die sagen, wir haben jetzt noch so und so viel Jahre Zeit, wo wir alles transformieren
müssen. Der Kapitalismus wird an ein Ende gelangen.
Ich habe daran nie geglaubt, warum soll der Kapitalismus einfach an ein Ende
gelangen, der kann ja auch in anderer Weise weiter wursteln und dies sehen wir
jetzt hier in Indonesien in ganz besonderer Weise, denn dieses Land,
diese vielen Inseln sind natürlich vom Klimawandel enorm getroffen,
so sehr sogar, dass man die Hauptstadt verlegen muss.
Also man muss sich das jetzt vorstellen, man würde sagen, Berlin ist bald überschwemmt,
wir müssen Berlin nach Saarbrücken verlegen oder so. Und so etwas findet jetzt hier statt.
Immer höher bauen sie die Mauern, die schützen sollen.
Der Klimawandel lässt den Meeresspiegel steigen, aber bedrohlicher noch, das Land versinkt.
Um bis zu 25 Zentimeter jedes Jahr, 2,50 Meter in zehn Jahren.
In den vergangenen 23 Jahren haben wir unser Haus fünfmal höher gesetzt.
Jedes Mal alles auseinandergebaut. Material kaufen, Holz, Nägel,
die Fassade runter und wieder rauf, solange sie hält.
Und wenn das Holz noch gut ist, verwenden wir es auch wieder.
Nur knapp die Hälfte aller Haushalte hier ist an die Wasserversorgung angeschlossen.
Die anderen pumpen Grundwasser, versorgen sich selbst damit.
Deshalb sinkt der Boden, deshalb säuft Jakarta ab.
Also es geht immer weiter und weiter.
Wir sehen also, dass auch gerade das, was dafür sorgt, dass man überhaupt dann
auch überleben kann, wiederum dafür sorgt, dass eigentlich das Problem immer größer wird.
Und das sollte man sich jetzt mal so als Bild sehen. Also wir kennen alle diese
Bilder, den Ast, auf dem man sägt. Aber hier ist es eher so,
man türmt was auf, aber dadurch untergräbt man wieder was anderes und macht es wieder größer.
Und das gilt jetzt aber auch für das Land im Ganzen, denn dieses Land ist prosperierend.
Die Direktinvestitionen sind enorm gestiegen.
Inzwischen sind das 50 Milliarden Dollar direkte Investitionen.
Das ist also eine Verdopplung innerhalb der vergangenen fünf Jahre.
Das Ziel ist es, dass Indonesien die fünftstärkste Volkswirtschaft wird.
Man setzt ganz stark dann auch auf die Ressourcen, die im Boden sind.
Darauf kommen wir gleich.
Jetzt aber erstmal die Sache mit der Hauptstadt. Was geht dann da vor sich?
Eine andere Insel, Borneo, eine andere Region, Kalimantan, eine neue Hauptstadt, Nusantara.
Der Imagefilm mutet traumhaft an. Eine saubere Stadt, in der nur Elektroautos
fahren, wo die Luft so rein und pur ist.
Eine Stadt ohne Dreck, ohne Müll, ohne Stau. Ein Anti-Jakarta.
Das wird eine einzigartige Kapitale, mit einem ganz eigenen Charakter.
Grün, smart, inklusiv, resilient, intelligent.
Und natürlich wollen wir eine nachhaltige Stadt erschaffen für die Zukunft.
Einzigartig. Eine Stadt im Wald. Und das gibt es sonst nicht auf der Welt.
Es gibt wohl kein anderes Land auf der Welt, das sagen kann,
unsere Hauptstadt ist eine Waldstadt.
Zwei Millionen Menschen sollen dort leben, man kann sich aber vorstellen,
dass das nicht ohne Friktionen vonstatten geht, dass da so sehr viele Umsiedlungen stattfindet.
Aber es scheint mir ein besseres Projekt als diese The Line zu sein.
Wahrscheinlich ja, aber es gibt natürlich auch da Umweltverbände,
die Alarm schlagen, was da jetzt gerade so passiert.
Die Sache ist die, die müssen also jetzt die Hauptstadt verlegen,
weil die alte Hauptstadt absäuft.
Jetzt baut man da also eine völlig neue Stadt,
will die natürlich möglichst modern gestalten mit allen möglichen grünen Transformationen,
die man so braucht, aber es ist also der Verdacht groß,
dass möglicherweise dies eine Stadt sein wird, vor allem für Leute,
die sich das leisten können dort zu leben.
Also die leben dann in so einer Oase, wie das hier geschildert wurde,
aber die anderen tragen großes Leid davon.
Das war jetzt ja gerade ein Bericht vom ZDF heute.
Wir hören jetzt mal, was die BBC dazu sagt.
So I'm afraid that these people who do not have adequate educations to get employed
by these sectors will not be given a broader opportunity in the long run.
The government does have reskilling training programs, but not specifically
to cater people who are affected by the new capital project.
So, wir haben jetzt hier schon gehört, also das könnte so eine Stadt sein,
die neue Ungleichheiten schafft.
Nun ist Indonesien vor einer ganz großen Herausforderung. Ich habe eben schon
gesagt, es gibt über 17.000 Inseln.
Und was ist denn eigentlich mit denen, wenn die immer weiter absaufen?
Nun, es gab da einen interessanten Bericht von Dieter Lianza,
die darauf eingegangen ist für The Conversation, was sich da jetzt gerade tut,
auch in Bezug auf die nationalen Grenzen.
Und zwar heißt es da, der jüngste Bericht des zwischenstaatlichen Ausschusses
der Vereinten Nationen für Klimaänderung stellt fest, dass der Meeresspiegel
weltweit immer schneller ansteigt.
Als Inselstaat mit mehr als 17.000 Inseln, die sich über 80.000 Kilometer Küstenlinie
erstrecken, sollte Indonesien durch diese Erkenntnis alarmiert sein.
Letztes Jahr prognostizierte die Nationale Forschungs- und Innovationsagentur Indonesiens,
dass mindestens 115 der indonesischen Inseln bis zum Jahr 2100 aufgrund einer
Kombination aus Meeresspiegelanstieg und Landabsenkung unter Wasser stehen werden.
Eine neue Studie ergab sogar, dass 92 Inseln in äußerster Randlage Indonesiens
aufgrund der steigenden Meeresspiegel versinken könnten.
Und das bedeutet natürlich auch, dass man...
Und möglicherweise Land verliert im Sinne von, also ich habe auch auf diesen
Raum, wo diese Insel war, die jetzt da gerade runtergegangen ist, kein Recht mehr.
Und auch müssen die Inseln… Weil das dann internationales Gewässer wird.
Oder?
Zum Beispiel. Es heißt hier, dieser besorgniserregende Trend könnte Indonesiens
Status als Inselstaat bedrohen.
Dabei handelt es sich um ein neues Rechtskonzept, das 1982 nach jahrzehntelangen
diplomatischen Bemühungen Indonesiens und anderer Inselstaaten in das Seerechtsübereinkommen
der Vereinten Nationen aufgenommen wurde.
Obwohl einige der Inseln in Indonesien äußerster Randlage wahrscheinlich unbewohnt
sind, haben sie einen strategischen Wert, dass sie die Grundlage für die Abgrenzung
der indonesischen Gewässer bilden.
Und es gibt so eine Regel dann,
also zum Beispiel können die, also so mit Basispunktenberechnung,
wie nah die Inseln einander sein müssen,
damit sie auch zueinander gehören und diese ganzen Fragen stellen sich also jetzt neu,
wenn plötzlich da Land auseinandergezerrt wird, weil einfach viel mehr Wasser da ist.
Also wenn mehr Wasser ist als Land, inwieweit hat man es da noch mit dem Land zu tun?
Das sind also große Fragen, die sich da stellen, die Juristen dann beschäftigen
werden, denn dieses Wasser-Land-Verhältnis ist natürlich entscheidend auch für
die Souveränität Indonesiens.
Also da bin ich gespannt, wie das so weiter ausgeht und hoffe da auch,
dass mehr dazu publiziert wird.
Jetzt können wir aber erst einmal festhalten, die versuchen es mit einer neuen
Hauptstadt, versuchen es da auch mit technischen Innovationen, aber….
Kohle spielt weiterhin eine große Rolle. Wir hören jetzt mal hier Vikak Sonogitavan
vom Just Energy Transition Association,
der ein bisschen das mal einschätzt, wie das mit der Kohle ist.
Die Kohle boomt und wird weiterlaufen, ja. Und hier mal der Energiemix von Indonesien.
Das ist eine Energie-Source, die den nationalen Energie-Mix dominiert, mit rund 40,46,
folgt von Öl, was 30,18 Prozent ist, Gas, was 16,28 Prozent ist und das letzte
ist neue und erneuerbare Energie, was nur 13,09 Prozent ist.
Das ist eigentlich ein bisschen schade, weil der frühere Ziel für renewable energy ist 23% bis 2025,
aber letztlich haben sie diesen Ziel zu rund 17% oder 19% gesteigert und bis
jetzt haben wir nur 13,09%, also das ist noch ein langer Weg zu gehen.
Das heißt, sie wissen, dass der Klimawandel sie existenziell bedroht,
ja sogar die Souveränität des Landes quasi untergräbt.
Zugleich gibt es große Investitionen in Kohle und wie dieser Experte sagt,
wird das auch bleiben, weil sie darauf angewiesen sind, um so eine starke Volkswirtschaft zu werden,
dass sie genügend Energie haben und das ist nun nur über diesen Weg möglich.
Das heißt also, wir haben es hier mit einem System zu tun, das seine eigene
Grundlage untergräbt und jetzt so ein Wettrennen macht. Was kriegen wir eigentlich zuerst fertig?
Aber wir sehen hier, dass das alles auf sehr vielen Ruinen aufgebaut ist.
Also insofern sollten wir vielleicht mal, wenn wir über das Klima diskutieren,
nicht unseren Standpunkt damit negieren, aber doch relativieren,
indem wir uns mal so deutlich machen, wie jetzt aufstrebende Länder mit diesem Klimawandel umgehen.
Die sagen nämlich jetzt nicht gleich, wir müssen auf die Bremse treten,
sondern deren einzige Möglichkeit ist ja auf Dauer erst einmal zu einem gewissen
Wohlstand zu kommen und den müssen sie erreichen auf Kosten der Umwelt.
Das ist diese unglaublich paradoxe Situation, in der sich solche Länder wie
Indonesien befinden und ganz entscheidend dazu ist dann auch der Nickelabbau.
Also er sprach jetzt erstmal so von 10 Gigawatt.
Ich würde sagen, dein Argument aufgegriffen für Afrika, wo er dann bis zum Ende
des Jahrhunderts drei Milliarden mehr Menschen mit Energie versorgen.
Nickel wird gebraucht, man muss da aber auch viel Land roden.
Christina Lu schreibt in Foreign Policy im Februar dieses Jahres folgendes.
Lange bevor die Energiewende weltweit in Schwung kam, träumte das nickelreiche Indonesien davon,
sein Mineralienreichtum zu nutzen, um seine Wirtschaft umzugestalten und auf
dem internationalen Markt mehr Einfluss zu nehmen.
Die weltweite Abkehr von fossilen Brennstoffen und die wachsende Nachfrage nach
wichtigen Mineralien, die für grüne Technologien benötigt werden,
haben Jakartas Ambitionen Auftrieb gegeben. geben.
Nickel ist ein wichtiger Bestandteil von Batterien für Elektrofahrzeuge,
doch nur wenige Länder können einen so großen Anteil am globalen Nickelsocter
für sich beanspruchen wie Indonesien,
das über einige der größten Nickelreserven der Welt verfügt und im Jahr 2022
die Hälfte des weltweiten Angebots abbauen wird.
Das sind ungeheure Zahlen. Wir hören hier mal einen Bericht von France24.
Das würde mehr Jobs erzeugen, aber der nationalen Unabhängigkeitsrate ist noch
ein bisschen höher als es war vor der Pandemie.
In den Regionen, wo diese Investitionen stattfanden, wie Zentral-Sulawesi oder
Nord-Maluku, hat der Präsident gesagt, dass die Nickel-Prozession 71.000 Menschen
und 45.000 Menschen verantwortlich verantwortlich war. Das ist ein riesiger Anstieg, als 2015.
Aber das regionale GDP hat auch zwei Doppeldigitale erhöht. but the poverty
rate actually ticked up last year in both of these provinces.
So it looks like these investments are benefiting only a handful of people and
could potentially hurt other sectors like agriculture because of the impact
nickel mining and processing has on the environment.
And that's why the policy has come under criticism, notably by former Jakarta
Governor Agnes Baswedan,
the challenger to the frontrunner, as we mentioned, Prabowo Subianto,
der die geplante Begrüßung von Joko Widodo hat, um seine ökonomische Politik zu weiterentwickeln.
Wie sehr dieser Nickel-Abbau zugenommen hat, lesen wir auch in Foreign Policy.
Als Jokowi 2014 sein Amt antrat, beliefen sich beispielsweise die indonesischen
Exporte von Ferro-Nickel, einer verarbeiteten Form von Nickel,
auf 83 Millionen Dollar.
Bis 2022 war dieser Wert auf 5,8 Milliarden Dollar explodiert.
Neben den Exporten verzeichnet Indonesien jetzt auch ausländische Direktinvestitionen
in Rekordhöhe, von denen etwa ein Drittel in den Metall- und Bergbausektor des Landes fließt.
Das heißt, zum einen diese Idee, wir machen die grüne Hauptstadt,
zum anderen wird die ganze Zeit dafür gesorgt, dass der Klimawandel schlimmer
wird und damit auch Indonesien mehr betreffen wird.
Und damit wird es eine Situation sein,
bei der man es vermutlich schaffen wird, wie jetzt hier auch in diesen Berichten schon angegangen,
dass man tatsächlich das BIP steigert, dass man wirtschaftlichen Wohlstand einigen
wenigen oder vielleicht auch ein paar mehr Leuten bringt,
man aber zugleich unglaublich viele Verlierer dieser Entwicklung hat,
die zum Beispiel in der Landwirtschaft sind, die jetzt umgesiedelt werden,
deren Lebensgrundlage schlichtweg nicht mehr vorhanden ist.
Und damit sind wir eigentlich hier in Nutsche bei dem, was wir so global erleben,
wenn wir das Verhältnis von Klimawandel und Kapitalismus betrachten.
Und wie dirty diese Arbeit ist, die da geleistet wird, Hören wir jetzt auch
in einen Bericht vom Wall Street Journal.
Wir fahren nach Obi Island, um einen
Riesenblick in einen der größten Nickel-Pflanzen Indiens zu bekommen.
Diese Fabrik ist die Schlüssel in der globalen Nickel-Versorgung.
Indien ist die weltweit größte Produzentin von Metall, ein essentielles Element
für Batterien, die elektrische Fahrzeuge weltweit anbieten.
Aber die Nickel-Fahrzeuge aus dem Boden zu bringen, ist dreckiges Arbeit.
Und die konsumierend-konsumierenden Menschen sind nicht völlig sicher,
wie verletzbar es ist, die Metall zu erhalten.
Warum ist überhaupt Indonesien so beliebt? Klar, die haben große Vorkommen.
Es scheint aber auch sehr einfach zu sein, da Nickel zu gewinnen.
Das bedeutet, dass es relativ günstig ist. Man muss keine großen,
sophisticated Tunnel-Systeme unter dem Boden machen.
Das Problem ist, dass viele von den Nickel-Tunneln mit Bäumen auftreten.
Wenn man also die Lande öffnet, dann öffnet man die Regenbäume.
Zunehmend benutzen Pflanzen einen Prozess, den High-Pressure-Acid-Leaching genannt,
um den Nickel aus dem Öl zu extrahieren, das hier gefunden wird.
Das, was das betrifft, ist, den Nickel zu extrem hohen Temperaturen und hohen
Bedingungen zu vermitteln.
Und das schafft es letztendlich dazu, die in Batterien verwendet werden können.
Dieser Methodus ist um die zweifach so karbonintensiv wie andere Prozesse,
die in Russland oder Kanada verwendet werden, hinter großen Mengen Wäsche.
Zweimal so emissionsintensiv. Es ist doch erschreckend, wenn man mal so ein
bisschen diese deutsche Perspektive verlässt.
Klar, wir diskutieren jetzt Verbrenner ja oder nein, aber wenn man sieht,
welche extremen Umwälzungen da stattfinden und wie sehr man zum einen versucht,
sich in den Wohlstand zu retten, zum anderen aber gezwungen ist,
dadurch den Schaden noch größer zu machen, von dem man selbst am meisten dann noch abbekommt.
Also bei uns ist ja immer noch sehr stark so, wir produzieren hier Dreck oder
kaufen Dinge, die irgendwo anders Dreck produzieren, aber wir haben es noch
nicht so ganz vor der Haustür, geht dann doch noch einigermaßen gut hier klimatisch,
aber dort ist es direkt spürbar.
Das heißt, einfach wieder ein paar Zentimeter weniger Insel, schon wieder was weg.
Wie groß die Unterschiede sind zwischen Nutzen und Folgekosten,
lesen wir in diesem Nature-Artikel im Salon.
Nickel sind natürlich für unsere Batterien. Das sind unsere Autos, die hier rumfahren.
Ja, also wir sind natürlich Teil des Problems und es gibt diese große Indonesien-Strategie für 2045.
Präsident Widodo, it aims to make the country the fifth largest economy in the world by 2045.
The current capital Jakarta is on the island of Java.
Over 150 million people live there. That's more than half the total population of Indonesia.
In den letzten Jahren wurden sie geholfen, die Dominanz von Indonésien,
ihre ökonomische Aktivität und Entwicklungsmöglichkeiten zu reduzieren und sie
mehr gleichermaßen zwischen ihren anderen Inseln zu teilen.
Es wird glaubt, dass das Rückliegen der Kapitalstadt von Jakarta nach Kalimantan
ein neues ökonomisches Zentrum der Gravitas in der Mitte von Indonesien wird
und die java-zentrische Anwendung von Indonésien wird.
Dass man solche Jet Peas,
werden die genannt, einführt, also dass die reichen Länder oder Investoren dieser
reichen Länder solche Finanzierungen machen oder Kredite dafür geben,
dass die Länder früher aus einer emissionsintensiven Industrie aussteigen.
Und es gab dazu eine Diskussion beim World Economic Forum, da war Bill Winters zu Gast,
das war im Winter und er ist CEO von der Standard Chartered Bank und sagt aber
folgendes, was uns noch einmal zum Schluss desillusionieren soll.
Zusammen mit der Privatsektorpartizipation. Nun, niemand weiß,
wie diese Kredite funktionieren werden.
Wer wird für Indonesien bezahlen, um seine 40-jährige Kohlfeuer-Power-Pflanze 20 Jahre zu schützen?
Wir wissen alle, dass jemand bezahlen sollte. Es ist eine gute Sache, es ist eine gute Kredit.
Aber es gibt keinen Mechanismus für das. Wenn wir das richtig machen,
in diesem einen Fall in Indonesien, mit einem öffentlich-privaten Partnerschaft,
hat Singapur gesagt, wir kaufen diese Kredite.
Das sollten wir hundertenmal replizieren können. Natürlich, wenn du am ersten
Pass verlierst, dann kriegst du keinen zweiten Schuss.
Das ist ein Beispiel von einigen Dingen, die wir machen können.
Wir können eigentlich repeatable Events machen, wenn wir sie in der ersten Ordnung richtig machen.
Haben, wobei Schweden ja sehr
viel Nickel hat, weshalb auch in Schweden Firmengründungen stattfanden.
Also es ist eine Geschichte von zwei Top-Managern, Peter Carlson und Paolo Cerrutti.
Die haben damals die Gigafactory One für Tesla in Nevada mitgeplant und gebaut.
2013 geplant, 2014 gebaut. Da rollten also die ersten Teslas rum,
haben ja die ganze Welt für viel Aufregung gesorgt.
Damals wurden 5 Milliarden investiert und wir wissen ja, dass Tesla dann eine
der, die fünfte One Trillion Company wurde, was Marktkapitalisierung angeht,
war also eine Erfolgsgeschichte.
Und das Ziel von Nevada war damals für Tesla, mehr Batteriekapazität herzustellen,
als die ganze Welt Batteriekapazität herstellt. Und das wurde damals auch erreicht.
Und diese beiden, Peter und Paolo, haben sich dann gedacht, das brauchen wir auch für Europa.
Und dann haben sie Northvolt gegründet, haben also nach dem Aufbau der Gigafactory
One, Tesla verlassen, sind nach Europa zurück.
PETA kommt ja aus Schweden und dann haben sie Investoren gesammelt,
zum Beispiel ABB, Vestat, Scania, kennt man soweit so ein bisschen, große Autohersteller.
Siemens, BMW, Volkswagen, Goldman Sachs natürlich, Volksam und so weiter.
Es gab große Kooperationen sogar schon mit Volkswagen in Salzgitter,
Salzgitter, da ist ja ein großes Motorenwerk von VW und sie wollten hier oder
haben Gigafactories gebaut.
Die erste davon in Schweden.
Damals 60 Gigawattstunden Produktion.
Nee, die erste in Schweden hatte 30 Gigawattstunden Batteriekapazität pro Jahr,
war also auf Augenhöhe mit der Factory One, Gigafactory One von Tesla.
Und dann haben sie in elf Finanzierungsrunden 56 Investoren gefunden,
die ihnen insgesamt 7,5 Milliarden Dollar gegeben haben für das Ziel,
Europa energieautark zu machen, was die Batterieproduktion angeht.
Vorher war also die Idee, das kaufen wir einfach aus China zu und dann hat man
gesagt, nee, wir brauchen eigentlich mehr.
Und die Firma der beiden heißt Northvolt und ist bis heute eigentlich eine große Erfolgsgeschichte.
Wir haben sie jetzt zuletzt mitbekommen, weil sie nach einer Gigafactory in
Kanada mit 60 Gigawattstunden,
Batteriekapazität und noch einer in Schweden mit 100 Gigawatt,
also sehr viel größer dann schon als Teslas größter, aber Tesla baut ja jetzt
gerade in Mexiko wieder die allergrößte der Welt und so weiter.
Jetzt gibt es auch einen in In Schleswig-Holstein. Das war ja ein ganz großer
Termin. Daniel Günther war da, Olaf Scholz war da, man hat zusammen irgendwelche
schwedischen Spiele gespielt und so weiter.
Und insgesamt geht es um ein Investitionsvolumen von 5 Milliarden Euro,
wobei der deutsche Staat 900 Millionen bezahlt, damit diese Batteriefabrik da entsteht.
Warum in Schleswig-Holstein?
Weil dort die Windenergie ist. Das große Ziel von Northvolt ist zum einen zum
Beispiel Batterien ohne Nickel bauen.
Das haben sie jetzt im Herbst letzten Jahres vorgestellt, dass sie jetzt Batterien
ohne Nickel und noch ein paar andere Sachen herstellen, die auf Augenhöhe sind
mit den Batterien, die man braucht
und die zum Beispiel auch schon in den Porsches und so weiter drin sind.
Sind, also wenn man heute einen Porsche kauft, einen elektrischen,
dann sind das schon Batterien, die da aus Schweden von Northvolt kamen und so.
Also großes Investitionsanliegen auf Augenhöhe mit Tesla, aber in diesem europäischen
Sinne, Autos bauen brauchen wir nicht, es geht nur um die Batterien.
Das mit dem Autobauen, das schaffen die schon alleine, BMW ist ja jetzt,
der verkündet, 2027 der letzte Verbrenner aus München oder in Bayern,
der da gebaut wird und so weiter und so fort.
Und dann nur ein kleiner Snippet, viel Unbehagen und so weiter bei den Leuten
vor Ort in Schleswig-Holstein zum Beispiel.
Hier mal ein Traktorfahrer, also ein Landwirt, den ich nur mal beispielhaft bringe dafür.
Na gut, wir hören ihn mal an und schätzen das danach mal ein.
7.30 Uhr, heute Morgen im Landkreis Dittmarschen in Schleswig-Holstein.
Landwirt Arne Gerdau will seinen Traktor von der Reparatur abholen.
Direkt neben der Werkstatt für Landmaschinen ist heute offizieller Baustart
für eine riesige Hightech-Fabrik für E-Auto-Batterien.
Dass irgendwas gemacht werden muss in der Industrie ist ganz klar.
Aber es geht immer darauf, wie und wie schnell.
Und auch Norswold ist ja nun keine Fabrik, die nun schon zig Jahre auf dem Markt besteht.
Wo lange gibt es die Firma ja noch gar nicht. Da ist auch die Frage,
wo geht das überhaupt hin?
So, er sagt, so lange gibt es die Firma ja noch gar nicht. mein Traktor ist
älter als diese Firma, ich bin skeptisch.
Und wir denken uns so, ja, die Skepsis ist irgendwie aus was auch immer für
Erwägungen begründet, aber sie ist grundfalsch.
Denn wenn wir eine Investition haben, die heute stattfindet,
und das ist von Firmenleuten, die schon gezeigt haben, dass sie es können.
Und wann begann das? Du hast ja eben vorgelesen, das war...
Ja, also das ist jetzt 2014 haben die Tesla fertig Dings gebaut da,
und dann sind sie 2016 haben sie dann Northvolt gegründet.
Seit 2019 oder 2020 bauen die jetzt Batterien. Also so fünf Jahre haben die jetzt auf dem Buckel.
Nur, man muss halt immer sehen, man muss halt immer sehen.
Große finanzielle Budgetentscheidungen in der Politik. Wenn sie neu sind,
sind sie immer durchdacht.
Da haben die Leute, die jetzt gerade im Bundestag sitzen und dort Fragen stellen,
den wissenschaftlichen Dienst beschäftigen, was auch immer, das haben die gestern gemacht.
Wenn es heute darum geht, 900 Millionen auszuzahlen, dann haben die das gestern gemacht.
Alle, die da in Verantwortung sind, haben das jetzt gerade in ihrem Alltag gehabt.
Ältere finanzielle Budgetentscheidungen, wie zum Beispiel diese ganzen Dieselsubventionen,
Das haben irgendwelche Leute entschieden, die sind schon gar nicht mehr im Bundestag.
Das ist aus einer Zeit, da war die Welt noch in Ordnung.
Wenn wir also etwas hinterfragen, dann sollten wir die alten Entscheidungen nehmen.
Und dann können wir nicht einfach einen traktorfahrenden Bauer hernehmen,
der sagt, ne, die gibt es ja noch gar nicht so lange, ich verstehe das nicht,
ich akzeptiere das nicht.
Das Problem ist, wenn solche Leute es einfach im Rahmen ihrer Alltagshorizonte
sagen, Können wir sagen, okay, ist ja kein Problem.
Im demokratischen Gefüge haben das eben Leute entschieden, die irgendwie dachten,
das wäre vielleicht ganz gut, wenn wir erstens Batterien haben,
zweitens welche ohne Nickel und so weiter und so fort.
Und ganz wichtig, wenn wir das in Schleswig-Holstein bauen, weil da nämlich
der Wind weht, denn eins der großen Ziele von Northvolt ist,
egal wo, in Polen, in Kanada, in Schweden, in Deutschland,
in Portugal, da wird jetzt überall diese Gigafactories gebaut. baut.
Wir nehmen nur den Strom, der durch erneuerbare Energie kommt.
Und so sage ich jetzt mal, etwas horizontbeschränkt wie dieser Bauer,
den wir da eben gehört haben.
Hat sich Markus Söder verhalten. Denn diese Batteriefabriken gehören natürlich
nach Bayern. Da, wo auch die Autos hergestellt werden.
Und wir wissen alle noch, vor zehn Jahren gab es diese riesige Diskussion, Südling zu bauen.
Wurde nicht gemacht, weil irgendwelche Landwirte gesagt haben,
nee, hier keine Stromleitung, das ist alles blöd und so weiter.
Und jetzt ist eine der größten, wenn nicht sogar die größte Industrieinvestition
der letzten Jahrzehnte einfach an Bayern vorbeigegangen.
Weil Markus Söder Quatschpolitik gemacht hat.
Irgendwelche Pandas, irgendwelche Ostereier, irgendwelche, die bayerische Landschaft
wird nicht zerstört und so.
Und wir können uns ja Keine Windräder?
Genau, keine Windräder. Und wir können uns jetzt ungefähr vorstellen,
dadurch, dass diese 10 Gigawatt Strom, die man für sowas braucht,
jetzt einfach im Norden wehen.
Und da jetzt auch die Batterien hergestellt werden. Und das nicht nur eine Investition
ist für eine Batteriefabrik, sondern die ganze Infrastruktur und die ganze Industrie
drumherum wird jetzt auch da oben entstehen.
Wenn 2027 dann BMW ernst macht und sagt, ab jetzt keine Verbrenner mehr,
die in Deutschland hergestellt werden, vielleicht auch in so einem Werk in Mexiko
oder so, aber nicht mehr in Deutschland.
Und die werden ein Werk erweitern oder neu bauen oder was auch immer. Wo werden die das bauen?
Also wir haben ja im Long-Termism-Buch diese Idee bekommen von,
es gibt, manchmal sind es Jahrhunderte und man denkt, alles ist normal und biologisch
und gottgegeben und wie auch immer, das ist halt die Natur der Dinge.
Und dann wird aber plötzlich eine Entscheidung getroffen, die alles aufhebt,
die aus festesten Institutionen und so weiter ganz weiche Strukturen macht und
die ganz flexibel plötzlich sind.
Und ich glaube, es ist jetzt wirklich das Jahrhundertereignis passiert,
dass eine der größten grundsteinlegenden Industrieentscheidungen gegen Bayern
für Norddeutschland stattfindet.
Einfach nur, weil die Bayern zu blöd waren, rechtzeitig eine Stromleitung zu legen.
Ja, und da sehen wir ja im Kleinen oder im Speziellen, was gerade diese große
Auseinandersetzung ist.
Also es gibt eigentlich jetzt grob gesagt gerade zwei Kapitalismen.
Es gibt den der alten Industrie mit alten Partikularinteressen,
mit CDU und FDP, die versuchen diese Partikularinteressen weiterhin zu schützen.
Und dann gibt es einen neuen Kapitalismus, der sich zum Beispiel so ausnimmt,
wie du es jetzt beschrieben hast im Norden Deutschlands und jetzt nur die cleveren
Leute verstehen beides miteinander irgendwie zu kombinieren,
weil man natürlich mit beiden auch noch Geschäft machen kann.
In dem aber gerade Söder und andere in einem Entweder-Oder-Sinn im Prinzip ja
auch ein Großteil der FDP.
Verlieren die natürlich total den Anschluss an diese neue Megaindustrie,
das heißt nicht nur Anschluss an diese Investitionen, sondern Anschluss auch
an eine ganz große Wählerklientel, die natürlich dann sich auch nicht mehr davon
locken lässt, dass irgendwie der Verbrenner bleibt, weil die sagen ja hier ist
ja alles mit diesen neuen Batterien und so gemacht.
Und das ist ganz erstaunlich, die AfD, da kann man es studieren,
wir haben es ja heute mal ausnahmsweise muss man sagen ausführlich gemacht,
hat da den Anschluss völlig verloren,
also die erreichen noch nicht mal mehr die alte Industrie, also mit denen ist
gar nichts zu machen und hier bei der CDU erleben wir, dass das alles aufgrund
eines Kulturkampfes, den man ja parallel führen will,
alles hochpolitisch aufgeladen ist, wo einfach nur die Vernunft einem sagen könnte,
naja es scheint schon eine ganz clevere Sache zu sein, wenn man da investiert.
Genau. Also die Entscheidung, Südlink jetzt doch mal zu bauen,
ist jetzt getroffen. Jetzt muss aber erstmal drei Jahre geplant werden und dann drei Jahre gebaut.
Also vor 2030 ist da nichts.
Es könnte sein, nachdem es, und das ist ganz witzig, Northvolt nennt die dann
immer Gigafactory und dann das schwedische 1, das polnische 2,
das deutsche 3 und so, gehen jetzt durchs Portugal, kriegt glaube ich die 4., Kanada dann die 5.
Und so weiter. Es könnte sein, dass dann Nummer 11 oder so auch in Bayern in
zehn Jahren, aber bis dahin geht die ganze industrielle Entwicklung an Bayern vorbei.
Also wirklich ganz erstaunlich, was für ein grotesker Fehler das einfach war,
die ganze letzten, also das ganze letzte Jahrzehnt so identitätspolitisch zu machen.
Also allenfalls mal rettet die Bienen, achso da gab es eine Mehrheit,
okay ich bin jetzt auch ein Bienenretter und dann doch wieder auf diesen,
wir bekämpfen jetzt mal AfD und sind die noch rechteren Rechten und so weiter, da einzuschwenken.
Also an Bayern ist hier richtig was vorbeigegangen und es ist böder anzulasten.
Diese Parallelität hat, also man hat zum einen die alte Industrie,
die man braucht, um jetzt die entsprechenden Energiekapazitäten zu haben,
zugleich die Vision einer neuen Stadt.
Man ist also tief gefangen im Widerspruch des Kapitalismus und muss sich in
gewisser Weise Selbstlebens und andere Grundlagen nehmen.
Während man in Deutschland aufgrund der komfortablen geografischen Situation,
aufgrund des Reichtums eigentlich diese Parallelität für erfahren kann,
ohne sich wirklich das Wasser abzugraben im wortwörtlichen Sinne,
wie das in Indonesien der Fall ist.
Ja, aber trotzdem nimmt man das nicht in
Kauf, sondern führt lieber eine Identitätspolitik bis aufs Messer durch.
Diese wirklich lebensbedrohliche Gleichzeitigkeit, wie sie in Indonesien vorherrscht, die haben wir nicht.
Wir machen uns die Probleme ganz klar selbst dadurch, dass wir uns in einen
völlig absurden Kulturkampf begeben.
Und ja, jetzt sieht man aber am Ende, wer der Leidtragende ist,
nämlich dann Bayern, weil sie die Investitionen nicht erhalten.
So, und wir beschließen den Podcast mit den zwei Themen, mit denen Söder meinte,
ich muss mal meine Bayern beschäftigen. Thema Nummer eins, Cannabis.
Wir haben ja alle mitbekommen, das CDF vermeldet, Volksfeste und Biergärten
in Bayern, Kiffen streng verboten.
Denken wir, okay, da gibt es irgendwie ein Cannabis-Verbot oder was ist denn da los und so.
Stellt sich raus, nein, auf Volksfesten in Biergärten und in Außengeländen von
Gaststätten wird es irgendwie irgendwann mal ein Verbot geben.
Das muss noch geregelt werden.
Bislang haben sich die Bayern da noch nicht herangetraut, weil am Ende sind
das ja Gesetze, die gegen Bundesgesetze und so weiter und ob die Länder da so Hoheit haben.
Dann klagt noch jemand dagegen und man will sich eigentlich nicht,
man wollte ja nur mal eine Pointe machen vor Publikum.
So, stellt sich raus, das Cannabis-Verbot im Englischen Garten,
im Hofgarten und im Finanzgarten wird geregelt über die Hausordnung,
weil das nämlich Liegenschaften des Landes Bayern sind.
So, da werden also keine Gesetze und
keine Verbote, das ist einfach ein Hausordnungseintrag, von dem ich denke,
naja, wenn man erstmal anfängt, dass in Biergärten die Biergartenbetreiber darüber
befinden können, das stinkt uns doch ein bisschen zu sehr, wenn hier die ganze
Zeit gekifft wird, regelt sich das schon von alleine.
Weil relativ viele einfach sagen, nee, das nervt hier irgendwie.
Ihr könnt gerne kämpfen, aber nicht hier.
Nehmt euer Bier to go mit oder wie auch immer.
Das Schlimmere finde ich noch, dass beim Genderverbot Gleiches gilt.
Also wir hatten das Cannabisverbot, okay, machen die Bayern jetzt wie sie wollen. Das Genderverbot.
Ich lese mal von der Webseite der GEW, also der Gewerkschaft für Erziehung und
Wissenschaft, die ja Schulen und so weiter, die da jetzt betroffen sind,
mitbetreut, gewerkschaftlicherseits.
Der Bayerische Ministerrat hat Regelungen zur geschlechtergerechten Sprache
in den Behörden des Freistaats beschlossen.
Was ja bedeutet, der Bayerische Ministerrat, wie und was, also gibt es überhaupt
ein Gesetz oder was? Ne, das ist auch wieder nur Hausordnung.
Man hat einfach die Hoheit über diese Gelände und sagt dann,
ja, in einer Schule gilt jetzt folgendes in der Hausordnung.
Und dann ist die GEW so frech und schreibt dann auf ihrer Seite,
was bedeutet das Genderverbot für die SchülersternchenInnen und Studierende?
Bei Schülerinnen wird die Verwendung der unzulässigen Wortbinnenzeichen bei
schriftlichen Leistungsnachweisen als sogenannte Normabweichung markiert.
Das bedeutet, dass Lehrkräfte diese zu markieren haben, aber die gendergerechte
Schreibweise nicht in die Bewertung einfließt. Warum?
Wenn sie in die Bewertung einfließt, klagen die Eltern.
Und diesen Klagen können sie nicht standhalten. Sie wissen genau,
wenn wir das so regeln, dass es sanktioniert wird, dann zerfliegt uns das.
Und man hat jetzt den Lehrern nur die Aufgabe aufgebürdet, das nochmal alles schön anzuschreißen.
Sie müssen das nochmal markieren, aber bitte keine Punkte, sonst gibt es Ärger.
Also es ist so ganz halb gar. Was droht, wenn mich als Lehrerin ich mich nicht daran halte?
Das ist noch unklar. Es ist durchaus vorstellbar, dass die Nicht-Einhaltung
in der Beurteilung einfließt und oder disziplinarische Konsequenzen nach sich zieht.
Also dadurch, dass man ja über die Liegenschaft und auch über das Personal den
Einfluss hat, ist es bei Lehrern unklar.
Also bei Schülern, sie dürfen weiter irgendwie schreiben, mal gucken,
da werden einfach so Markierungen gemacht.
Bei Lehrern kann durchaus zu irgendwelchen disziplinarischen Maßnahmen führen,
kommt drauf an, wie der Schulleiter drauf ist oder wer da und so weiter, was dagegen hat.
Also es ist völlig irre, aber sehr gut, dass die beiden da beschäftigt wurden.
Und schlimmer, weil wir hier gerade in Hessen sind, in Hessen gibt es auch ein Genderverbot.
Mhm.
Das allerdings ist wirklich gesetzlich geregelt. Wir hören hier mal in H2,
es ist nicht mehr H2 der Tag, soll man sagen, sondern es ist der Tag vom HR oder irgendwie so.
Hier werden nun wirkliche Fehler markiert. Also es führt zu Punktabzügen,
wenn Schülerinnen gendern.
Studierende dürfen also gespannt sein, ob Gender-Sonderzeichen für sie in Zukunft
tabu sind, sagt unser landespolitischer Korrespondent Nikolaus Buschlüter.
Und er hat uns inzwischen auch berichtet, was der hessische Kultusminister Armin
Schwarz von der CDU im Kulturpolitischen Ausschuss des Landtages auf Fragen
zum Thema geantwortet hat.
Der Minister hat dabei unter anderem gesagt, dass beim mündlichen Abitur auch
in Zukunft der Glottisschlag, also die Pause mitten im Wort, erlaubt sei.
Dass es aber im Schriftlichen nicht als Wiederholungsfehler gewertet würde,
wenn im selben Text zum Beispiel die Wörter LehrerInnen, SchülerInnen und DemonstrantInnen
vorkommen, sondern dass dann tatsächlich drei Fehler angestrichen würden.
Nur wenn sich der Wortstamm nicht ändert, also bei dreimal LehrerInnen,
wäre es ein Wiederholungsfehler, der nur einmal gewertet wird.
Grundsätzlich halten wir fest, der hessische Ministerpräsident will nicht,
dass Klausuren und Hausarbeiten schlechter bewertet werden, wenn darin keine
Genderzeichen vorkommen. Und was macht er daraufhin?
Er führt eine Regel ein, nach der Klausuren und Hausarbeiten nun womöglich schlechter
bewertet werden, wenn darin Genderzeichen vorkommen.
Ist das logisch oder eher ideologisch?
Nicht logisch, es ist völlig grotesk und die Hessen haben hier einen großen
Fehler gemacht, weil das wird natürlich im Grunde Boden geklagt und am Ende
steht die Landesregierung so ein bisschen bescheuer da. Was heißt das aber für die Lehre?
Das Genderverbot sei das falsche Signal zur falschen Zeit, sagt Emilia.
Gendern sei jetzt plötzlich auf einer Ebene mit Spicken.
Gegenüber dem HR kritisieren auch Lehrerinnen das Verbot.
Als Staatsbeamtinnen drohen ihnen Sanktionen, wenn sie politische Entscheidungen
öffentlich kommentieren.
Deswegen haben die Lehrerinnen für diesen Beitrag um Anonymität gebeten.
Ihre Stimmen haben wir nachgesprochen.
Mich hat das Genderverbot ratlos zurückgelassen. Außer dem Verbot gibt es keinen Handlungshinweis.
Im Schreiben werde ich das Sternchen nicht mehr nutzen können.
Im Sprechen ist es eine Grauzone.
Bisher sei es so gewesen, dass manche ihrer Kollegen gendern, andere nicht.
Man habe sich darüber ausgetauscht im Kollegium, aber einen Klärungsbedarf habe niemand gesehen.
Das sei mit dem Genderverbot jetzt anders.
Jetzt gibt es eine Verunsicherung, die gab es vorher nicht. Wenn ich doch Sonderzeichen
nutzen sollte, würde ich wahrscheinlich ein Gespräch mit der Schulleitung bekommen
oder ein Vermerk in der Personalakte. Das kann etwa in einem Bewerbungsprozess
schon zu einem Problem werden.
Es gäbe außerdem derzeit ganz andere Probleme, mit denen sich die Landesregierung
mal beschäftigen müsste, kritisiert die Frankfurter Lehrerin.
Hört, hört.
Ja.
Das kennt man doch eigentlich sonst nur von Dissidenten aus China,
wenn die interviewt werden, dass die auch nicht so einfach vor eine Kamera oder vor ein Mikro können.
Tja, das sind absurde Zustände und ich finde es auch strategisch jetzt von konservativer
Seite so dumm, weil man natürlich dadurch das Gendern zu einem heroischen Akt stilisiert.
Da natürlich jetzt die Dissidenz gefragt ist, also man hätte es natürlich eher
ignorieren müssen oder sagen müssen,
wir müssen dafür sorgen, dass weiterhin alles möglich ist, also dass auch der
Text, der nicht gegendert ist, weiterhin nicht falsch ist, das ist ja irgendwo nachvollziehbar.
Alles darüber hinaus macht das Ständern zum heroischen Akt, sorgt also dafür.
Dass man jetzt dem höhere Wein verliehen hat.
Also genau das, was man eigentlich nicht wollte und was ja auch wirklich unsinnig ist.
Und insofern würde ich vorschlagen, wir vertragen uns auf den Teaser,
sprechen dann nochmal über das Thema Canceln von allen Seiten.
Mir scheint es doch nochmal wichtig zu sein, wir machen ja eigentlich nicht
so Kulturkampf, sondern einfach nochmal um die ganze Absurdität dort sichtbar zu machen,
wie weit es jetzt übrigens auch im politischen Diskurs da schon gekommen ist,
wenn es um Leute geht, die bei Wahlkampfveranstaltungen von Politikern auftauchen.
Aber wir wollen jetzt zum Schluss nochmal darauf hinweisen, dass wir über dieses
Buch sprechen, Demokratiedämmerung von Veit Selck.
Wir wollen gucken, was da dämmert, ob noch etwas zu retten ist,
was ist mit der Demokratie.
Wir sind damit gut vorbereitet, einmal auf die Wahlen im Osten,
auf die Europawahl und dann einen Monat später sprechen wir dann über das Geopolitikbuch
von Richard David Precht. Also da geht es ja dann auch um Demokratie versus Autokratie.
Und ich frage dich, welche Texte wirst du uns noch präsentieren?
Wir lesen den großen Text der
New York Times, in dem sie behandeln mehrere Autoren wie die Autorinnen.
AI-Unternehmen an Datengrenzen stoßen und was sie so alles tun.
Es ist der größte Raub in der Geschichte. Ich schließe mich dieser Meinung an.
Außerdem hat Nature diesen sehr großen Artikel veröffentlicht,
der ein Jahr im Peer Review war, was auch immer so lange gedauert hat,
über die Ökonomie des Klimawandels.
Also wir schließen an der Indonesia in Sachen an.
Wie werden die Schäden verteilt und vor allem, wie stehen die Schäden,
auf die man sich schon geeinigt hat?
Denn das 2 Grad Ziel ist ja kein 1,500 Grad Ziel, sondern im Verhältnis zu den
Kosten, die auflaufen, weil wir es nicht einhalten.
Da liegen so mehrere Faktoren dazwischen. Außerdem Ben Bernanke.
Der wurde beauftragt, ließ sich beauftragen von der Bank of England,
die Bank im internationalen Vergleich, zum Beispiel mit der EZB oder der FED,
zu bewerten, wie man mit der Prognosegenauigkeit ist, BIP und einiges,
unter anderem auch Inflation.
Wir gucken insbesondere in diesen kleinen Abschnitt.
Und wir haben ja heute leider nicht über diese Bonn-Rede von Macron geredet.
Sie liegt auch nicht auf Deutsch vor.
Es gibt aber ein offizielles französisches PDF, das ich natürlich dann jetzt
einfach mal mit DeepL übersetze.
Damit wir zumindest die markanten Stellen, wie zum Beispiel sollte man nicht
die EZB jetzt auch mal mit einem Mandat für Wirtschaftswachstum und ökologische Wende ausstatten.
Ein paar interessante Ideen, die da drin stecken. Macron hat ja gestern nochmal
nachgelegt und in einer Anmerkung darauf hingewiesen, dass man durchaus bereit
ist, ganz offiziell die französischen Atomwaffen zu europäisieren.
Er hat sofort von allen Rechten auf den Deckel bekommen dafür.
Die französische Atommacht ist natürlich nicht veräußerbar, aber er legt jetzt
tatsächlich die Karten auf den Tisch und will einfach mal sehen,
was die anderen dazu sagen.
Wahrscheinlich auch, weil wenn Trump dann gewählt ist, möchte er sagen können,
An mir lag es nicht. Ich habe es euch gesagt.
Ihr wolltet nicht, dass es sich zumindest mal so ein gutes Gewissen macht.
Ich werde einen Roman vorstellen, in dem sich eine Angestellte in einer doch
sehr persönlichen Beziehung zu einem
Drucker befindet, weil sie mit ihren Arbeitskollegen wenig anfangen kann.
Also wir haben da einen modernen Angestelltenroman.
Außerdem gibt es einen interessanten Artikel mit der Überschrift Keiner...
Kauft Bücher, nämlich über diese große Verhandlung zwischen Peng Juin und Schuster.
Was ist da eigentlich in den USA gelaufen und was erfahren wir da über das Bestsellerwesen
und all die Vorschüsse, die so gezahlt werden.
Auch noch eine sehr hübsche Randbemerkung zu den Obama-Büchern.
Und dann habe ich noch weiter vor einen Text vorzustellen über die deutschen
Thinktanks, warum die so merkwürdig sind, also es ist einiges dabei.
Und wir wollen nochmal darauf hinweisen, diesen Salon kann man ganz einfach
abonnieren, wir freuen uns auch, wenn ihr das tut,
nämlich das ist am besten möglich über neue20er.de da ist ein goldener Button
rechts oben, da kommt man zum Salon, dann Dann kann man sich bei Steady anmelden,
auch das ist alles selbsterklärend, sehr einfach.
Man muss aber dann nicht vor seinem Desktop sitzen und diesen Podcast aufrufen
und dort hören, sondern man kann den Podcast, also den Bezahl-Podcast,
den Salon, dann immer so hören, wie man sonst diesen Podcast gerade jetzt hört,
also mit seinem persönlichen Podcatcher.
Und wer uns lieber über Apple hören will, weil das so schön praktisch ist,
uns darüber zu buchen, der kann das natürlich auch machen. Auch das ist ganz
einfach dann über Apple, das einfach dort anzuklicken.
Wer schon einen Patreon-Account hat, kann dort auch den Podcast abonnieren und
wer über Spotify in den Salon kommen will,
der tut das auch über Steady quasi, aber wird von Spotify direkt dahin geleitet,
wenn man dort auf den entsprechenden Button klickt.
Ja, Spotify ist ja ein beliebter Player, aus Nutzersicht verständlich,
aus Anbietersicht ein bisschen fragwürdig, aber man kann durchaus den Salon mit Spotify hören.
Ja und nochmal zum Schluss der Hinweis oder die Bitte vielmehr,
wir freuen uns sehr, wenn der Podcast weiterempfohlen wird, geteilt wird,
gut bewertet wird und dann sehen wir uns nächste Woche im Salon.